learn how to use next.js to create full
stack web apps in this course you will
create a project that also uses mongodb
and apprite a test chowdery developed
this course hitesh is a software
engineer and a popular technical course
creator let's get started hey there
everyone my name is hitesh and I'll be
your instructor for this really long and
very up-to-date next JS course nextges
is an amazing framework which actually
helps you to build a full stack
application yes you write your backend
in the next JS you write your front end
in the next JS and don't you worry your
back end is just because it is written
in JavaScript it doesn't get exposed to
the client side all the backend that you
write in next.js is rendered only on the
servers and all the front end that you
write it that is getting rendered on the
client side it's a fantastic framework
to work with it it's growing rapidly
like anything I'll walk you through with
that but before we go further you need
to know some things first of all I'll be
your instructor my name is Satish and I
make tons of videos on YouTube do
consider checking out my channel as well
in case you get some time otherwise no
problem at all now the way I have
designed this entire series of next
year's videos is because next year's got
a revamp there is now a new app
directory the API folders and how we
write the things so I wanted to keep
everything up to date if you're watching
any past tutorials they are either being
made outdated or they'll not no longer
good so we need to work on that now
apart from this there are some
prerequisite that you should be aware of
it and there's a mindset also that you
also need to be aware nexius is a
framework so first of all understand
that there are certain rules and
regulation that you have to follow that
comes up with every single framework and
especially the file names how the
directories are being structured how the
file names are structured next.js is a
file based routing system that it uses
behind the scene so every single file
name and everything which I've walked
you through with quite in detail with
the diagrams and everything so make sure
you take care of that another important
thing is next year since it's a
framework built on top of react.js
definitely it uses react so your react
Foundation should be decent I'm not
saying you need to be expert in that you
will learn a lot of things on the go as
well but yeah it's built on react so
obviously you need a basics of react
since it's a full stack framework I also
expect that you have worked a little bit
on the API building as well I don't
expect you to be an expert in that but
make sure you have decent basics in it
because we'll be writing some apis we'll
be creating some apis as well so a
little bit Foundation is expected but do
I don't expect too much you will
understand everything every single code
that I'm writing now along with this uh
one more request that I have the way I
have built this entire project is
actually divided into two phases first
we understand the next shares and do
everything Hands-On means we'll be
writing our own uh back end we'll be
using mongodb and all of that and the
second portion is dependent on some
service we'll be using one service known
as apprite which is totally open source
and will be using their Cloud to
actually see that how when their backend
is being written by somewhere else how
you can utilize those things in this
case we are using app right but your
backend might be in Java maybe Django
fast API anything so that portion covers
that now I expect and I also see that
make sure you understand that
authentication is really amazing thing
and it's not like we are only learning
authentication in this entire series see
in the authentication you collect some
data from the user and then you send
this data to to the to the back end your
database this is exactly what you do
when you're building any other model
your product category everything so a
lot of people think that authentication
is different to do app is different in
this case I have merged it all I've gone
through with all the complicated cases
that how you'll be collecting the user
data in this case the sign up data I
will be sending it and making a
connection on the mongodb send the data
make some queries filter out the data
collect this so this is fantastic also
there are two videos which are optional
but in case you are not aware of it I'll
also walk you through with that so make
sure you understand that part so in this
entire series I haven't actually walked
you through with like apps absolute
scratch because we already did a live
stream here I don't know an xjs live
stream which was almost around a one
hour of live stream where we went into
the documentation of next year's how to
read the documentation how to study it
how the file rest file based routing
works the error files how you can have
the middlewares and all of that so this
actually covers all of that in the
series itself I have actually skipped
that part that's one thing the second
thing is since it's next year's there
are some Basics that you need to know
especially like what is CSR SSR the
client-side rendering server side
rendering incremental rendering there's
some jargons which are absolutely
hundred percent Theory so I've already
created a video about it so make sure
you simply go ahead and check it out
this one here I have not included them
in the series because I thought that's
too optional for this one and we'll be
starting the series fresh every single
code is available on GitHub as well so
make sure you check it out as well so
that's it now let's get started with the
very first video let's start the Journey
of the latest next.js
hey there everyone hitesh here back
again with another video and I would
like to welcome all of you into this
really long and hopefully really long
next JS course I wouldn't be calling it
as the next year's crash course because
it's not a crash course it doesn't just
give you overview but it's a real world
production grade application that you
can deploy and can use in the real world
this application is specially designed
in such a way that it provides you a
path to learn nexjs absolutely from
scratch I'll give you the prerequisite
as well but the goal was not to just
teach next years but to teach it in
certain way that you feel absolutely
confident about building application
using nexjs I want to lay down the
entire architecture of nexgs in such an
easy manner that you feel that it's like
a walk in the park no longer afraid of
being app directory and Source directory
and all those jargons you will be able
to dive deep into the actual
documentation of the next shares if you
find any problem you will be able to
tweak it out now this application is
decently complex so we need to pick up a
tech stack I will choose that I will
also give you the prerequisites and
everything that is required I'm pretty
sure you are excited to build this
application with me this application one
more very important thing this
application will lay as a foundational
block of some of my upcoming tutorials
in the future as well as if you are
trying to make any application which is
really really complex in next year's
this will lay down a solid foundation
for you so everything is all set up and
I'm pretty sure you are all excited
about getting started with the next
shares along with me this is going to be
one of the best ride and again trust me
you will have so much of confidence
that's my goal bring confidence in you
so that you can build application and
again even if you are not that much
confidence in building a full stack
application no worries I'm here I'll
walk you through with each and every
word that we are going to write no copy
pasting of the code we'll be writing
everything down and I'll explain you
every single logic that is required for
that so I hope you are excited for that
now first let me tell you what are the
tech stack and what are the prerequisite
for that let's start with the
prerequisite now this entire next.js
application is built in typescript but
again if you are not much familiar with
the typescript that is totally okay I am
not using any a crucial part of the
typescript which is making it just for
typescript people if you know JavaScript
that is also fine you will be able to
understand hundred percent of the code
so there is no too much higher
dependency of the typescript if you know
it that's great otherwise I do have a
series on typescript as well you can
watch that otherwise it's not that much
of a hard and fast requirement
on top of that nexjs is a framework
which is built on top of a library known
as react.js everybody's favorite now
react.js is amazing but I don't expect
that you have 100 knowledge of react.js
if you know how to just use a simple
user State use effect and just can write
some buttons in next year in the
react.js that is all that is all but if
you don't know even that much that's
also totally fine I'll still try to
explain you some of the bits and pieces
of it but I would certainly say that the
experience of react.js would be super
helpful in this series and that is it
now I don't expect you to have too much
knowledge on the back end part I just
expect you have heard about some of the
backends and stuff this would be also a
great starting guide for you to
understand about the database that we
will be using which will be mongodb in
this case everything that we are writing
in this in this entire example and this
entire app is fully productionable so
you will be able to put all of your
application into the cloud and you will
be able to serve the users and
everything not only that that this
application will be available to you on
the GitHub not just to Simply watch and
see it but actually to contribute in
that I am deliberately not touching too
much on the styling part of this
application I'm keeping it very raw so
that you can bring in your Tailwind
experience and can contribute in this
repository you can the functionality of
this app will be 100 working but the UI
part you can modify it as much as you
like I'll keep it open-ended so that you
can focus more on this remember this is
a Nexus course not a Tailwind course so
I'll keep your Tailwind aside on totally
you so that you can bring your knowledge
and can contribute in this application
remember don't fall into the tutorial
hell you need to contribute something in
this as well all right I hope you're
excited now bringing in about the tech
stack side that what is the text tag
that we'll be using let me walk you
through with that so the text tag that
we'll be using is absolutely simple
there is nothing too much to be scared
about that first thing we obviously will
be using next.js together we'll be
reading a lot of documentation so that
you can actually learn that what it
takes to read the documentation bring
the code from documentation and write
along with it so this is the first thing
that we'll be doing and we'll be using
App router absolutely latest as modern
as possible we'll be firing up an npx
create next app later so we can pull in
the latest of the next JS apart from
this for the database side we'll be
using mongodb and we'll be using mongodb
in the cloud the only thing that I don't
like about it it's too white it should
have a dark mode but sadly I couldn't
find it so we'll be using and creating a
new cluster I'll walk you through from
the scratch that how to create a
database and how to use it and apart
from this since we are building up an
authentication system I'll walk you
through what we are building in a minute
but we will be needing some kind of a
mail service now one of the production
grade mail service is a mail trap I'm
not affiliated with them but I have been
using them for a while for teaching
purposes I found it pretty interesting
instead of just exposing your Gmail and
firing up email from that that's not a
good idea use professional tools and
mail trap is one of of the many such
tool that you can use so I'll be using
this one so apart from this I'll be
using a little bit of excally draw
everybody's favorite to just draw some
diagrams and explain you the stuff all
right so this is all what we'll be doing
first let's dive into the theoretical
part and what we are about to build so
what we're about to build is pretty
simple so first and foremost we will be
having at this screen and this one is
going to be a simple sign up screen now
this is not going to be any ordinary
sign up screen in the world of next year
so you obviously cannot just rely on the
front-end part we surely will have
front-end part we need a back-end part
as well I'll talk about that in a second
so now apart from this we'll be having a
simple login screen as well so what
we're building basically is a user
authentication system now since in the
latest a lot of upcoming tutorials will
require this authentication system so we
have a proper course here which explains
you everything about what happens what
goes in the authentication system as
much as in the core way possible all
right so we have a sign of have a login
and apart from this once we have this
sign up and the login we will also have
a profile section now this profile
section will have a couple of pages
again we'll not focus about what we are
serving on the profile we are more
concerned about how we can actually
reach through the profile if there is a
unique ID with the user associated with
that how can I grab that unique ID from
the URL there's so much to explore about
this so this is going to be a basic
application where user will be able to
sign up login and profile that's all but
there are also cases where user might
also request you couple of more features
so we'll be designing them I'll walk you
through with the scenario of how we can
actually go ahead and reset the password
or maybe also verify
so user account needs to verify as well
so we'll be working on the functionality
of reset and verify once you understand
even one part of it the next part is
super easy to understand I'll walk you
through with that scenario as well how
to reset the password how to verify the
user so all of this functionality will
be taking it down it's absolutely a core
of any application that you'll be
building so we'll be working on that
part and after this I'll keep it a
little bit open-ended so that there is
enough space that you can contribute in
that part all right so hope that is good
and I'll just write the tech stack here
as well so that we don't uh get any
troubles or problem in it so we'll be
using next year's I know that's very
small I don't like even the small fonts
and stuff I always keep them Big Easy to
watch in the tutorial for the back end
part we'll be using uh mongodb so we'll
be going with the mongodb now of course
we'll be needing a few of the stuff
since we are on the mongodb we'll be
going with the Mongoose we'll be going
with the node mailer as well and couple
of more things will be there like I'll
be using react hot toast and all these
things I'll not configure them properly
I'll leave them as a simple exercise for
you but don't worry we'll get the enough
of the messages and everything for us so
again it will be super fun to work on
with that all right so this is majorly
The Tick stack that we'll be going
through so I think that is it that is
all what will be going of course I'll
walk you through how we can configure
the mail trap and stuff now let's first
start not not by creating anything but
actually to understand the theory about
it now the theory is actually very very
amazing here so let me just walk you
through so first and foremost just
understand that everything in nexjs has
changed any tutorial that you're
watching which is older is no longer
going to work so you need to really
understand this part now everything that
you work on with this now actually goes
inside the source directory so consider
this as this is my source directory so
this is the source directory where you
will be working inside the source you
are going to find that there is a
directory known as app so this is our
app let's explore this
so this app directory has a couple of
things inside it the first part in fact
if I bring this app directory here and
try to explain it that how does this app
directory actually goes this app
directory can easily be divided into two
portions of it the first portion goes
here second portion goes here the first
part you can easily call this one as
backend
and yes there will be a lot of people
who will try to explain it with the
meaning of this is a server component is
it a client component yes we'll go
through with that we'll understand the
difference of it but not right now they
are much more easier to understand in
this way and context so we have this
back end and we have got this front end
so this is all that goes into this app
directory and this app directory is
obviously a part of this source so go
ahead and just let's just go ahead and
have an arrow just like this so we have
this Source but apart from this app you
will also find that it's not just
everything goes into the app directory
some things goes outside of the app
directory as well for example most of
the time when I design my models you can
absolutely place these models outside of
the app directory not just the models I
will also keep some of our helper files
for example I want to shoot an email I
want to verify my tokens JWT tokens yes
we'll be using them so how that works
we'll be keeping them outside as well
all right this is the whole gist of
everything let me summarize that quickly
now in the latest of next.js you'll find
everything is inside the source
directory and inside the source
directory you have this app app has two
portions of it the back end part and the
front-end part of it but it's not like
everything goes inside the app directory
there are other files you can obviously
create it like models helpers components
there's so many of the files that you
can create which can rely and reside
outside the app directory now more
notoriously you will see not notoriously
but yeah more of the time you'll see
that the backend portion is actually
written inside the API folder and yes
the naming convention is super super
important in the next JS even a
slightest wrong thing in the next in the
naming convention will just create a
havoc in the folder remember this is a
framework whenever we talk about
framework There are rules and regulation
you have to follow usually these rules
and regulation comes with the variables
names or maybe uh how the process needs
to work how the response needs to send
how the app directory should work out so
all these things need to go hand in hand
now you'll find a common thing as well
that whenever you are writing most of
the part in the apis in the back end you
are using file name as route and in case
of the front-end part you are actually
using the file name with the name of
page it could be page.tsx it could be
page.ts usually TSX and Route is usually
route dot either JS or either TS
whatever you are using will be using
typescript so we'll be calling it as a
route dot TS and here the page so I have
now this diagram makes it so much clear
that how things are going to go and how
things actually work now apart from this
there are certain files which also needs
to be inside this app directory and how
this actually goes and work on now one
of the most important thing that you'll
be looking up for
is notice this this is what the meaning
of app but hey there is a very common
file which you'll be using a lot which
is known as middleware where does the
middleware looks like
it's inside the source directory but
it's not inside the app directory yep
that's how usually the configuration is
there are other files and folders you
can have middleware just like the
middleware is here you can have your
customized error Pages lots of other
Pages which I'll walk you through with
the documentation as well you need to
put it a little bit outside so let me
walk you through with the documentation
as well so let's just say we want to
understand about the middleware right
now we don't understand too much the
working part of it but if I go ahead and
look for it notice here this is the
middleware and here's the convention use
the middle page and notice here for
example the same level as page or app or
inside the source if applicable so as I
told you it's actually inside the source
everything is inside the source but it
doesn't need to be inside the app
directory this is where it confuses a
lot of people but don't worry I'll walk
you through with every single thing how
to read the docs and everything how to
even see and utilize will be utilizing
this exact piece of code so you don't
have to worry even a tiny bit for that
part all right so this is all the basics
that we have done and we have understood
the basics meanings of how the things
are being done let's go ahead and create
with that I have already created an
account on mongodb Atlas you also need
to do this so let's go ahead and start I
have actually removed everything from
scratch we are going to be getting with
there so just click on build a database
and I'll be using AWS but I'll be using
free one I'll not pay money this is
YouTube I'm teaching for free so I think
this should also be free uh so I'll be
choosing a location which is nearby to
me
and where is nearby to me I think Mumbai
is the nearest looking for me and yes I
am from India so I think that's it and
create this this usually takes a couple
of minutes to spin so go ahead and be a
little patient about that I also want to
create a user and a password so I'll
actually do this later on and connect
from IP address and all of this so we'll
be doing that manually so I think we'll
not use this quick start of the security
guide I'll just walk you through this is
actually way better to explain if I go
ahead and explain everything in a much
precise and easier way so there we go
our cluster is created now first thing
that you have to do is go up here and
let me just go ahead and show you this
so all right I'll just shrink myself a
little bit move here all right so uh
first thing that you have to do is look
up into this security thing so this
security thing is super important first
go ahead and click on network access
here this network access simply means to
say that from where your application
should be available your application is
maybe Universal your database might be
in AWS should they talk to each other or
not so in this case I have given access
to all of this so you can just go ahead
and also click on ADD IP address you can
either add your current IP address but
since you are not on a permanent IP your
IP as soon as your router shutdowns and
reboots it might change so in this case
just for an example this is not a
production level setting we can go ahead
and say 0.0
dot 0.0 and slash 0 which means I want
everybody to be able to access my
database if they have correct ID and
password again there is one more layer
which is ID and password so that needs
to be there I can confirm this and this
will add there's nothing to add then go
ahead and click on database access that
who can access your database right now
we don't have any user so I'll click on
add user and I'll add a simple sample
user with the name of YouTube
and I'll enter a password
and again you really need to be careful
about what you are using as your
password if you use any special
character that might be URL encoded or
might create some issues in that so be
careful about that the usual practice is
to use numbers and letters that's all
and what we're going to do is we will be
also adding a built-in role so click on
that drop down and we'll be selecting
read and write to any database right now
and I'll just click on add user so this
will simply add a user which can
actually talk to any of the database now
that is it that is all you have to do
now click on the database
and all you have to do is click on this
connect and it will give you this
Compass click on the compass again and
this is the URL that you want to copy so
just click up here it will copy it now
notice here carefully that if you go
ahead and carefully look onto this one
this actually gives you the username but
doesn't gives you the password so
password is something that you have
already given there so go ahead and use
that one I'll just close this one that
is all the requirement here for having
this now let's just go ahead and move on
to the next JS home page and we'll be
creating a new project here so I'll just
go ahead and open up a folder so this is
the folder that we are using I already
built this app obviously otherwise why
would I be recording the tutorial so
I'll be calling this one as auth next JS
and this one is for YouTube so I'll be
just grabbing this one let me fire up my
vs code there we go vs code here we are
and I'll just go ahead and
just fire this up here
and let's create an xjs app
all right so this looks good full real
estate
all right let me go ahead back up here
and just click on this small command
which says npx create next app very
nicely hidden there I'll just go on to
vs code and we'll start that so I'll
just go ahead and open this up and just
paste it up here and I guess the dot
command still works if I want to install
everything here let's go ahead and try
this out and I'll just put up a DOT to
just create a project in this same
directory and it will ask us a couple of
things do you want to use typescript
obviously I want to use it let me also
move myself a little bit on to the
perfect place all right looks good looks
good okay do you want to use es linting
for this one so obviously I want to use
es linting so I'll just go ahead move it
up here
and let me just
all right just give me a second all
right so we want to use eslinting uh yes
we want to use eslinting uh do you want
to Tailwind yes maybe you can contribute
with the Tailwind a little bit so I'll
just go ahead and yes do you want to use
the source directory with this project
uh we want to use the source directory
or we want to use the app directory now
this is where a lot of people get
confused yes we want to use Source
directory because as I mentioned up here
the source directory is now everything
remember the source yep source is
everything and this will also give you
the app directory so moving back yes we
want to use it you want to use app
router a 100 you want to use app router
this is the way forward so anything that
you're learning from now onwards you
want to use app router I'll just hit
enter would you like to customize the
default import Alias I usually no but
I'll show you that if you write yes what
actually happens if you go ahead and
select yes it gives you two options you
can use at the rate or you can use or
asterisk for showing where is the home
of this home directory so we'll be using
at the rate which is also the default
and then it will just create a simple
project in your application
in your folder not your application so
this doesn't usually take much of the
time should be really really fast and
yeah mostly other things are installed
all right so there we go okay let's
clean this up first let's understand the
directory structure which I was telling
you so notice here in the source we can
see there is the app directory and
inside this all the files are there we
have the page.tsx which is always the
common file there is also a layout which
is also a wrapper and inside the layout
we actually get the page so notice here
if I just show you this is wrapper so
everything that you are passing in as a
children the whole job of this is to
just render this if I go ahead and move
it to next line it's much more easier to
understand so this layout is nothing
it's just a wrapper maybe you have a
common navigation bar maybe you have a
common footer so all this can be
actually injected into the layout and
then children whatever is being passed
on it just renders it as it is so that's
the basic meaning of how the layout
actually works
base.ts is the way how we deal with the
front-end part of it and most of the
client side or the client rendering will
be doing through this I'll show you the
difference between the client side and
the server side in the next JS you don't
have to worry in that part absolutely
simple and basic I will go with that so
we'll close this one this is the basics
of it now inside this app directory
there is so much that you can go ahead
and work on with this and we will surely
be doing that in just a second first
let's open the package.json and you can
see in order to run this we have to say
npm run Dev which will run the next Dev
which is let me tell you is painful low
painfully slow not low painfully slow
application to run so if I go ahead and
say npm run Dev this looks like it it's
faster but it's not so I'll just copy
this and go back on to the browser
and I'll start this and you will notice
every time it takes build the first
build is painfully slow but this is how
you get your application all right now
it's not just that we will be just
working with these dependencies only we
actually have some of our own
dependencies as well which will be super
helpful for us in the future so we'll be
first installing them installing them is
super easy you can just go ahead and say
npm install the first package that we'll
be using is xeos yes you can use fetch
as well but I want to give you the taste
of how things actually work in the
production but feel free to use fetch
there is no such hard fast rule then we
have
decrypt
decrypt JS now bcrypt JS is a library
which use is used commonly to encrypt
the stuff I will be encrypting our
password obviously we don't want to
store the clear text password in our
database not only that for creating the
tokens as well if you remember I told
you just a few minutes ago that hey
we'll be using this middleware models
and helpers and they will be useful to
reset and verify the tokens we don't
want to send ABCD we want to send a
really long strings which is encrypted
to the user so for that we'll be using
the bcrypt JS it's a super simple and
amazing library for this one now apart
from this we'll be sending the tokens
and securely we'll be sending it not to
be stored in the local storage but we'll
be sending and securing the cookies from
the server side so that it doesn't get
manipulated on the front-end side for
this we'll be needing a Json web token
so Json web token this is the library
that we use for that now after that
we'll be using node mailer this is one
of the most simplest library to shoot
out an email either you want to send it
or shoot it out from the Gmail or if you
have something else like AWS maybe
Bluehost whatever you're using you can
just go ahead and use the node mailer
for that now another Library which I'll
not be setting it up but I'll give it to
you for as an exercise is this react uh
hot dose this is one of my favorite
Library which works really amazingly
well it actually gives you small pop-up
messages that hey just a user
successfully signed up a user didn't
sign up so we'll be using that I'll not
be using it so you can skip it at this
moment but it will be super good for you
to contribute further down the road
all right so I guess this is all that we
need as of now if we'll be needing
something else we can just oh I forgot
one guy which is Mongoose how we are
going to talk to the database now
Mongoose is a library which helps you to
talk to mongodb it's a wrapper around
mongodb drivers makes our life a little
easier so we'll be using that now one
thing a lot of you who are coming from
the backend development might be
noticing I'm not using Express you don't
need it you don't need it in the next
years this is all what we'll be using so
go ahead and install that if we'll need
any more Library we can go ahead and use
it later on I think this is more than
enough for as of now and further down
the road let's go ahead and work on with
this okay so a couple of things I'll
mention it straight forward I'll be
creating couple of directories first and
foremost so that you get a feel of how
the directories and all of this is
layout because notice already you can
see the source and then app then all the
things are inside that but it is too
difficult to see I'll show you in the
part here so if I go ahead into next.js
notice inside the source everything is
inside the app but here the structure
the directory structure of the vs code
might confuse some of the people so
everything is inside the app all right
I'll show you more of this as well now
let's go ahead and create couple of more
folders and directories and stuff like
that first and foremost now click on the
source very carefully click on the
source and create a new folder and we
want to create a folder known as model
or you can say models both are the same
so it helps us now to actually see that
oh now we can see that everything is
inside the app and there is a model
directory as well we obviously will need
some helper as well to shoot email and
stuff like that so it's a good idea that
we create these helpers as well again
this was not going to crash your app or
anything it's just a folder in directory
structure all right now we have these
application there's a lot more that you
can go ahead and create like that so
we'll be using that part as well now one
of the most important thing that we'll
be using is the environment variables
obviously our database strings cannot go
in the clear text format they need to go
somewhere secure so that when we deploy
them in the production they actually are
secure there as well so one neat trick
is you can come here into the vs code
and just double click here and it will
automatically create a file in the root
of the directory that's where we want it
it is dot EnV these are your environment
variables and you can access them easily
and in the production as well in every
single hosting these environment
positions are there that where you have
to inject them in the digitalocean AWS
everybody has these secret managers
we'll come back on to this one right now
we don't want to add anything like that
I'm just creating a folder structure
which can help you to do all these
things all right so this is the basics
that we have that everything now notice
here everything is still inside the
source as I mentioned then we have this
app and then all the things are here now
one more interesting thing which
confuses a lot of people is majority of
your file will go into the app and I
told you just here that inside this app
somewhere here it is your backend also
goes your front end also goes so we need
it's time that we verify that that how
does that works so inside this app I'm
going to go ahead and create a new
folder and I'm going to call this one as
login so login is going to be first now
I have to ask myself before creating
these folders am I creating it for
backend or front end I am creating it
for front-end so if I'm creating it for
front end I know I have to call it as
page yeah that's that's the page we
talked about so I'll go back and inside
this I'm going to go ahead and create a
new file and I have to call it as page
dot TSX the name is super super
important call it something else and it
will crash up everything here that's how
it works so now that we have this
page.tsx now it's time that we simply go
ahead and just simply have the basics of
a simple hello world kind of a thing or
just have it a simple test or something
like that so I'm going to go ahead and
say export and default
export default function and we'll call
it as login page just like this now
inside this login page obviously you
want to return something to just say
hello world or something like that right
now I'm not worried about the
functionality so I'll just go ahead and
say hey return and what do I want to
return a simple div and which will say
login and a Dev close that's it that's
all what we are doing now obviously I
would love to just properly align this
this is really really bad I'll enable my
uh oh there we go so I need to just have
this now no Auto prettier is coming in
I'll make sure I enable that so that
doesn't bother you that much but I have
to just save it now the moment I save it
that is it I don't have to worry about
any route or anything I can go back on
to my next app and I can simply go ahead
and say slash login
and that's it probably I didn't started
my server yeah my bad so we'll just go
ahead and say npm run Dev
and there we go our server is up and
running
all right looks good looks good let's go
back on to the browser and hit a login
route again and this is painfully long
so we can see that this is a login of
course you can use go ahead and use your
skills like you can go ahead and add a
class name then you can go ahead and say
Hey I want to have something suggestions
please
Flex
okay no suggestions
I'll just leave it I'll just add a
simple classes here so class name we'll
just go with the text Dash Center text
Dash white I was expecting that it will
give me all these suggestions and we'll
just also say text Dash 2 Excel yep
so that at least we can see that there
is a nice login
there should be text Center as well
align Center yeah there should be text
Center all right anyways we'll just
figure out the CSS part little bit later
on but as we can see now can I go ahead
and use a sign up here
nope I cannot this is a 404 page by the
way you can customize your 404 page as
well you can read the documentation a
little bit and you can customize just
read about hey I want to learn about 404
not found.js so you can create a new
file there with the name of just not
found as you can see app blog not found
so wherever your app is inside the blog
and this is where you can just create a
file and customize this one I'll not do
that as of now I just want to show you
the basics of how things are working now
let's try to crash this app so let's
just say I understood the basics of it
but I didn't understood truly of it so
I'll just go ahead and again click on
the app create a new folder you always
have to create a folder for every single
route I'll just go ahead and say sign up
and obviously it's engineering that we
try and fail the stuff as well so let's
just say I call this one instead of the
page I just call it as login dot TSX
what happens in that case again we are
going to go ahead and say export uh
default command suggestions and we'll
call this one as we should call it as
sign up page that would be more cool to
crash
because we are in the sign up so let's
just call this one as signup.tsx so now
we have export default and I'll not call
it as login page
sign up page
there we go and inside this we're going
to go ahead and say We'll return what do
we want to return a simple div with the
flex it's probably not we'll also have a
simple sign up and we'll have a div just
like that and again of course this needs
to be there
all right so we're returning this now
let's just save this there is no problem
here it says compiled successfully no
problem there but if I go up here
instead of
hitting the sign up now if I let's try
login First
login works and then I try
sign up
nope it doesn't work so now we
understand the importance of the file
and naming convention because it's a
naming based routing so I'll go ahead
and turn it up into page.tsx and what
you're going to notice as soon as it
compiles all you got to do you don't
even need to hit the reload so it works
out of the box so this is how the naming
convention and everything works up here
all right
let's go back and try to explore a tiny
bit more into that how the things are
going to work all right so as I told you
everything is inside the app and there's
one major portion of it so we have
talked about how the front end part will
look like and I told you you can also
work with the back end part of it but
the back end part needs to be inside the
folder of API let's go ahead and do that
so inside the app we'll create a new
folder naming convention cannot
emphasize it more API and inside this
API this is way how you actually Define
your routes so for example let's take
this API and in this API the way how
you're going to make your folder is
going to be your API route so for
example if further inside this API you
create a folder or maybe a couple of
folders let's go ahead and work on with
that so you created a folder named as
users maybe for an example
and you also created a folder name as a
what else home
so you can go ahead and create and this
will Define that how the routes are
going to work so API slash users and
similarly API slash home so this is how
it actually works absolute basic there
is nothing too much complex about it but
this is how it actually goes I'll go
back and now inside the apis I want a
new folder structure to be followed
which is known as users so obviously my
route is now not just the API directly
but API slash users and then whatever
the file folder how am I creating and as
I mentioned inside this API just like in
the front end it is exactly almost copy
paste but the file name is just route so
what we learned here is if we want to
create a sign up we have to create a
signup folder first and inside that
folder we have this page.tsx similarly
in the users also we need to create a
folder first now this folder can be
anything sign up anything whatever you
like so I'll just go ahead and create a
sign up
and once I have this sign up now inside
the sign up you have to create a route
that is Route dot TS of course it's not
X because it's not a component now just
to make sure you understand it more
proper inside the users I'll create one
more folder that will be login because
obviously anyhow I have to create login
route and I'll just create a new file
and that will be route dot TS so this is
now a proper folders and structure that
we have that we have this login API
route we have this sign up API route as
well
this is now finally a complete guide
that how actually the folder structure
and everything is is laid out this is
absolute basic uh but there's couple of
things I cannot just go ahead and work
on with sign up I cannot go ahead and
work on with login because these apis
needs database connection and this
next.js is an edge run framework so
there's always edged runtime so it
doesn't stay connected with your
database every single time there is a
database call you have to actually call
your database make a connection with it
and then you talk to a database send
some file receive some file all these
things actually go ahead and work
through that now in order to actually
have this you need to have some
configurations so I'll just close this
app notice here we have helpers outside
we have models outside just like this we
can also have our database connections
outside as well and there are a lot of
ways how you can go ahead and do this so
at least let's go ahead and connect the
database I'll first go into EnV and I'll
create couple of environment variables
so that they are helpful for us and
later on we can use them so first and
foremost we'll be having this
underscore URL or URI whatever the way
you prefer I'll also be using a token
underscore
secret that could be any secret I'll be
using something like next Js YouTube
whatever and we'll also have a domain
this will also be useful later on so
I'll just use an HTTP local 3000 that's
my domain name this will be helpful for
me when I'll be shooting some emails so
I obviously want to click on the and
have the localhost so this will be
useful later on now let's go back on to
getting the string so let's go ahead and
connect
compass and just literally copy this
come back here paste it up here
and all you have to do is add your
password here so obviously I'll be
adding my password but behind the scenes
so once this video gets over this part
of the video gets over I'll add my
password so I'll just say add my
password so obviously I'll not add it in
front of you otherwise I don't want to
mess up anyways it's a test database but
still okay so I'll just save it and
we'll try to connect with the database
I'll walk you through with the
connection at least the code part of it
now notice here we have app helper
modules so similarly we'll have the DB
config whatever the name you want to
give it I'll give it a name of dbconfig
I think that makes sense so DB config
yeah that sounds good to me now again
inside the DB config I would love to
keep uh I can just actually close all
this close others yeah close everything
all right so inside the DB config
come on
yeah now inside the DB config I will
just have a dbconfig.ts file let's go
ahead and create so DB
config.ts
in this part the naming convention
doesn't really matter much so you can
just call it whatever you like it is not
going to bother you anything at all in
order to connect with the database let's
get some more screens real estate the
first thing is who actually is capable
of connecting or talking to mongodb it's
Mongoose so we're going to go ahead and
have Mongoose and that Mongoose will be
coming up from Mongoose and then we'll
be exporting this method as well and it
obviously needs to be a sync we are
talking to database and as I always say
database is always in another continent
so things needs to be a sync so I'll
just go ahead and have a function just
like this connect we'll call this one as
absolutely simple connect and we'll wrap
this up into try catch block so I'll
just go ahead and have the try
try catch there we go the catch part is
the easiest one so first we are going to
handle that part it's really simple
we're going to have a oops console dot
wrong and we'll say the classic the most
horrific error which is something went
wrong but we'll also go ahead and use
the console log for displaying the error
you can go ahead and use error.messages
as well that's totally up to you no
problem at all in that case let's try to
get a string of mongoose connections so
Mongoose dot connect obviously
dot connect and this requires you to
have just the URL now I'll not give the
URL which is suggested me by the copilot
I'll be using my own string and that you
will see quite a lot in this entire
Series so process.env dot
um and again make sure you take the URL
and name of the variable pretty
accurately it is URL I'm using I
should be using all uppercase to make it
actually all underscore URI
this one should also be domain so
everything is consistent there
I'll I'll simply copy this and we'll say
manga URI now here's the interesting
thing since we are using typescript
there is no guarantee that this URI will
always resolve but I know it will always
so I'll just put an exclamation to make
sure that hey I take care of it you
don't worry it will always be available
and that's it so all you have to do is
this much now once you have done this
much then you can actually grab a
connection so we can go ahead and grab a
connection
and actually let's hold this into a
variable
so connection will be given to you by
Mongoose dot connection
once Mongoose has connected it will give
you Mongoose dot connection the string
will be available and based on this you
can actually listen to variety of events
for example
one such event is a connection and every
event is being listened by the word dot
on now inside this you can go ahead and
try the connected
connected this is the one event and it
fires a callback obviously so once I
have this call back and I'll just go
ahead and use it like this
and we'll remove this yep
sometimes these Auto suggestions are
just painful but bear with me so we'll
just simply have a mongodb connected
successfully
successfully yeah I would love that okay
so this part is all done you can also
listen to some of the errors in case you
wish to so similar to that connection
dot errors and you can just go ahead and
listen to these errors just like this
I'll come back here if there is any
error you can just go ahead and say hey
mongodb connection error please make
sure mongodb is running then we can pass
on error as a post process string and we
can exit gracefully here so this is all
that is required to go ahead and get
connected with that and I'll save this
one as well so there we go so this is
the basics of it now the most important
part is this connect needs to come in in
almost every single place in the API
because without the connect
you cannot talk to database and every
single time an API call is there you
have to have to connect with the
database there is no exception there is
no option that is available for you this
is how it works so there is no exception
on that part all right so I think this
is a really really a good progress that
we have made about this application so
far all right so this looks okay this
looks good okay what else we can do uh
next up now next up I want to do is
actually I want to prepare my at least a
sign up screen so that I know that there
is a sign up screen and how things are
actually going on working on with this
all right so let's go into again I don't
want to go into API backend part I'm not
handling I'm handling first the front
end part so this is my sign up screen
I'll go into page.tsx and I will
obviously import few of the things now
one thing important that you need to
understand
from the front end part I need to grab
some data and send it to the backend
just like we do in a regular application
in react application or maybe there's a
backend in Django spring wherever that
is you collect the information and make
an xcos request or fetch request to that
the same thing I have to do but there is
a problem in the recent version of the
next JS everything is a server component
and server component don't have access
to anything that is on the front-end
side it's on server so the most crucial
thing that you need to understand here
is that whenever there is this dilemma
between the front end part or the back
end part you need to understand it very
clearly that anything that's on server
needs can access everything on the
server side file system anything that's
on the server front-end part if you want
to take advantage of you state use
effect anything that's on the front end
part of it Windows location maybe you
want to access the location the URL
anything that's on the page that's on
the client side and you have to
explicitly make make your application as
a client side cut it no confusion
absolutely simple anything that's on the
back end here's a simple hint most of
the things in the API folder yep that's
on the back end side that's default
server component so that is that but
anything that's usually outside not
always but outside is usually a client
component if you want to take some data
in this case the sign up form we want to
take some data from the user and send it
on the back end so obviously that is
going to be on the front-end side so let
me walk you through how we can convert
any component into the front end or the
client component it's super super simple
let's go ahead and go up here all you
have to do is simply say use client just
like we have used strict we can go ahead
and say use client that is it one
decorator and it is now a client
component you can use all of your window
object you can use all of your use date
you can use all of your use effect
everything yeah how cool is this all
right so now we'll be needing some of
the libraries and stuff so obviously
I'll be needing something to redirect
the thing so I'll be just going ahead
and say Hey I want to import the link
this is the next link okay I'll be also
needing react as well so I'll be saying
that hey let's go ahead and bring in
react and from the react we'll be saying
we'll be using a couple of stuff but as
of now let's bring in react only I don't
know what we'll be using and we will be
using because once the user is
successfully signed up I want him to
redirect or get redirected to the home
page for this I need to use router
here's a common thing which a lot of
people are going to make mistake the
router is changed in Nexus in case you
are coming up from the previous routers
I'll go ahead and say I want to use
router so this is the way how you bring
in use router and this router actually
notice your suggestion it's absolutely
wrong this suggestion doesn't work you
cannot bring it like this
and let me show you how you actually
bring it you have to actually bring it
from next come on I can write it next
slash
again this suggestion is also Wrong by
default even your GitHub co-pilot every
suggestions these are all wrong because
this is the latest version of it this
one is now coming up from navigation yep
use router not user router use router
this is the one I want to bring in use
router is actually coming up from
navigation and I tried it while building
the application every single time the
suggestion I relied on it it gave me the
wrong suggestion so maybe it will take
some time and last but not least we'll
be using xeos so I think we need to
bring it like this
xeos and these suggestions are usually
correct
not this time again suggestions are good
but they always don't work always so
we'll be just going xcos
all right
so this is the basics now you'll also
get these squiggly line because a lot of
time a lot of models Mongoose xios this
is perfect installation there is no
problem in the installation but
typescript is one such thing which
requires type definitions as well and
since the axios types are not defined we
have to actually explicitly install it I
don't remember them always so always
remember this you can click up here and
then you'll get this bulb icon and you
can click on it and you can say that hey
uh right now it's for error for the
unused input but it will also give you
that hey install the dependencies or the
types for it so I usually click on that
that's how I actually go for it right
now we are not using Xeo so that's why
it's getting a little bit bothered so no
no worries on that part okay how we are
going to get a sign up now first and
foremost we haven't designed our model
yet but I'll do that very very soon so
first let's go ahead and try on the
front end part what user data you want
to accumulate so I'll go ahead and say I
will grab a user so so it will give me a
suggestion hopefully set user react use
date and I'll just go ahead and close it
like that
now what all information I'm looking up
for uh maybe I'm looking up for an email
maybe I'm looking up for a password of
course and also maybe username
so let's just say username that is all
that is all the information I'm looking
up for as of now and of course once a
user actually gives me this all
information there should be a method
which does all the sign up thing so
we'll be just going ahead and say const
and I'll say on sign up and this method
obviously will be talking to database so
this needs to be a sync and there we go
right now I have no clue that how this
will work so I'll just keep a method as
it is I'm not worried on that part so
I'll just keep it as a test all right
now right now there is nothing uh more
in my mind I just want to have a simple
divs here so that I can just go ahead
and place it up here so I'll just use a
little bit of my CSS that I have
pre-written here so I'll just use that
instead of this login and stuff so I'll
just go ahead and give it to you
directly there's nothing basic
all right now inside this we are going
to first have in simple H1 which says
login
and I think that should work a tiny bit
decent let's see that if we are crashing
our app or it's going good and we should
be ah we should be in the sign up page
so we should not be saying login we
should be saying sign up that's better
all right so our looks sing up
all right
sign up there we go all right looks very
tiny but I'm okay with that now after
this I'll be creating a couple of input
forms for this I'll be starting with the
label we just need to create one and
then after that we'll be just copying
and pasting so have some line break then
let's go ahead and have a label
this one is going to be HTML for
not for email but I'll I'll edit that
this one will be for username I'll First
grab the username this one will be for
username
all right by the way we have we have all
lower case that's nice we have this
label up here and let's see how does
that look yeah username not the best but
I'll I'll work with that all right next
up is we need an input
now input field will have some other
things ID username okay I'm fine with
that type is text and the value is user
dot username yep absolutely correct and
on change absolutely perfect in case you
didn't got it we are grabbing the event
we are calling this set user which is a
method a function responsible for
updating my variable user so that's why
I'm using here is set user and set user
in which we are keeping existing user
everything same and the username only is
getting updated with the E dot Target
dot value which is coming up from here
absolutely simple uh no problem uh we'll
also grab a couple of modes like for
example it is not suggesting me anything
but
all right
I want placeholders as well
placeholder and I'll say username let's
see how does that look
decent not the best but I'll just work
with that in case you want you can go
ahead and add a class name we can add a
little bit of padding of four
there's some suggestion let's see if
that suggestion uh okay not the best not
the bad
all right I think padding four is too
much I'll just go ahead and padding one
is
uh two we'll go with the two we'll go
with the two all right okay so this is
just a decent as I told you you can use
your Tailwind skills and just uh design
this much better now the best thing
about this is now I have to grab email
and password so I can just go ahead and
copy paste this so I'll just grab from
here I'll make a duplicate of this one
and obviously they made a mistake yep we
shouldn't be copying and pasting till
the div my bad and we'll just copy from
the label to the input now we'll copy
and paste better so we'll just go ahead
and use multi-cursors username username
username username username this needs to
go on email
let's see if we have made any mistake
should be okay
and then let's copy and duplicate this
and this one this time will be password
so command D command d control D also
multi-cursor I love that
password
the text should also be password
and that should be it for majority of
the portion
username email password horrific form
but it will work it will work now let's
go ahead and grab a button as well so
we'll just go ahead and say button just
like this and this button will have
class name ah I love that and what we're
going to do is just have this button and
we'll call this one as sign up suck sign
up
all right sign up button sign up here
well right here okay a couple of more
things we need in this one is
first and foremost this signup needs to
go uh somewhere so obviously we cannot
just go like this so we need to have an
on click
suggestions please no suggestions
yeah on click sign up so I'm referring
to this method which I created above I
don't know how this method works but
right now this is all the basics also
apart from this I'll use a link
so link will go to a login and will say
something like this this page will go
like
visit login
I'm not interested about login page yeah
that's basics
so there we go now we have a sign up
page looks decent and we have this
username email password uh so right now
I don't want this email
okay so we got this one so password sign
up everything is working nice we are
happy with this this also is taking us
to the login page which is not yet
design but we can actually quickly
design that very very uh Basics all part
of it so nothing too much worried on
that part as of now we are going
absolutely good with that let's also try
and do login also in this same video
Also let's let's try that okay so I'll
just go up here and we'll go to vs code
okay this part looks good notice here
how easy it was for us to actually
Design This I'll go ahead and create
copy all of this so copy this let's go
into the login and page and let's go
ahead and paste it obviously we want to
change first the sign up page to login
page that's the most important thing
login page
okay let's analyze this from top to
bottom uh this needs to be client okay
link is there react is there use router
is there we are not using it but we'll
be using it very soon to forcefully push
the user to slash profile or something
like that
all right so this is what we have as a
user
we'll be grabbing only the email and
password so this time it's a login so I
don't need this field
all right no suggestion please thank you
this one is on login makes sense on
login
and then we are returning this sign up
no it should be login
and login all right and then we have
this username is not here we are just
email and password so I think we can
just get rid of this very first
and should be all okay yep all okay so
there we go email is there nice and easy
password is there nice and easy uh this
one is obviously going to be on login
did we ported anything else yep we don't
want this on so this one is good we have
got this one password is getting
password value good good login here
and what we can see uh visit
sign up here we are not too much worried
about providing a proper message to the
this is not what we are going to do all
right now notice here though all the
error is because of axios but this is
not going to bother anything this is
just because of we are not using it
right now notice here XC has declared
but it's never used so don't worry don't
bother this is just squiggly line
warning I'm not going to do anything all
right save this and let's see if I go
ahead and there we go sign up is good
and our login page is not good now it's
good take some time some reloads common
so we have some email and password and
that's nice and we can visit the sign up
page and yeah it takes a little time did
we properly linked it
looks like not
yeah not this one is
sign up so there we go small debuggings
sign up there we go login sign up all
right so at least we are able to do this
much of the thing now not this much is
not enough we need to do a tiny bit more
tiny bit more uh I want to walk you
through with One More Concept which will
act as a foundational for a lot of
upcoming things don't worry about these
Reds I know these are bothering you but
these are okay okay just like we have
studied about these logins and
everything we need to study about one
more thing which will also be super
super helpful for us which is known as
how we can grab and build a profile for
the user now notice here this profile is
not in the API this is not in the
backend part I'm talking about the front
end part only so I'll just go ahead and
say that hey app I'll create one more
folder for you which will be
profile
and as you know in the profile I
obviously have to create a page.tsx so
page.tsx and we'll just go ahead and say
export suggest me please
suggestions no no suggestions hate that
export default yeah now suggestions ah
good I like that
and we can just go ahead and say return
give me something yep nice and easy
and a profile
and an HR
and what else profile page okay I'll
take that now I'm not going to take this
much I'll just go with this
and I'll just go ahead and wrap this up
this div
isions are good as long as you know what
you are doing or what your application
is trying to do
otherwise you'll fall into the crap okay
I'll just indent this a little bit so
that it doesn't bother you that much
all right so this is my profile page and
as you all know this is super easy to
work on with this later on we'll learn
how to protect these profile Pages as
well so I can go ahead and work on the
profile okay profile page works
absolutely fine but what about if I go
ahead and move into the profile and type
slash One how can I grab this one
because this is a very crucial part of
building the application how can I grab
not just one but if I go ahead and write
ABC here this is a common syntax you'll
be doing this thousands of time there's
a special syntax of how you do this in
the next year so let's go back on to the
code there we go so in any folder or any
route where you want to grab this ID
there is a special syntax in next.js
right click on this create a new folder
yeah
folder not file all right and make sure
you put this into square brackets in the
square bracket whatever you want to
extract whatever the object named
remember we have this request.body
similar we have request.params in case
you worked somewhere in the next.js not
next year's express.js similar to that
you have to grab your ID it could be
user ID it could be ID whatever you want
it could be anything but it needs to be
in the square bracket but for example if
I go ahead and say ID
ID
this is not alone enough this since is a
folder and every folder on the front end
needs a page known as page.tsx you have
to create that so I'll just right click
and create a new file and I'll call this
one as page not a page page dot TSX
there we go now inside this page.tx you
will be able to grab it how first I'll
go into outside page because we have
this already created for us I'll copy
this and I'll go into this page.tsx
inside the square ID yep the square id1
so this is going to be the page where
I'll actually grab everything now notice
here this is not my client component I
haven't said use client or something
like this
I'll just go ahead and call it something
different because profile page there's
already profile page although it's not
going to bother me anything but I don't
like it I'll probably call it as user
profile
not even page user profile whatever the
name you want to give it's not going to
bother you all right so how can we grab
these parameters really simple you have
to Simply say I want to grab some params
that's it this prompts needs to be of
type any but if you know the exact type
strings whatever you're passing on you
can get that type but since I'm not
focusing too much on the typescript so
that everybody can understand next.js so
we'll simply go like that now
how we can actually grab this so just
here in the profile page we'll first add
some classes here so that it can be
easily visible so we'll just grab text
Dash 2 not to 4XL we need we need big
one for Excel text is already white yeah
I think that's enough now just go ahead
and inject your variable and all you
have to go ahead and say is
params.whatever you are grabbing in this
case we are grabbing ID so just grab the
ID that's it now let's go back and
probably we have got some errors I know
it is compiling successfully let's go
ahead and kill this probably I saved it
at the wrong time
all right compiled successfully now
let's go ahead and grab this come on
take so much time so we can see the
profile and ABC I think we should
actually span this up all right to show
you in a little bit better manner
although it doesn't really matter but
I'll just go ahead and do this I'll cut
this out and I'll go ahead and say
span just like this paste it up here and
I'll add some classes onto this one
and we can close this down and we can
say hey what do you want I want first of
all padding off two and I want it to be
rounded I want a PG Dash golden do you
have golden yeah they don't have golden
we have to go through with the orange
and the text is going to be black I
guess
text Dash black you can use your own
CSS of Tailwind there we go we got it we
just need a tiny bit of margin on left
we'll just grow with the two
there we go so although it was not
intended to make it look like that I
know what you're thinking don't think
that it's not that uh so I will go ABC
and we can go one one two two three
three whatever you're grabbing it's
gonna grab it from there so this solves
a lot of our future problem that we'll
be having looks nice absolutely gorgeous
there and simply if I go on to just the
profile one page is also getting served
there but that is this page this page
that right now here this is a different
page and once you have this uh some IDs
after this like 9988 whatever this is a
difference page that is being served so
this actually sums up your Basics about
nexius I know this is a really really
long video but again uh we'll be having
a really long short videos about
discussing about next years and
everything now we are in a perfect
position that we have our folder
structure ready everything is almost
ready that how we want it to be our DB
connection is also ready now in the next
video or if you're watching in
continuation that means just to skip
forward what I'm going to do is now
first we'll create an API how we can
create a back end I'll just close a lot
of things here okay so let me just walk
you through what we are going to do next
up in this one so the next plan is
really simple we simply want to work
with the back end now we have worked
quite a lot on the front-end part handle
the parameters file structure directory
structure client component server
component a lot of things we have
discussed now the next goal is how I can
design apis that will make me a full
stack developer almost so in in the next
video or just a fraction after if you're
watching in continuation next up we are
going to take an attack on building the
apis we'll start obviously with the sign
up API the most basic will extract the
data and we'll sign up a user and throw
up into the database that is all what we
want to do and that would be a fantastic
start and then eventually we'll do login
then mailing verify tokens and all of
that but slowly slowly we want to take
enough of the gradual that it's
enjoyable it's fun and all of this so I
hope you have enjoyed this one and in
case you are watching it along with me
then hey let's catch up in next video if
you're watching it in the next one just
the moment of pause and let's catch up
on the other side
all right hey there everyone hitesh here
and welcome to another video or another
part of the video in case you're
watching in sequence and it's a next
year's complete full stack course that
you're watching on YouTube of course so
in this video I'll walk you through with
the next step now this video is almost a
part two so in case you have in case you
haven't watched the part one go try that
or in case you are jumping directly on
this portion please don't it's not a
good idea so we have seen that how we
can handle the front and part a little
bit more like a file structure we
haven't learned how we can make a web
request from the front end to our
backend because our backend was not
ready in this particular section we are
going to learn that how we can create
models which can talk to a database we
have already configured our database we
have already injected our environment
variables learned that how we can have a
database connection file which can which
needs to be called in every single API
call because edge cases not edge cases
Edge functions which actually run so
they don't have a constant database
Connection in this we'll start by
creating a simple model and that model
will be a structure of our database and
there's a lot of ways how you can design
it I'll walk you through with some of
the quirky things and interesting things
about it you'll definitely enjoy that
part and then we'll directly jump into
the sign up portion so that we can write
a simple
apis which can or basically controllers
for API which can do the logical part
take all the data and send it to the
database that's our first goal then
we'll figure out what to do next up so
that is how we'll be going now let me
take you on my screen first so this is
our screen that's where we have been
enjoying so notice here the models is
right now totally empty we have almost
nothing in our model so it's a good idea
good time to create a new file into it
and feel free to call it whatever you
like and why is it not listening to me
why is it not listening to me so just
give me a second probably my keyboard is
not working yeah should be working now
yep and we'll be calling it as user
model M should be capital or not I'll
keep it capital user model dot again
this would be a simple JS you can make
it TS as well I'll make it JS
usermodel.js because there is nothing
too much sensitive going into this one
first question who can talk to my
database obviously Mongoose so go ahead
import Mongoose that will be coming up
from Mongoose now how do we create it
simple const let's call this one as user
schema and that is going to be simply
new Mongoose dot schema
and there we go basic just like this now
before we go ahead and work about rest
of the things let me tell you something
really interesting now there is a
special way of how you export your
models from a mongoose in case of nexjs
because there are chances that the model
might already be created in the database
so in most of the cases in the express
and all that the model file doesn't run
again and again automatically but here
we need to actually import this file
quite a lot of time and we need to take
care of the cases if it is already
created then use that if it is not
created just create that so there's a
lot of ways how we do that one of the
very common user built syntax is just go
ahead and take a user and simply go
ahead and say Mongoose dot models and
then create this users because remember
in the mongodb even if you call this in
the Mongoose or the model file as user
with a capital u everything is
lowercased and is pluralized that's a
mongodb thing it does it for everything
so that is the first thing if it is
already created use that otherwise we
are going to create our own model so
we're going to go ahead and say Mongoose
a DOT model demo
model and then we will be creating this
is going to be a simple model which
takes two parameter what do you want to
call it in the database and how does it
look now usually you'll see that
something look like this and again
that's totally fine and you can go ahead
and call it like this as well there is
absolutely no problem in that case why
is it giving it like that there we go
why is it bothering me this much
there we go
or if you wish you can go ahead and call
it as lowercase users that is also
totally fine anyhow end of the day it is
going to get created as users lowercase
and once you are done with this then you
can go ahead and Export it as a default
so export default user that's what I
prefer that whenever I'm taking this
user I always call it as uppercase
because it has a lot of superpower it's
not any ordinary variable it's coming
from from Mongoose so dot save method
find one there's a lot of features that
comes up as a built-in now apart from
this I'll not talk too much about the
Mongoose superpower because Mongoose
definitely itself deserves a course but
I'll just go with the basics for example
I'll just go ahead and say hey I'll be
having a username and that will be of
type string and we're going to go ahead
and required it true and provide a
customized message of hey and we'll also
keep this you username as unique so that
will be nice and easy we probably can
have a trim but I'm not interested in
that already too much and then we'll be
having email will be having a type of
string and required true please provide
an email and let's keep emails as unique
as well that is it this much is already
more than enough all right now next up
we'll be having the password which will
be a type of string and require true
please provide a password that's it
don't want to do any further into the
password category now apart from this
you'll see that in these kinds of model
there are common fields which are there
for example uh usually I go with the
role because I bring my roles from an
enum file constant file from where I can
bring the enums like is admin manager
student teacher there's a lot of roles
with that in this case I'll drill it
little bit down so that it doesn't
create that much of confusion all the
introduction grade application I usually
keep it as a role but I'm going to go
ahead and use this one here first of all
is verified so is the user verified by
default no it is not type Boolean of
course default is false so my user is by
default not verified I will send him an
email in which all he'll click a link
and once you click the link then only
he'll get verified similarly as I was
talking about the role I'll just go
ahead and call this one as is admin and
is admin will be like type Boolean
default will be false and probably
that's it
now again as I mentioned I usually don't
go with the is admin I usually go with
the role because that's a better
approach but again will not go about the
better approach or data modeling in this
case that's uh very basic now comes up
the interesting part now what a lot of
people does is they try to keep their
tokens as a separate model itself I
don't do that usually I try to keep them
all separate because I think somehow
that they are part of user itself and
mongodb is a document database so I
think this is a better approach again I
could be wrong you could be right so
there's a lot of debate about it so the
way how I do it is I keep a couple of
string like forgot password token and
this forgot password token is usually a
type of string and I keep on updating
the values now along with the forgot
password I keep the forgot password
token expiry so forgot
password pass
word
token expire
nah not happy with expire I go with
expiry expiry which is a type of date
similar to that I do have a verify token
as well
very no no suggestions please give me a
suggestion there verify token that is
also a type of string and similar to
that verify token expiry now how does
this token works there's a lot of
mechanics into that and I would love to
share this but this is the whole our
model is now complete now let me take
you back on our excali draw and show you
that how actually the token part and
everything works so for this we need to
understand what are the three parts of
our application so the three part of our
application uh the first one being
the first one is the user wherever or it
would be better to write browser or I'll
just write user slash browser
so whatever makes sense to you so this
is our user and browser so this is first
part of it the second part of the
application is our controllers or you
can say our apis uh I think API would be
a greater name but obviously I would
love to call it as controller but I
think in this case API is also fine and
the third part is actually our database
where all of these things are stored so
if I go back all this data about is
admin forgot password token and all
these things are actually kept up there
now how does this forgot password token
or verify token works that is also a
very interesting use case so I'll just
walk you through so
this thing known as your verify token
this is nothing it's just a field which
holds some string values now obviously
these string values are encrypted that's
why we brought in the B crypt.js and we
love to store the complex things the way
how it works is in your API call if
somebody makes a call to your let's just
say user slash verify so you simply
generate this verify token and this
verify token is going to be long
gibberish string something like this
this is how it usually goes so this is
let's just say a long gibberish thing
now this is generated by API now there
are two portions of it now this only
alone is not generated
this thing is actually one portion of it
is updated into the user's database now
our this model has something inside us
right now it is empty but as soon as
somebody hits that API call that long
generated string is actually copied and
is saved into database of that users
now one portion of this is actually sent
to the user as well all right now API
doesn't keep anything it's just a
business logic it doesn't have the
capability to save anything it just
simply goes ahead and sent one copy to
the database one copy to the user
now what next now what next is once
somebody actually verifies that this
token actually comes back to you now how
it comes back that's we'll study in this
lecture but this might come up into a
URL you can extract it from a URL we
know how to do it it might come up into
a request body as well that's okay we
can also handle that part but the whole
idea is this token actually comes back
to you now once this token comes back to
you in the database we have to find that
where this token is just like we can
find a user based on email just like we
can find a user based on ID we can also
find the user based on this token yep we
can do that now once that particular
user is actually being found and let's
just say you have found this and there
is this user now this user information
comes to your API based on this token
now once this is actually being done you
actually invoke the API Logics and
simply go ahead and certain Fields into
it for example we are talking about
verify you go ahead and update verify as
true so now this is a verified user so
this is how the basic logic of how
verification works somebody clicked on
it you know the request is coming up
from that token now apart from this you
might have noticed that I also keep the
verify expiry as well because I want to
give the user only a certain time
duration when this verification can
happen I don't want it the verification
that I send an email today it happens 30
days after that so I'll definitely don't
want that that's why I keep that
expiration I always bring back the user
only basis on that the token should
match and the time should be certain
limit in under certain limits I'll walk
you through with that as well so this is
the base case of it now with a similar
way
your forgot password token also work
I'll walk you through with that scenario
as well because I can understand this
can be complex so I'll again retrade
that part it will be a revision as well
so I'll just go ahead and remove this
this this and we'll just get back to
this one
all right so what happens in this forgot
password token we can now remove this
part okay so we have a forgot password
token again what is the forgot password
token nothing it just encrypted a long
string a hashed value that's it so this
hash value looks something like this
this can be something like this with few
numbers really long strings something
like that and what's the job of the API
is to send the copies simply it takes
one copy send it to the database I'm
going out there we go and this one copy
is sent to the user browser it doesn't
keep anything for itself it just removes
it API cannot hold it so now user had
this has this token of forgot password
and the DB also has this token or the
forgot password again this is sent to
the user or the browser or you can say
to the email that is also a good word to
have here so now this is being sent to
the email now what next obviously we
have to search it so now this token will
come to you from the user side so user
will hit a route maybe forgot password
whatever the route is it will give you
that a particular long token again I
repeat this token might come up into the
URL in the request body it doesn't
really matter in this case we are
talking about this forgot password so
obviously with forgot password I need
this token and I also need what is the
password that you want to update so that
I can add the us into my field with my
logic so that is there the logic is same
for verify and the forgot password now
what I have to do next I have to take
this long string and I have to search it
here in the database just like I can
search for email I can also search with
the token and this will return you an
user entire user who is having this
token when this user actually comes to
the API the API is perfectly capable
after matching the token and the expiry
that hey the token is valid the expiry
is also valid then it simply goes and
update one field so I can simply go
ahead and say hey update user dot
password that gets a new value whatever
the new encrypted value user has given
you a value you encrypt that and you
update that so you simply go ahead and
simply say updated password password if
I can write that updated password so
that that is all you have to do that's
it you have updated your password so
this is behind the scene logic of how
the verify password Works how the forgot
password work or any other token based
mechanism that you are used to this is
how all of them works
quite a lot of theory isn't it
uh yeah but I hope that you are enjoying
this I hope that I'm able to explain
this so much Basics to you and you are
enjoying that all right so now that my
models are all done now it's time to
open another file my models are there my
database connection is there notice here
the database connection I can just call
this connect and connect to any time
with the database now what's interesting
is go into the app and inside the API we
have users and inside that we have the
sign up and we have this route now this
route is actually empty right now in
this case but you might be wondering can
I create only just one file in the sign
up yep there is no other file you can
create and this might be bringing to
your question another question so I'll
bring this up a lot of notes Here
that I also handle a lot of things so
for example if it is slash API slash
users slash
sign up if this is the case then I have
a lot of things that I handle here for
example uh on the same route how do I
handle the get request or the post
request or the put request or the delete
request so how do I handle all of these
cases now there is a nice way of how you
handle this the standardization of the
apis I'll not talk about too much of the
standardization of API that again
requires a separate course in itself but
the ideal is that you handle all these
things via the request method a lot of
time when we actually teach the tutorial
it's okay then we go ahead and simply
ask them to Simply create routes with a
different controllers like for example
create user or maybe something like we
asked to create update user but the
whole idea is this is not a
standardization approach it's okay for
tutorial part there is no harm in that
but if I go ahead and say simply user
then if it is a get request I should be
getting a user if it is a post request I
should be adding a user if it is a
request I should be updating a user
delete request then I should be deleting
a user so this is a standardized
approach and this exactly is being
followed in the next JS as well a lot of
behind the scene details so all we got
to do is simply write the functions for
the Post method get method and all of
that now the syntax is a little bit you
have to first get it and understand it
once you get one syntax all of them are
exactly same so first we're going to go
ahead and simply bring the connect
that's the most important thing so
connect
and the first time you'll be seeing the
default import statement so yeah this is
the first time you'll be seeing it
from if I can write that
from and this will be coming up notice
here you can write at the rate yep
that's your root directory and then you
can simply go ahead and say Hey I want
to go where should I go
what's the name dbconfig okay DB config
and inside the dbconfig there is this DB
config file okay this is dbconfig.js I
guess let me just check this uh
dbconfig.ts although you don't need to
import the TS but sometimes I have seen
that there are some issues in bug
because I didn't mention a DOT TS a very
rare very rare sometimes it even gives
you problems but it has happened to me
couple of times okay the first thing
that you have to do is simply go ahead
and connect that's it that is it don't
need to do anything no then catch it
just needs to connect but we need couple
of more things as well
the first obvious thing is user we need
model so that we can add things into the
database and that will be coming up
import user and that will be coming up
from at the rate app models and users
make sure you double check this because
I had noticed this this actually creates
a lot of problem just now you have seen
because our model is not coming up from
App model user our model is sitting
somewhere else and that's totally
allowed you can keep it here as well
there's no problem in the app models and
user that is also one way but we're
keeping it all totally outside so in the
models and then we are getting in notice
here this is still going to give you a
problem the reason for that is you need
to give the file name so inside the
model we are calling it as user model so
make sure you are cautious about that
user model that should be happy
okay now the next thing is you need to
grab request and response so in case you
have worked with Express or anything of
a backend you notice everything actually
is dependent on request and the response
you need to take something send
something in the next JS you actually
work with it a little bit different we
go ahead and First grab next request
yeah come on so just me yeah there we go
next request and we also get next
response so these are the two things
which actually helps you to do all of
this they all comes from the next server
just like this we'll be encrypting some
of the passwords so let's go ahead and
import
decrypt Js
and that's coming up from B crypt.js and
what else I guess that's it uh this one
we don't need JWT because we are just
talking about sign up so that's not
required uh it's declared but never used
we'll use that no problem there all
right so now this connection and
everything is done so I'll just keep it
there outside so all the connection
everything is done now the way how you
define a syntax of handling a post
request because data is coming to us so
we'll first say export and then we'll be
using a sync because obviously talking
to database database is another
continent it takes time and then simply
write the function and then what request
you want to handle is it a post request
is it a get request is it a delete
request so whatever that is you just
handle that in my case post makes sense
so I'll just use that then you simply go
ahead and say that hey I will be
handling a request you can handle both
request and response but there is no
need of handling everything here in the
first parameter you can just say I'll
handle the request and then say hey I'll
get the next request just like this and
there we go that's it that is how you
handle and if you want more things to be
handled just create another function
which is post which is get you get the
idea you get the idea now in here the
simplest part is to handle the try catch
via the try catch so I'll just go ahead
and have the try catch and the error is
going to be of type error type any by
the way
not ideal case of handling everything
with any now how we're going to return a
response that's also super easy you
simply go ahead and say next response
and we will not be handling the errors
like this although you can there is no
hard and fast rule but I prefer to send
a Json response with the error message
and status code I think that's that's a
better approach so that's the first part
of it how we'll be handling
now the next question is how we're going
to grab data from the body in case you
have worked with Express or something
request.body was our friend which
actually does that it is almost similar
to that but in here you actually have to
await a little bit so await a request
it's not body.json don't go with these
suggestions it's Json just like this and
we can hold this into a variable let's
call this one as request body just like
this and lot of example you'll see
calling it as request.body I also picked
it up from the dark so yeah all right
notice here it's request.json just like
how it works now further down this you
can actually extract all the variables
that are coming in so we'll be doing a
little bit of the destructuring so from
request
body we need to extract some stuff and
what we'll be extracting is const let's
grab some stuff from request.body I know
that from front-end side I'll be getting
a user name I'll also get an email and I
also get a password because this is the
first time I'm registering a user now
again it makes sense that you first go
ahead and do all the kinds of check if
email is not there if username is not
there if password is not there then go
ahead and throw this response although
we have handled a lot of these error
cases required and all of that in the
Mongoose itself so in the error response
they'll be getting a good message and
all thanks to the custom messages that
we have written here so it is handled a
lot but not entirely so I highly
recommend you do on your own validation
I'll just move on to the basic
validation but before that I'll also do
a console log of uh entire request body
so that we can see that what is
happening not ideal for the production
grade so remove these console logs but
I'll just keep it to check things now
I'll go ahead and first check
check if user already exists very simple
basic check all I have to do is use the
superpower of this user remember this
user is coming up from the Mongoose so
this has a lot of superpower and can
find a lot of things for us so for
example it will say find one and what do
I want to find I want to find an email
so I'll just go ahead and say email and
that's it I want to find most important
thing is this will return you a query if
you don't put up in a weight so this is
a common mistake that a lot of people
are doing these days posting them on
every single platform so put up in a
weight because it's a database call
and we'll just say simply user now if
this returns me something that means
user already exists so all I have to do
is if user is there then simply go ahead
and suggestions please no suggestions
we're going to go ahead and simply say
return
next
response come on now suggestion there we
go Json that user already exists so this
is nice and easy so there we go again
you can make more checks onto this one
I'll not do more I'll just go ahead and
hash the password now
hash password
again this is what the basics will be
doing so we'll be first creating a salt
which is the basic and after the salt we
need to create a hashed password just
like this uh feel free to use any number
of rounds that you want to have uh so
the B Crypt JS library is responsible
for creating the salt and if you'll read
the documentation you'll find it exactly
same the Gen salt will generate a salt
with the 10 rounds and again different
Frameworks and libraries use different
rounds for example Ruby on Rails use 12
rounds nexius and react not react
Express and Mongoose mostly use 10 so
again it's totally up to you a hashed
password we are hashing password we have
to provide two parameter to bcrip.j Hash
the first is the password which we are
grabbing from the request body and then
the salt value so absolutely simple
there is nothing too much Panic about it
now we want to save a user in the
database so we have to create a user
accordingly
so all we're going to do is create a new
user just like this this will have a
username this will have an email and
this will have a password but not the
password that we're getting from request
body but the password that we have
encrypted the hashed password so we'll
be going like this so we'll be saying
hey let's just go ahead and go like that
all right now we'll be storing this into
a variable first so let's just call this
one as
const new user because it's actually our
user to be saved new user whatever you
like now this is nice and easy now all
we have to do is save this to the
database you can do it in one line as
well but I prefer to have more uh
explainable approach of this thing so
I'll just go ahead and say await new
user dot save that's it it's going to
save let's store the response into a
variable maybe you want to save it have
a look on it so I'll just say save the
user again this is a little bit of a
verbose approach but you can do this All
by shortcut as well but it's a tutorial
I need to explain the things so I'm just
keeping it a little bit more verbose now
after this maybe you want to do a
console log of the saved user that's
totally up to you I just keep it so that
I can show you more things and that's it
now apart from this all we have to do is
simply return a response maybe in the
response I'll just go ahead and hit and
enter here and one more
okay
okay let's just go ahead command Z
because I think that is messing it up a
little bit yep it's messing it up I'll
just remove it like this and there we go
so I'll say message is created user
successfully then we'll get no not like
that
success
is true and maybe I want to throw in the
saved user totally up to you how you
want to deal it with this I just want to
go like this
all right so this is my Approach of
saving the user and as you saw that it's
not really that difficult now we
understand how this is going to be all
taken here in the database and
absolutely but one thing that is still
missing is we are not able to send any
data to the page we have to actually
work on this page as well because it's
right now not going to be doing anything
at all so let's go ahead and take care
of this so right now this is the basic
page that we designed a moment ago now a
couple of variables that needs to come
once the user will be signed up I need
to push it to the login page for this I
will be using a router so notice here
this use router now it will come in
handy so I'll say const router use
router I'll use that in a minute I've
already created my state so that I can
actually go ahead and use it but I'll be
creating couple of more states which
will be helpful okay but again you can
optimize this a lot more and a whole lot
of things can go on so I'll just go
ahead and create one more which will be
button
disabled so there we go I'll keep it by
default as false button will not be
disabled I'll not do much here I'll just
change the name of the button on our
front end so if you remember on the
localhost we have the sign up
uh my hopefully my server is not running
I guess
yeah it's not running I just push the
code on the git that's it so by default
it will be saying just sign up so I'll
be changing the text only based on
whether the button is disabled or not so
I'll not do too much but you can go all
fancy with it so that's all the basics
we'll be doing all right now coming up
onto the part that how the things are
going to work now this button state is
all just a fun that we are doing to
understand a little bit more about the
react use States and all of that now
this button will be changed on like
usually what how you want to utilize
this button disabled so this will add
some classes on the button so nobody is
able to press it but as soon as the
button disabled is gone that means
somebody can press it one ideal case is
when there is some values in our field
so one case one a hook that you can use
for this is use effect
so what is going to happen in the use
effect if there is a user uh I'll just
first enter end it so there we go it is
dependent on this user so this is a
dependency array that how should I how
how often should I run this use effect
and I'm able to do all of this because I
have actually enabled use client and I'm
doing this just to show you that I can
do it so this is all dependent on this
user as soon as something change in that
that will run this use effect or
whatever the code you write inside this
use effect callback so I'll just go
ahead and write the very basic of it so
I'll just go ahead and say if user dot
email so there are a lot of fields into
it email email and I'll just check the
length of it
if the length is greater than 0 and wow
suggestions I love that
then I'll check the user.password length
is greater than 0 and the username
length is greater than zero then I'll
set the button as disabled as false
because if the length is greater than 0
the set button should be default to
false let me just check that quickly all
right
and in other cases it should be enabled
yeah because it is set button disabled
if it is true the button is disabled ah
get it sometimes you need to evaluate
yourself as well all right so set button
disable to true in other cases all right
so there we go we can run this and again
this use effect is not available so I
need to go to react and say hey we will
be bringing use effect
and there we go now we can do it and
based on this we can check out some fun
stuff here as well so I'll just go ahead
and change up the text here sign up here
and I'll just cut this out and inject my
variables and based on
button disabled
I'll check that if there is a button
disabled then I'm gonna go ahead and do
something otherwise I'll do something
else so if disable button is
true that means button is disabled so
I'll just say no sign up
and if the button disabled is false
that means button is enabled that means
this time I can do sign up
so there we go just really basic so we
can go ahead and save this let's try to
run that server it's been a while so npm
oops npm run Dev
and let's see how many crashes we are
going to see always expecting the
crashes
all right looks good decent
all right so yeah take some time
okay so we'll do a sign up and there we
go so it says no sign up all right
that's good because right now there is
no value so if I go ahead and say a oh
man the reason why you are not able to
see it is because there's a text color
so
in all of this come on I have to do this
for all of them yeah
okay no no other option we'll just go
ahead and say text Dash black there we
go we have to do this for everyone
text Dash black
one more one more not that much of a big
problem text Dash black
there we go so as soon as I save this
there we go now I can see a and no sign
up still then I go ahead and a and then
I go ahead and a and it changes to sign
up now I can sign up definitely I'm not
checking much of these fields neither on
the backhand side or front-end side that
what should be the minimum length of
password we can do a lot of validation
but this video is little bit beyond the
validations all right so this is the
basic that we have gone through with it
now let's learn that how we can actually
utilize the sign up method because we
haven't talked about it we have this
xios giving us red squiggly line but we
haven't worked on that all right the
basic and the most easiest way is first
have the try catch handle the catch part
and that's the basic sometimes people
actually get this uh on loading as well
maybe you want to show some loading
let's go ahead and do this loading as
well let's go ahead and have a loading
text as well so const and we'll have a
loading
set loading by default it's false So
based on this we can actually render
some variable as well uh maybe in place
of sign up we'll just go ahead and cut
this out inject a variable again and
we'll just check for loading if loading
is true we'll if loading is true we'll
do something otherwise we'll do
something so we can just go ahead and
say sign up
and
in this we can say
processing you can have better Spinners
and loaders but my goal is not to have
you parked down with 1000 different
libraries but to show you more about
next year's we can see this is
processing right now because loading is
true somehow
uh loading
all right why this is loading
okay let's check if loading is true oh
my bad if loading is true this should be
processing
and if it is not true that means loading
is not happening that means user can
sign up all right so at least this also
gives us a check that you can flip the
switch all right good good enough good
enough
so let's go back here in the try catch
and let's also add a finally here you
rarely see the implementation of finally
but in this case finally makes sense
because no matter what happens loading
needs to go away this is the common
syntax
now as soon as you go first let's handle
the catch part because it's easy and in
case you remember I actually asked you
to do something we'll actually handle
that part as well so if you remember I
asked you to have this react hot toast
this is your assignment you have to take
care of how this Library actually works
so the way how it works is you simply go
ahead and say toast and then error and
you can just give it error message
that's how the basically it works now in
here it says hey I know I have no
guarantee that error will have a message
so I'll just go ahead and write in any
here so that it gets away the errors but
also I love to get a console log
because I know I have I have not
perfectly implemented react hot toast
it's assignment for you but just for the
sake of so in this case we'll just go
ahead and say
sign up
failed and we'll also get the error Dot
message in the logs now this log message
will be available to you on the user
side in the browser because it's a use
client all the console log messages in
the API will be available in the bottom
section the terminal because it's on the
server side that's one difference as
well now let's come back on to the
tripod what do you want to try first and
foremost what I want to try is set the
loading that's the basic set loading as
true all right now I want to make a
request so I'll just use xeos and I want
to make a post request from the xeos now
make sure you provide this URL very
carefully you don't need to provide the
entire URL the next JS is already
configured for hitting your own route so
slash API slash users the folder you
have defined let's check it one more
time API slash users so there's an S and
then you can simply go ahead and hit a
sign up route so I'll just go ahead and
hit the sign up now I'm also taking
along with me all the data which is user
which is stored in here so I'm just
taking all of this and obviously once
this is being done this will take some
time so I'll just go ahead and await for
this one and I'll hold the response in
some variables so I'll just go ahead and
say response
the punch
response there we go
all right so this looks okay now I also
want to see that what kind of response
is coming up so it would be properly
better for me if I go ahead and say sign
up success and I just go ahead and say
response.data I should be getting a
response.data.message as well but let's
just say I want to get a response data
only
and then the most important thing is I
need to push the user onto a new page
and that is exactly why I have this
router sitting behind sitting idle doing
nothing so I'll just go ahead and say
hey router just go ahead and push the
user to slash login make sense
all right so that is it that is it if we
haven't mistake done any typo attempted
import error xeost did we made any
mistake typos
and why is it having an issue because it
shouldn't be like that
there we go now it should be happy why
did it added these extra
curly braces no idea about that all
right so this should be all let's hit a
refresh just for the sake of
self-satisfaction I'll just go ahead and
add a username with the name of one
email will be one at the rate gmail.com
and the password will be one two three
four five six and let's try a sign up
processing working nice we have been
redirected that is also nice let's go
ahead and check out in the database in
the database and oops uh so let me go
ahead give me a second I'll just go
ahead and sign in again probably just
redirected me I need to actually use my
emails so I'll just keep you up here
till the meantime you can just hang out
with me chit chat with me no worries it
will just take a seconds I'm just
logging it into my detail I don't want
to expose that email so that is the only
reason I'm just having this ah didn't
bother it much so let's go back up here
and going back all right so this is
where we are and we'll just go into the
database
and there we go we can browse the
collection
what did we name this project
and there we go this one we named it as
test all right we should be naming it
better but anyways this is also going to
work so we can see we have one one at
the rate gmail.com is it visible yep
little bit is verified as false is admin
is false the rest of the fields since
they don't have any value they are not
being displayed here let's try with one
more user so I want to go with the sign
up page let's sign up to as well two
this will be two two two at the rate
gmail.com at least we need two users one
two three four five six nice very secure
password
sign up this time it's quick because
obviously first time it takes time and
you get the idea it is always like that
let's hit a refresh
and it should be getting us two users
hopefully there we go so we can see that
it is not that much difficult to
actually get the data into the database
let me go on to code base there we go
and we can see that some of the users
that we are getting these users are
actually on the backend side so we are
getting that but not only that we must
be getting some of the users in response
on the console as well there we go we
can see sign up success which gives us
an object and this object has a message
which is coming up our own message from
the backend user created successfully
then we said saved user is getting us
that's nice and then we have success
true they can be in any order so it
doesn't really matter so there we go
it's working nice and we can also see
the difference between the messages that
are coming up some are being read on the
backend side some are on the front-end
side if it is a console log in the use
client obviously it will be in the
browser otherwise if it is in the API
route usually that will be on the back
end part of it or the back end side of
it so this is how we can actually go
ahead and and create a simple uh sign up
you can say uh now the next thing that I
want to do is uh similarly take down the
route for the login as well the login is
almost similar you'll find so much of
similarity there but I'll still do it in
front of you so that you get more idea I
will grab all of this because yeah we'll
be a little bit uh lazy you can say
there's no good word of putting it all
right so I'll just paste it so we have
all the things make sure use client is
the most important thing again this is
all happening in the route not in the
front end part we are still in the route
of login so the first thing we have to
do is connect with the database every
single time we have to connect I have
spent a little bit good amount of time
in debugging when all I was doing is
missing disconnect
all right so connect who said to bring
it to you from HTTP 2. I am bringing
this from ah why oh my bad we actually
brought this in from the wrong place my
bad my bad we should be bringing in from
the sign up this is where the real stuff
is so copy this
and paste it there we go
okay so now notice here this is the B
Crypt this saying uh cannot find a
declaration file for module the whole
idea this is saying is I don't know the
types about it so all you can do is
click on this bulb and say install the
types about the big crypt.js once you do
this it actually install additional
types for you and get rid of the error
no need to worry about that part in case
this red squiggly line is bothering you
too much get with that or fix your
linting
okay uh this is good all right so now we
can go ahead and connect
there we go connect in with the database
again
this is my login route so async export a
sync function uh post is good request
header looks great suggestions love them
it increases my speed of explaining and
writing the things so much okay all
right the basic starts again so there is
a try catch the catch is any and in here
we can just go ahead and send any
response that you want we want to Simply
return a next response so return
suggestions no suggestions
requestresponse dot Json error message
status 500 happy with that done with the
catch part now coming up on to the
tripart most of this is going to be very
similar what we have seen But there are
some changes not too much first is how
we can get data from the request so it's
really same request dot Json this will
be giving you all the data so how we can
grab this we can grab request body from
it and we'll be destructuring some
values so let's go ahead and restructure
email and password from request.body uh
basic so there we go why are you
bothered again
all these structure elements are unused
come on let me type first too much
aggressive let's go ahead and do a
console log
and we'll be saying request.body that's
fine okay to give us just the detail
that whether it is working or not now
obviously when we are logging uh into
this one so we have to check whether the
user exists or not so check if user
exists or not otherwise we'll throw him
in some error so we'll be saying that
hey how can I do it again the user which
has all the superpower I can go ahead
and say find one and this is bad find
one and I want to find it based on the
email that's it that is all I want to do
if I found it I'll just go ahead and
store that into a user variable but
since this is a database call make sure
that is awaited
all right looks nice and if I don't find
any user then I'll just request send a
response that user doesn't exist so much
time is being saved all right but don't
rely totally on suggestion they are
horribly wrong sometimes
all right so what I want to do next this
is a login so I've checked the user now
I want to check the password all right
so I'll just go up here why are you
bothered I have used the email just here
email does not exist on Typecast it
exists I know the email is coming up and
I think we need to handle an await yep
my bad almost missed that okay sometimes
the linting is good okay now we want to
check if the password is correct that is
super easy we can simply go ahead and
validate the password based on the B
crypt.js it has a method which says dot
compare and we can compare the password
which is coming up from the request.body
and if you remember this user is coming
up from the database this is also
bringing the password there is a field
in the model user dot password so I
don't have to do any magical thing
becrypt.js can compare it it knows the
stuff how much the default values and
everything so it will handle the stuff I
don't have to worry about that now if
the password is not valid I have to send
a response that hey you have an invalid
password I won't be doing that now in
case that is all done now let's prepare
the data because the way how it works is
it's actually really really simple if
you have never done this kind of a thing
it's actually super easy to work on with
now once everything is verified that
your user exists your password is
correct then we actually create a token
this token is created by uh simply Json
web token we encrypt that obviously it's
not just a plain token and we send this
token into users cookies not in the user
local storage because you can manipulate
the token there but we can send the
secure cookie to the user and then later
on whenever we wish we can access those
cookies as well so it helps as a Bridger
to verify whenever the user we want to
verify it just has the ID of the user
but it can have a lot of payload into
that you can send a user ID email admin
type whatever you wish you can send all
this data as a payload to that that's
exactly what we'll be doing next
all right so moving up here first of all
what we're going to do is create this
token data so I'll just go ahead and say
create token data now how we are going
to do this is we'll be first having this
ID
and one more important thing whenever
you look into this notice this uh every
single time a user is created it's with
underscore ID that's what the ID is
there so this is what exactly I'm
bringing in although every single detail
you can bring in from with this ID again
you just have to type in this uh find
one that's it based on ID you can find
anything but it is no harm that if you
want to send extra things like user dot
a username or maybe you want to send his
email I'll just send this much but you
can definitely send a lot more than this
now once you have done this then
obviously it's time to Simply go ahead
and create the token and send this token
as well so first and foremost let's this
is token data only we haven't created
the token now we are going to go ahead
and create the token the token this is
how it is created all we have to do
again notice here there's a problem why
because suggestions don't always rely on
them you have to actually import this so
I have to say import JWT and that's
going to come up from Json web token
again and could not find the Declaration
so I'll just click here where's the bulb
here it is and install all the types
don't want to see the Reds quickly lines
okay so all it does is obviously uh the
process.env JWT secret key that's not my
key my data is actually stored I have
actually created a sample file for you
so that I don't have to Peak it again
and again where it is somewhere here uh
sample.env uh so hitesh subscribe app
you should do that
my token secret is here so I'll just
copy this go back here this is not my
this is how it works but still it will
give you some of the issues that hey
what is this and all of that I'm 100
sure that this is coming in so I'll just
put an exclamation That hey I know this
is coming in so all you have to do is
this takes some time to create the token
so make sure there is an await here JWT
has a method of DOT sign to create
signed token it takes the token data
this is all the data that we have you
can directly inject a object here there
is no problem and then
process.env.token dot secret how long
you want it to stay there expire in one
hour I'll not do one hour I'll stay for
one day at least totally up to you how
you want to do that now all we have to
do is token is created but this token is
not yet set into the user's cookie the
way how we do it first there are a
couple of steps involved is we have to
create a next response so we'll be just
going ahead and say hey we want to have
a response we are not sending this
response yet we are just creating it and
the way how we create it is simply
uh next response and it will be dot Json
there we go I have an object like this
there we go and in here we'll say
messages login successful that's a nice
message and success true I think that is
enough but now the great advantage of
this is if you have this response this
response right now is a type of next
response which can actually go ahead and
access your cookies not your the user's
cookie so I'll just go ahead and say hey
response
did I mistyped it yeah response
response response
come on too many suggestions response
dot cookies there is a s here don't go
with the suggestion bad suggestion here
response dot cookies and you can set the
cookie similarly you can also get the
cookies so I'll just use a set here and
for this I'll be using token token HTTP
only yeah that's that's fine I would
love to have it on to a separate line I
think that will make sense for me at
least
there we go we don't need to set even
the path that is obviously cookies yeah
Escape that escape that don't need that
all right so this is what we have now we
have response dot cookies being set now
this response has already sent the
cookies and everything now you can
return the response back
return response now as you'll be
returning the response it will be doing
all the things it will be sending the
message it will be handling the cookies
all the things are being done so that is
how it is being done
ah quite a lot quite a lot but I think
that's good now just like we did here uh
we need to now go into the login page
.tsx yep we haven't actually worked a
little bit onto this page so uh now we
need to do exactly all the same kind of
thing that we did in the past yeah
Basics just like that all right so we'll
start this time we'll do it a little
faster because I think we have studied a
lot all right so first thing uh router
because we'll be pushing it to some
different page so const router use
router there we go first thing done we
have got the state we'll be getting the
button disabled and the loading as well
so we can copy this all suggestions I
love that don't need to even copy paste
that loading there we go
okay all right this is all done very
quickly on login okay how do we want to
handle the login part first what we want
to do is exactly same use effect hook we
want to actually use that and since this
is a use client or the client side or
the client component we can actually do
this so use effect and I'll just close
it first
and then the user it's dependent on the
user and it's not available so react
please give me
use effect
there we go and in here we'll be using
the exact same logic
so let's just go ahead and use it like
this if user dot email now it's
suggesting me nicely there we go and we
can also have an else part
and we can have set button disabled to
true
button disabled is true that means
button is disabled okay that's correct
and sometimes confused in that so yeah
re-evaluating yourself is not a bad idea
okay although it is giving me the entire
bunch of code but I'll prefer to write
it
so try catch catch error would be any
and all I have to do is simple
assignment for you but first I'll do a
console log so that I also know that
what is happening so console.log login
failed error.message that's nice but
we'll also do the toast so that you can
verify the toast messages and stuff
right now the toasting is not working I
have not properly Incorporated it but
hey and we'll also go with the finally
how can we forget that finally
set loading uh bad there we go
es like this
and a suggestion no suggestion there we
go okay so we have finally this set
loading as false that's nice okay Meat
part the how we're going to handle this
request super simple first start your
loading there we go and keep it as true
so that we know something is happening
then we have to use a weight because it
might take some time and then we have
xeos
axios will make a post request here so
super simple where it is going to make a
post request slash API slash users slash
login that's the route it will also take
the users with them so that is nice and
easy and there we go
and looks like there's an extra yep
there we go we also want to store that
response so we'll be saying const
response
and again you can dump down this
response into console log you can post
up a toast message whatever you like
I'll do a console log because this is
important and we should be seeing this
data as of now learning phase learning
phase and then obviously we can hope
first before we do router push this is
great suggestion by the way but we'll be
doing a toast
dot Success login success you can
Implement that just a few lines of code
and then we're going to go ahead and
router.push we don't want to push it we
will be pushing it on to
slash profile Maybe
yeah do we have profile pages
did I taught you that
uh yep I I taught you that yeah profile
page so we'll be redirecting into
profile all right so let's see if this
actually works in action or how many
errors we are going to get
okay okay xcos is not exported this is
again xcos problem
there we go
save this hopefully things are okay
expect errors that's the only advice I
can give
okay now we are on to the login page
just to refresh can I go into sign up
yep visit login
yeah working nice so the email is one uh
my bad email also needs to go ahead and
work with this
nobody is able to see this because of my
bad CSS text Dash
black
and the password is also going to have a
text Dash black
should be okay now also let's since we
are here let's also change the thing so
login will be based on
not like this we'll be having a loading
so if loading is true
that means processing
otherwise we are doing what
we are login
okay and button disabled
I'll not do this you can do this
all right so I'll just go ahead and say
one at the rate gmail.com and we'll be
having one two three four five six the
securest password ever let's try login
and no I don't want to save it
did we call it even
uh there we go on click login
on click
login
so all right so this should be working
do we have any data okay so we are
receiving the data till here that is
nice
but it's not getting redirected
okay
we should be getting a redirection
log in don't want to save this let's
check out and let's see what are the
mistakes that we're doing console log
okay the server is
okay so we are getting a lot of Errors
probably we should be going back onto
the code file there is a lot of
okay uh we need to check out what is
going on wrong API slash user slash
login
that seems to be correct
and since we are receiving the data on
the backend side that means at least
this one two three four five six one at
the red gmail.com do we have one at the
rate gmail.com and the passwords are
coming in okay at least we are getting
this on the backend side so now the
problem is technically on the backend
side so two times we have requested the
body
and we were able to encrypt that
and we were able to actually get this
saved user as well
okay
oh I'm checking on to the sign up route
I should be checking into the login
route
I should be in the login route did I
made a mistake
okay so here is this this is coming up
from here so we are getting this
request.body and now we are getting this
so we should be actually checking this
token data we are getting the user no
user here we are getting the user again
this debugging will take some time so
this is the real world development
that's how it happens and let's see if
the user is actually getting some tokens
so let's see in the application
and here in the localhost we don't get
any token all right so this is going to
take a little while to debug so let me
go ahead and quickly debug this and will
tell you what is actually happening here
Welcome to the Real World development
this is how it happens and Yes actually
I found the bug it was nothing I just
forgot to save the file there was a big
white dot I couldn't see it and that
actually turned out and notice here I
didn't change anything I was just
logging out a few things to check out
whether user exist or not not even a
single line changed but yes I made a
couple of requests then I realized I
need to actually restart the server that
is all that is all I did and nothing
changed and it works nicely now I'll I
don't have a log out route yet we'll do
that soon but this is how we have I can
go into my application now just after
restarting I can see there is a token
being included up here and I'm also
getting redirected to profile but there
is a problem there's a lot of problem
here I can still go back to my login
route this shouldn't be happening and I
can directly access these profile which
shouldn't be happening if I'm not logged
out so there is no controlling mechanism
right now also there is no log out
mechanism right now now I'll obviously
push this code so let's do it right now
in fact so I'll just go ahead and push
all of this yep all of this and we'll
say
sign up
and login
complete good
I'll just complete this commit this and
obviously I'll push it
why don't you use command line I don't
it's just easier it's fun so I'm just
going with that
so uh what we have done right now and
what position we are that's the most
important to evaluate right now so let's
just go ahead and quickly evaluate this
so we are at a position now our front
end is working our back end is working
we are able to register a user in the
database we have tried that couple of
times it works and we are also able to
log in a user there was a small hiccup
where I paused for a minute but again it
was nothing more I just had to save and
restart the server so once I restarted
it worked absolutely fine also I'm
pushing the code in the GitHub as well
so that you can also see and check out
what is happening how is it happening
and all of that now there are a couple
of challenges in front of us first of
all there is no logout button so we need
to design that we also don't have any
kind of a mechanism to stop the user
from visiting the profile if they are
not authenticated and if they are
authenticated they have the token we
have no way to stop them and protect the
routes that the logged in user should
not be seeing the sign up and the login
page he should be seeing just the
profile and all of these pages so we
need to find a way and of course I'm
talking about middleware so we'll be
talking about Dem so this is all what we
will be doing in the upcoming videos I
hope you are enjoying them I'll take a
small pause it's already like four
o'clock in the night or in the morning
so I'll record the rest of the videos
tomorrow so just stay tuned hit that
subscribe I would be super super helpful
if you drop me a tag note on Twitter or
LinkedIn there's so much effort that is
going on in that so in case you wish you
can do that otherwise it's totally fine
let's catch up in the next video or
after a break and finish up our
middleware and remaining of the part
let's see you in the other side of the
video or the next video whatever that is
all right hey there everyone hitesh here
one more time into the next year's
Series so what we were doing in the next
year series it's tough to remember just
kidding just kidding I exactly know what
we were doing in the last video and yes
in this video we'll be taking this a
step further so we have achieved the
goal of signing up the user logging in
the user even producing a token and
storing that token into the user cookies
but right now there are a couple of
issues that we want to take down the
first one being some of my pages are not
protected I want to protect them and
obviously the middleware will kick in
here the middleware how it works in
nexgs is little different so you need to
understand that part as well other
couple of other use cases as well which
I'll discuss in this video and on top of
that we want to Simply achieve a route
where we can have slash me or something
where anybody can get their own
information from the database right now
we don't have ton of information but
whatever the information is we would
love to extract that and obviously we
need to click up with the log out route
as well we haven't worked on that so
we'll be working on that as well I think
that's enough for this video and uh we
will see if there is a little bit more
to explore or something we'll definitely
go ahead and do that as well all right
so let's share the screen here so this
is what we have been doing now let's run
this first and foremost npm run Dev so
that we can see what is happening how is
it happening and is it all okay so if I
just go ahead and refresh this hopefully
this is booking Yep this is working
let's try to change the number with some
name yeah bits working but this is
nothing is protected I can still go
ahead and visit the login page as well
so everything is just back and pass and
forth let's also see let's also try to
log in again let me see the database we
have two at the rate gmail.com so let's
go ahead and try to log in with that so
we'll just go with the two two at the
rate gmail.com because I set up the
expiry time for one day it's it is not
here 24 hours but still I would love to
just set it up password very secure one
one two three four five six very very
secure one let's login it's processing
nice and we are redirected to the
profile page let's right click inspect
is there a shortcut of going directly
into the application just let me know if
you know in the comment section so I
have the token so that is all clear that
is that part is still working nicely so
let's go back and let's see how we can
do that now first thing that I would
like to take down is a log out button
that how we can actually have a log out
so for this I have to create a log out
route should be fairly simple obviously
we need to First create a backend
portion of it then we need to call that
log out button or that method or that
API route from the front end part of it
so let's start with the backend in the
apis we have user slash login sign up
we'll create another one which is for
logout so let's create another folder
and obviously without any
thought we'll just call it as log out we
know this is a back end so we know this
is going to be route dot TS there we go
now basics of this logout is going to
remain same we don't need to create any
post requests for that because the way
how this is going to do a log out is
simply just clear out the token that you
have there are a lot of ways how people
do it some people actually create a
token and save the token expiration time
as well refresh token there are a lot of
ways I will be going with the basic I
want to just clear out the token now in
order to clear out the token there is
nothing too much to worry about I'll
just first bring the next response
because that will be doing this
and we will be using next response
majorly requests no not request okay
let's go ahead and do this export
obviously this will be a sync
uh function I'll just use the get
request for that
get and we don't need
any of this here so we anybody can just
make a get request just directly that's
that's it all right so how we are going
to log out first and foremost is go
ahead and work on with the try catch the
catch part is easy so we'll do that so
let's try with the try catch catch and
then we'll be saying error that could be
any suggestion please
no suggestion there we go so and we'll
be saying next response we won't be
dealing up with the errors suggestions
are good but they're not always the best
I will be having a Json error response
just like that and we are having an
extra dot all right so that part is done
now only thing that's remaining is
create a response which is capable of
removing the cookies why this is giving
me a problem
is it extra
yeah this one was extra all right
so let's create a response how do we
create a response
response if I can write that
and we simply go ahead and use the next
response and with this we want to create
a Json remember we are not returning the
response yet we are just trying to
create a response object so with this
I'll hit an enter just like this we'll
create a message of logout successful
and a success of true also I want to
send
success of true and that is it now this
is my response this response now since
it's a response of type next response
this can actually interact with my
cookies so I can go ahead and say hey
response go ahead and interact with
cookies there is an S at the end of it
and then we can go ahead and use a set
and that's it so what we are doing here
is
a response now this should be a smaller
response
so token we are setting the cookie token
as empty and we are also setting some of
the options here which are HTTP true and
expire we are just expiring it right now
immediately although there is no need of
this expiration because just HTTP true
will actually do the job but anyways if
we are just doing it that's also don't
forget to return the response because
right now we have done a lot of work but
we haven't returned the response and
that is it now you are completely
capable of logging out the user but the
point is how you are going to do this
log out because there is right now no
place where this logout actually works
so you need to find a place where this
logout actually works so I'll walk you
through that you can just choose any
page and can do a log out there
the logout that we'll be doing is going
to be simply on which page we should be
doing it that's a confusing statement
I'll be doing it in the profile not into
the ID so in case you remember we have
this profile and we have the slash ID
wherever you wish you can do this I'll
actually do this directly into the
profile again there is no strong Choice
there you can definitely inject a header
a navigation bar can put a button there
that's not my goal my goal is to get you
familiarized and comfortable with next
shares so a button wherever that is you
know now you now know how that is going
to work so in this profile page let's go
ahead and add a button first we're going
to do is simple an HR
so there we go and after this let's go
ahead and add a button so we'll just go
ahead and say hey Button this button is
going to say logout
all right and we'll add couple of
classes here as well so that button at
least looks decent so we'll be having uh
I'll happy I'll be happy with the
suggestion whatever they provide us all
right let's see if that actually works
I'll say yeah that's a decent button if
I can just add a little bit of the
margin on the top
margin top four
yep I'm happy with this button now this
button alone is not going to work
definitely we need to set up an on click
on that so on click we'll be calling
this one as log out this reverse
approach is always good because first
when you actually click this or declare
this method on click automatically the
suggestions are improved so that's why I
love this all right so let's create a
method of this so const log out and
we'll be showing like this all right now
before we do this obviously we need to
make this because right now this is a
client not a client component this is a
server component so let's go ahead and
create this as a client how do we do
this a simple uh decorator decorator-ish
I will be saying use client there we go
now this is a client component what do
we need in this we need xeos for that so
we'll be saying axios from axios that's
the first part we'll be also redirecting
the user or probably providing some
linking as well so we'll be using this
next link
there we go and what else
I think that is it I think that is it
all that we need all right so how do we
log out a user really simple just go
ahead and simply have a try catch we
have done this many times so that should
be all easy for you now and for the
error part we'll be doing a console log
of the error Dot message but I'll also
give you an assignment as well we also
need to provide an any here
and after this we'll be having a message
which will be a toast
Dot error
suggestions please no suggestions
and here we can say error.message
obviously we haven't brought in the
toast so I'll just bring in the toast
you decide how the properly how is the
proper way to bring it up
so toast and that is from react toastify
not reactors if I react hot toast
there we go this is obviously not a
proper implementation but I'll just
leave this as a simple exercise for you
now how do we do this make a simple uh
get request that's it so we'll be saying
axios
uh dot get request because that's what
we are handling where does this get
request go it into slash API slash users
slash
log out this is where it goes and again
this is asynchronous Operation so we
need to provide an await as well this
logout is also not a synchronous so
let's go ahead and add this a sync so
that it's happy you can actually trap
the response as well in case you wish
but I don't think that is required so if
you wish you can actually provide better
messages with that but I'll go ahead and
say toast or successful obviously this
is not going to print it anywhere but I
also want to push the router somewhere
so we haven't used the router because
once user is logged out he should be
pushed back to login page
so we'll be saying import
use router from next router okay I'm
happy with this and let's go ahead and
say I want to create router from use
router nice and this router will be
capable of pushing to slash login
all right so looks okay to me let's try
let's test this out and see how many
bugs and errors we have got all right so
okay next router not mounted
all right why the next router is not
mounted that's ah my bad because this
used router is not from router this is
from navigation
I told you we actually got this bug many
many times let's go all right looks
happy now let's go ahead and try ah is
there some video recording issue let's
see if we have this token uh do we have
the token token token token
and I don't have a token that's good
that's good that means I'm properly
logged out so our logout functionality
is working that's that's good to know
all right so now that our logout
functionality is working
uh let's go ahead and work on that how
the middleware actually works for this
we have to actually study a little bit
we have to close all of this and this
let's study the middleware
and here it is this is file not found so
I'm going to go ahead and say I want to
study middleware thanks for
understanding my typos so now it says
that middleware allows you to run code
before a request is completed so
obviously this is exactly what I want to
do is before when my request is
completed I want to run something the
advantage of this my request doesn't
reach to the completion phase it
actually is being checked intermediately
in between so if somebody is not
authorized to visit the profile page it
will stop it before doing that if
somebody is not authorized to visit the
login page the user who is already
logged in so I can just stop him before
visiting that page and I can redirect
him to some other page so that's the
goal of it so that's a nice one before
completing a request
and let me Zoom this again then based on
incoming request you can modify the
response by rewriting redirecting modify
the request or response headers
sometimes we inject some things in the
headers as well for example maybe user
ID so some things you want to inject in
the response headers or the request
header you can do that or you can
redirect this modify this however you'll
go with that a middleware run before the
cached content and routes are matched so
this is what they say I use the file
middleware.ts now this is a really
important word here you have to have to
use this as middleware.ts there is no
exception in that there is no other file
name that you can use it needs to go
into I'll show you where it needs to
exactly go and how it runs so don't
worry on that part although it is
mentioned that it goes the same level as
Pages app or source so we obviously need
to put it inside the source we are
talking everything about the source if
applicable yes source is applicable for
us so we need to put it into the root of
source not the root of project remember
this okay and now how does the
middleware looks this is how it looks in
fact instead of talking about it here we
can just copy it that would be great and
we can simply go up and talk about it so
let me go back my code editor here it is
again as I told you it is inside the app
directory just to show you again Yep
this is inside the source so not in the
app inside the source all right
so we'll just right click on the source
create a new file this will be middle
middleware dot TS or JS whatever you're
using I'm using TS obviously I'll be
using the TS you can copy and paste the
code which we just copied here just a
moments ago and this is exactly how your
middleware looks like now there are two
parts of the middleware the first
portion of it is the logic part and the
second part is the matching part that on
what route you want to match and you
want to run your middleware so you can
define a lot of things here so what I'll
do is instead of giving it as a string
like this you can actually give it an
array and it will match all of this that
is what I found in the documentation and
I found it much more useful so the route
that I want to match is Slash and by the
way there is also something more
interesting in the darks so there is a
pattern matching as well so you can
match the file patterns as well for
example here you can say slash about
Slash colon path and whatever the path
comes of asterisk means anything you can
also match the paths like this like this
so this there is a regex that you can
involve there's a lot of this so you can
see somewhere here
let me zoom out so somewhere here they
actually mentioned that hey you can
match a lot of paths a lot of these
details so all of them are mentioned up
here I'll just go with the basics that I
want to match so I want to match uh this
one I also want to match
slash profile you can match slash
profile slash anything as well that
comes up I also want to match if
somebody is visiting slash login login
and I also want to match slash sign up
okay uh these are the paths that I'm
worried as of now if I have more I can
come back in the middleware and can just
simply write the code for that super
easy so this part is a matcher I hope
that is clear now now let's go back on
to this part I'll just remove this
comment somehow they're bothering me a
little okay
so we have this function middleware and
right now it's redirecting just the
response and we'll just remove
everything what is it is returning
because we want to write our own logic
now what do we want to do now we have
couple of paths which are public paths
for example login and your sign up these
are public paths if somebody has the
token he should not be able to access
those public paths all right and there
are some parts which are protected path
so somebody who is
not allowed or who is not logged in he
should not be seeing profile so
something like that so first we need to
find out that how we can find out what
are the paths because right now we have
no access to the paths and luckily for
us this next request actually gives us a
lot of thing uh next request by the term
next request I mean to say this request
so this will be helping us in finding on
what path you are so you can go ahead
and declare a simple path variable just
like this and this request has access to
this next URL dot path name yep that is
that is so simple and no it is not a
client side or a client component this
is how it always needs to be so once you
have this now you can match that what is
your path name so we'll be declaring
that some of the paths are public and
some of the paths are not public so we
just need to find out which one are
public so const is
public but and for the public path what
we're going to do is we'll just check if
the path is equals to login or the path
equals to sign up I think these are the
two public paths we are worried about
login and sign up so this should not be
visible to somebody who has token all
right
so it's public path again if it is login
then it will be true if it is sign up
then also it will be true now next thing
is we need to extract the token now this
is very common we have already seen that
while injecting the token that this
request is completely capable of going
into the user's cookie and we can
extract the token from it super simple
we can go ahead and say hey request just
access the cookies and from that just
like we were using set we can actually
use the get method of this and we can
grab the token now this token might be
there might not be there but if it is
there so optionally it might be there
that's why the optional we can extract
the value or we can just provide the
empty one so in any case there is a
variable known as token which has some
value either the actual token value or
completely empty that's that's fine
okay now I have two variables here and I
can decide based on them that whether
should somebody should be able to access
a path or not so if the path is public
and you are having the token that means
you should not visit the login you
should not be able to visit sign up so
let's go ahead and code out that so
we're going to go ahead and say if the
path is public is public path and you
have token then I would love to redirect
you now the redirect response is is like
that but there are a couple of other
ways as well how you can actually
provide that this is also good there is
no problem in it and you'll also see
some of the documentation code that is
written somewhat a little bit different
in this there you can directly use the
redirect there is no problem I haven't
found any if you find any let me know in
the comment section but you can actually
create a new URL that is what I found
and new URL
no suggestions are not good so I'll just
go ahead and say hey this guy needs to
redirect somewhere we need to redirect
him somewhere because he's trying to
access a sign up and login so I don't
want that so let's redirect him on to
slash that's it and then the second is
you have to request use request and then
we can say dot next URL so I found this
is a little bit tiny better this one
needs to be request
request
come on can't I write request all right
so again you can directly use a redirect
and can work with that there is no
problem with that I found this one a
little bit more reliable but again I'll
check out documentation as in the next
years things are evolving so I'm just
also learning as as we go so this is
first path we have handled we have
rededucted the authenticated users to
the slash of the application or in case
you want to redirect him to slash
profile uh that's your choice totally
your choice maybe dashboard whatever it
is that's up to you
now what if the URL is not public and
token is not there so in that case
obviously you should log in first so
we'll just go with that if
uh
there is no public path and
there is no token
so in that case we'll be just
redirecting him to login and then again
we'll be using the same format request
dot next URL so that it automatically
moves to the next URL and it looks like
we are having some issues with the curly
braces
should be happy now
yeah the indentation is messed up
it shouldn't be like that
I think this one can go here and that
will do a little bit cleanup
yeah I think better all right so now we
can see that this is all there and let's
see if we can still visit the profile
let's save this and let's see how many
errors we got
uh looks like a good day no errors and
let's go back to our application okay
let's try to visit
profile
okay I'm not able to visit profile uh
what if I visit profile and Slash hitesh
I can still visit it because I haven't
mentioned that after the profile am I
looking for all the path remember we saw
in the documentation we can use Asterix
and all those rejects to do so but I'm
happy with this this is a simple
assignment for you but I cannot visit
the profile because that is now
protected now let's see the login
version of it so I'll just go ahead and
say 2 at the rate gmail.com password
secure one you know it one two three
four five six uh login processing and
now we are on the login page can I still
visit the login
uh no I'm redirected to the slash which
is home uh but I can actually go ahead
and visit the profile as well we should
get a profile link here on the home page
as well but anyways
ah it's fine it's fine we Now understand
that how we can extract and write a
middleware as well so that's that's a
good start now one more thing is notice
here that we are able to grab the token
as well can we extract some data from
the token as well because yes it was us
who actually designed this token so we
can definitely uh 100 get some uh data
from the token as well let's go ahead
and try this out let's go ahead and
create an API route for it so inside the
API users and let's create a new folder
what should I call it a user
a me user
and me yeah whatever the naming
convention you want to follow you can go
with that I'll probably go with me I
think that's okay
and then here we'll have a new file so
we'll be having route dot TS there we go
now how we can grab this information all
right now this grabbing the information
is going to be done probably multiple
times because we will have the token now
we know how we can extract the cookies
and token and token if you remember if
you forgot that let me remind you again
at the time of login we actually
injected a lot of information in this
token I'll just close this one this is
the token data so I can technically
extract all this information if I know
this token secret which I know because I
created it so I can actually do this now
I can do it directly here as well or I
can create a helper method which can
help me to extract this token so maybe
later on at some point if I want to use
it I can call this method so time to go
into helpers let's go up here
and in the helpers we have this we have
no helpers as of now that's so sad we
should be having some more helpers so
let's create a new file and let's call
this one as why it's not writing ah
there we go now it's writing so we can
say get data from token very liberative
dot TS of course
okay how we can grab the token data now
get token data is super super simple
just a few lines of codes I'll do that
quickly again this requires the next
request otherwise how we will be doing
it
all right and also we'll be needing JWT
JWT suggestions from Json web token now
let's go ahead and simply export a
function which we'll be calling it as
get data from token very liberative I
like that and we can have requests just
like this and we'll close this
all right how we can get that obviously
we'll do a try catch the catch part is
super easy super simple we can go ahead
and get any and we can say
throw
not like that
throw come on I can write that and throw
a new error and we'll be throwing an
error message all right that's all we'll
be doing now how we can grab this we can
simply go ahead and say hey request
you can access the cookie you can get
the token value just like this or there
might be a case where it is empty so
we'll just go ahead and use this and
we'll store this
uh token into a variable or you can call
this as encoded token because right now
the value is encoded now we need to get
a decoded token as well so for that I
can use this JWT and this JWT has the
option of dot verify not only it
verifies the token but it also actually
extracted the information as a response
of this function so I can just go ahead
and say process
token and then process.env this is not
my variable I have created a sample EnV
for you so that we can actually grab
this variable from here I'll not open
mine one because there's a password in
that
so I'll just go ahead and paste this
make sure you follow this exclamation as
well if you are in the typescript now as
I told you this actually contains a lot
of information so you can call this one
as d
coded token because it is now having
this information and you can extract
this information now it's up to you what
do you want to return you can return the
entire decoded token or you can just
extract the ID from it now we have to
check that what we actually injected
into this one in order to extract this
so I need to go into my app API and
login route Let's see we injected this
ID which is actually user.underscore ID
okay so we are happy with this all the
keys that you are setting that needs to
remain same ID username email so this
key is really important so we'll be
simply going ahead and getting it like
that now this is going to give you a
problem because there is no surety that
the ID will be here because it doesn't
know the data type of it I'll not
declare any types here that's not my
goal so I'll just inject an any here not
a good idea I explicitly say do this in
my typescript series but we'll do it
here all right so now that this method
is available for me which is uh get get
data from token now we can actually go
back into the me route again I'll just
close this login one so that we don't
get confused let's import this method
and simply work with that so we'll just
say get
data from token so there we go we got
this method here and we'll be needing
the request and response because this
method is dependent on this request
somebody needs to send it there so we'll
be saying hey import give me uh not like
that yeah give me next request and
response from the next server uh we'll
also be needing the user
user
and that user will come up from Models
user model I think that's correct
let me check that
so we are having this models and inside
the models user models okay that's
correct that's correct and we'll be
needing the database connectivity as
well so let's go ahead and simply say
connect
there we go
obviously the connection needs to
establish so first and foremost let's do
this now let's create a simple a method
don't go with the suggestion in this
case you will explicitly make it go
wrong so let's go ahead and say export
async I'll accept that and then let's
call it as a function this will be a get
method a get yeah we are not getting any
data so get method is fine and we'll be
saying request that request will be type
of next request and we can have it like
this
all right next up obviously our try
catch
so we'll go ahead with the try catch the
catch part is easy so we'll just go
ahead and say any here and then we'll be
returning a next response not like that
next response Dot Json I want to return
a Json yeah that's what I like now what
do we want to do in the try catch part
simple just call this get data from
token and pass on a request to it that
is it it will give you a return response
we coded it like that return the decoded
it gives me a ID so I can just store
that into a variable now and obviously
this will take some time so let's just
go ahead and await that
and that is why we created a sync and
this will give me a user ID that is my
variable so I can call it as user ID
underscore ID whatever you like that's
totally up to you and then it's time to
find a user based on this user ID so
user has the superpower to query with
the database and I can go ahead and say
find by ID or find one whichever you
like both of them are gonna serve same
in this situation so I'll just use the
find one and I'll just give you that hey
find based on underscore ID and I'll
give you the ID user ID
so a space would be nice okay I made it
all caps now I just want eye caps not
the T
I'm happy with this okay so now when
this is done uh what more we need to do
await because that's a database
operation database is another content
and we'll store this as a user so you
have given me back a user now this will
give you everything I don't want
everything because if you check out the
database it has ID username email
password verified is admin so you can
select your fields which one you want
and you can deselect the fields which
you don't want so I'll just say hey I
will go ahead and set select and the
password that is what I don't want so
you can put a negative sign there by
putting a space sadly there is no comma
I think the comma would make more sense
but sadly there's no comma if you want
that I don't want maybe is admin so you
can go ahead and put that as well but
I'm happy with this one only
all right so now I have a user now what
can I do with this user I can return a
response that hey here's your user now
do whatever you like it's an object so
I'll just go ahead and say return next
response
the next response
response come on and we'll have a Json
just like this and in here we'll be
saying a message first and foremost
come on
message user found and then the data
will be sending the data like this so
we'll be sending user all right looks
good you can send the data directly as
well in case you wish that's okay and
now we can simply have a save on this
one all right so now we have designed a
route which can actually help us to
Simply go ahead and work with this so
it's totally up to you that how you want
to utilize it maybe you want to make
another request let's do it let's have
fun so in this slash profile let's
actually grab the user's ID
now we know how to do this so as soon as
somebody lands here I want to fire an
xeos request to me and I want to grab
that user let's try that let's try if we
can do this
and
inside the profile will go into page now
obviously I want to have this get
details method and this get details
method uh will run
let's just run it on a button click you
can run it with the use effect as well
as soon as the page loads but I want
this one to run it on a method call so
we'll go up here we'll design the method
so I'll just minimize this log out not
interested in that let's call this as
get
user
details like this and obviously this
will be a sync just like this now how do
we do this pretty simple we need xtos
it will fire a get request to slash user
slash me ah nice I like that this will
await because it's a request and we'll
grab a user out of it or a response out
of it first not the user now with this
we can go ahead and say a console log
first
and we'll say res dot data all right and
since this is a res dot data we actually
need a state as well where we can pass
on this information without this it's
it's not going to be very helpful but
again it's up to you I need a I need a
state so I'll call this one as data you
can call it as user as well I'll call
this one as data no I don't need this
I don't need this either I'll have a
string which says nothing just for fun U
state is not available why is it not
available
it should be here
react and we'll be having you state from
react okay now once we have this now I
can use this set data method to actually
use this so set data
what is happening no I don't want
Mongoose set why
unobvious suggestions so we'll be having
set data and that data will get res dot
data but the problem is the data is not
inside the res dot data it's actually
inside since we have passed our
information like this so let me show you
this if we are passing the data so res
dot data has all of this data so res dot
data dot data dot user will have the
information Yeah we actually
accidentally made it more messy so
further down the data and then further I
can extract this underscore ID yeah
that's that's messy and what we're going
to do is
just below this profile page we will get
an H2
and this H2 will get some data so if the
data is there do something do get
available
just like this
uh probably not we'll just first get the
strings otherwise do something else
so what is happening so if there is
nothing inside the data so what we can
do is we can write some of the things
let's actually evaluate this that would
be better if data equals
nothing because that's the default State
remember nothing so if data is nothing
then we'll be saying hey this is nothing
so let's just go ahead and inject
nothing here
just like this and if there is some data
then we can actually go ahead and inject
instead of this string let's go ahead
and give it a link as well
so I'll just go ahead and say link
just like this
okay
and why is it giving me this problem
here
that oh href is missing okay I can I can
add that no problem
and I'll move it to the next line
now I'll do it here okay
href okay where do I want this one to go
so I'll use the back tech I'll say slash
profile okay but since I have extraction
of the ID now I can go ahead and Slash
and put this data although we should be
calling it as ID but I think that is
good
all right now uh one more thing who will
be calling this uh there is no button to
call it all right so let's create
another button who can actually call
this so I'll just duplicate this one
and I'll say that hey you will be
responsible for get user details so yep
get user details ah I don't think you
will be happy as a blue so we'll just go
ahead and say you will be what a violet
purple
you you get purple a little darker shade
of purple
900 no I'm not happy with this
okay uh what else colors
uh green yeah will will go green
800 cream okay I know
okay so this still says logout this
shouldn't be saying log out this will be
get user details
all right ah right now it says nothing
which is good I also want to actually
highlight this nothing as a little bit
so we'll say class and we'll be having a
little bit of padding rounded
and we'll be having a BG Dash I'll use
green this time not the orange you made
a lot of fun of that
and we'll be saying 500.
and padding
not padding like this what am I doing
padding Dash three
let's go
yeah better okay so let's see get user
details and there we go right now we are
having an empty that means we are not
getting any user details let's see what
we are going doing wrong it says a
message user found and then we have this
data and username and email okay so this
is coming up into the rest or data
so what we have to do is rest.data
and then inside that we need to go
inside the data and then we need to grab
the underscore ID
and then we actually can grab the ID so
I think this is correct why it is not
mentioning the details here so let's
check what we are doing wrong in this
case
okay okay my bad my bad I actually
didn't set up anything inside this link
my bad we never injected the variables
so my bad so we need to inject this data
here
so the URL was there but the value was
never there ah there we go totally a
small bug so now we can actually click
on this and there we go not looking good
this profile should be a little bit
above but anyways you get the idea that
how we are able to grab the user so now
any user we are able to track him down
so that's nice and the log out
middleware that's working nice get user
details we get this and now we can
actually click this we can actually grab
all of this so instead of running this
method on a button click just like we're
doing here we can actually use a used
effect hook and just whenever somebody
visits this page we can load his
information there and can directly just
display there so I think that's a that's
a great start that we have done so
that's really nice and I think this is
wrapping up our application quite a lot
that we are able to do so much in this
one I'm super happy that we are actually
on this phase that it's working nicely
now a couple of more things what we can
do is we haven't talked about how we can
utilize the mail trap which I actually
discussed it's probably logged out
so we haven't discussed that I'll close
this one I'll close this one I need to
push this on to GitHub as well so let's
go ahead and do this and I'll go ahead
and say hey let's add every things like
this and we'll be saying added
middleware
come on
added middleware and what else we have
done we have added middleware we have
also worked on me route
okay Commit This
and of course we want to push it
all right so that you can see the
repository is available on my GitHub
account it's pretty easy to find you can
definitely easily find that all right so
I think that is uh what we'll be doing
in this video but there is little bit
more that we need to have an action plan
so we have gone through with quite a lot
of details in this one we have gone
through with the middlewares I showed
you how the how to protect some pages
routes and all of that from the server
side grabbing the cookies and all of
that
couple of more things which are easier
things now is how we can first and
foremost shoot an email so obviously
we'll be creating a helper file for that
and once the email is being shot how now
the values are there in the database so
I want to update the values in the
database that's my concern now get this
token into the database as well and send
this token to the user email as well
that's what my action plan is right now
and obviously we'll figure out the plan
as we go we make a lot of mistakes and
all of that so that's that's a part of
the things I hope you are enjoying this
series if you want more details or more
projects or something let me know in the
comment section I'll definitely love to
do that for you guys and consider
hitting subscribe there's a lot of
effort going on I would appreciate that
let's go ahead and catch up in the next
video or if you're watching all in
continuation just a small break and
catch up on the other side
hey there everyone ate here and welcome
to almost the finalish video of the
series I'm saying almost because I'm not
sure I will be able to do all of this or
we'll be extending this series depends
on you just let me know the comments so
the one of the last thing that's
remaining almost last is how we can
actually retrieve the user update some
data in the database as well as send an
email now sending the email has a lot of
issues and a lot of good ways okay
shways and the bad ways of doing it I
found that luckily we are in this
typescript JavaScript environment where
things are super easy for us to work on
with that we have this package known as
node mailer which helps us to do almost
everything that we want to do but there
are new players which are coming around
in the market which are handling these
mailing into a new and creative way I'll
talk more about them in probably some
another video this time we'll be going
with the core node mailer way also there
is an exception that I have taken in
this particular video that is usually I
keep my mailing helper as just to send
email nothing else it doesn't do
anything it doesn't generate any token
or anything like that it's a special
helping file which helps me to send an
email that's it but in this case I'm
actually generating my tokens within the
mailer as well because in this use case
it actually makes sense to generate
these tokens within the mail itself and
I'll show you the walkthrough as well
and again I always say there is no good
practice bad practice it depends on what
the project is what scale is and is it
the maintainable code is it not so
that's all it is in this project since
it's not very scale we are not talking
about like making thousands and
thousands of files into it so we'll keep
our mail and we'll keep it in such a way
that we are able to generate the token
within the mail itself the mail helper
file and based on whether the user is
requesting to verify an email or forgot
the password I'll walk you through with
a couple of scenarios of how you can do
it that's the one part the second part
is how do you want to verify the user
that's up to you there are a couple of
ways you can do it all in the back end
you can do a mix of backend and
front-end that is also totally doable
it's totally your approach again there
is no good right and wrong here it's
totally approachable whichever you feel
you can do that in case I talk about
just the back end approach then the URL
formatting needs to be in that way and
if you are looking for the front-end
part of it then obviously you need to
have a front-end page of it both have
their advantage if you do it totally on
the back end then there is nothing much
you can just redirect the user onto a
home page or something but if you bring
the user on some page and then the
verification happens then we can provide
a message to the user that hey
verification was successful that's
totally up to you how you want to do it
it's totally up to you I'll show you and
walk you through with the boasted
approach that it makes you comfortable
with both the approaches all right so
first this is the service that I'll be
using known as mail trap the one good
thing I like about the mail trap is
again go ahead do a sign up they have a
free tier I'm on the free tier I'm not
buying it because it's a good service
but I'm happy with without buying it for
testing we'll be using this email and as
soon as you go ahead and create ad inbox
it was empty so I added an inbox and
simply go ahead and click on this inbox
after this and what you'll notice that
on the left hand side you get all the
Inbox and you get all your Integrations
here so you can go ahead and integrate
it directly with the curb I'll really
like that how thoroughly and deeply they
are working on almost every single thing
is available for E for us we are using
the node Mailer in case you are using
play mailer or something for Java or
something you can still use it so I'll
go with the node mailer and all you have
to do is copy this and the good thing is
while copying it also copies your
password so obviously I'll resetting
this one so again this will obviously
expose my password as well but again
this is just a test account I can reset
this reset the credential just a one
click not going to be bothering it much
now one more thing that you should
really know about it is let me show you
this by opening up the Google and try to
search for JS and this will be useful
information notice here the URL let's
say search question mark Q equals and
something now this is a classic
JavaScript there is nothing in like too
much import important in this case what
I'm asking you is how you can actually
grab this information how you can grab
the URL information now grabbing the URL
information requires a couple of things
you can grab it from the back end we
have already seen that by creating a
square bracket ID we can directly prick
the params.id that's one way but if
you're having this question mark or
something like this you can still go
ahead and click on inspect and in the
console clean this up and we can just go
ahead and say window dot location if I
can write that and then you can go ahead
and look for a search and this gives you
the search parameter everything after
question mark Q equals and I can go
ahead and later on split this up and
divide it based on the question marks
everything before the question mark
after the question mark I can grab all
of this data so this is basic that we
have now coming back why I'm showing you
all of this yes that's a good question
that's a very good question let me go
back into my helpers where are my
helpers and here are my helpers I'll
create a new file and feel free to call
it Alan thing I'll just call this one as
mailer dot TS of course now the reason
why I'm showing you this is there are a
couple of ways how you can do this for
example if you have a domain.com
ah come on don't do this domain.com
there we go you can go ahead and write
something like a verify token and then
slash and the token name so whatever you
want to write so that's the one way of
doing the thing another way of doing the
exact same thing is how you craft your
emails it will be whole dependent on
that and which approach to take another
approach is having this
again domain.com
why are you doing this to me domain.com
and then you can write something like
this slash
verify
token and then you can have simply a
token question mark token equals
whatever the token is now again there
are some easier way of doing the things
if you do it with the first the first
way this is almost looking like
domain.com profile and then send this so
we can extract it directly with the
params params ID so we have the square
bracket syntax we studied about it and
this is also the syntax which we just
studied that we can actually grab it
anything that's a question mark and then
token equals all of that we can extract
that by using window.location.search
this second approach is better for me if
I am actually using a client component
this approach is better for me if you're
if I'm doing everything from the server
component there is no right and wrong in
this one so again make sure you choose
whatever you are choosing a little bit
wisely will make your life easier and
again it's it's not like that hey this
approach is not possible in the printed
it is possible but easier way and making
yourself an extra travel that's up to
you all right so we have already
installed the package of node mailer we
actually talked about that in the
earlier so we'll be just grabbing the
node mailer we also need to grab the
user I usually don't do this because I
like to send the token and everything
and update the information directly from
the controller where I'm writing but in
this case we'll be actually doing a
little bit different so just bear with
me for a minute
all right so we'll be getting the user
come on from
and we'll be using command at the rate
slash come on no suggestions
models and then this is
slash
user model there we go this is the file
name and also we'll be encrypting this
so we'll be needing be correct Js
that's coming up from B group J so these
are the libraries that we'll be needing
now first of all let's learn how we can
send an email now sending the email is
actually super easy if you'll go on to
the node mailer website you'll see that
hey is it that simple
yeah it's actually that simple so if I
go ahead into npm install node mailer we
already did that and all it takes here
is example so in this example you can
see we create a transporter which
actually is nodemiller.create transport
in this you provide your host Port
secure authentication which will grab
all the details uh from our SMTP host
which is mail trap and then you simply
go ahead and provide some options in the
send mail so these are all options we'll
actually create these options outside so
it's much more easier from to subject
text HTML so you can just provide
everything and that's it that's await
dot send mail that is all provide the
option so two lines of code first is
provide the create transport and then
this transport can just send the email
with the options yeah literally that
simple so this is all what we have as of
now let's go back and see that how we
can try this let's create a simple
function and call this one as send email
which is perfect in this case and
obviously this is going to be a sync
and what information you will be taking
from the user that is a big big question
now what information do I expect from
the user first and foremost I expect
that he'll be sending me the email where
do I want to send this email obviously I
need to know that then optionally you
might use the same file for sending the
email for verify token for forgot
password as well so both the tokens can
be sent and right now we'll talk only
about the verify but I'll still walk you
through with the code that can be there
for detecting the email type and all of
that in this case we have just two but
otherwise I prefer to have an enum for
that and based on that I like to check
that so I'm telling you what approach I
usually use and what I'm using in this
case so I'll just have this email type
and then also send me the user ID as
well without this I won't be able to do
much and I'll just go ahead and type any
here so that it doesn't bother me much
and there we go so this is my basic it's
all right email to send where should I
send this email email type that is it a
verify email forgot password token email
or something else like that and the user
ID because obviously I need to grab some
information from that user so I'll
actually use this one as well again it's
not super required but I'll actually use
it to get some encrypted token all right
first and foremost let's go ahead and
have the simple try catch the catch part
is always the easy so I always take down
this one super easy just cast this as
any I don't know what the error type is
and then simply go ahead and say Throw
new and we'll be saying error.air
message not much worried not much
bothered about it the first step is now
if you remember from our excalib draw if
we have this
yeah here we have
if you remember I told you that we need
this hashed value now this hashed value
can be generated by a variety of means
and variety of encryption rounds as well
decrypt.js helps us to do all of this
but right now we don't have this so how
we can actually go ahead and get the
value so it's super simple we are using
the user ID So based on the user ID we
have to provide some string that can be
encrypted around so obviously there is a
requirement for this you can go ahead
and give him any gibberish which doesn't
really make sense but you can you can
there is nothing which is stopping you
so all you have to do is simply ask
becrypt JS that hey bcrypt.js I need a
hash value yep that's it and in the hash
value you have to provide that hey uh
what should I use to do the hash value
like what am I encrypting what is the
string that I'm encrypting you can give
any string because it doesn't have a
meaning it just in the database we want
to match it but in this case I want to
actually provide the user ID
and then you have to provide what number
of rounds that you want to go so I will
just go ahead and go with the 10 rounds
and that's it that is all I'm doing now
I don't have a guarantee that this user
ID is going to be string or not because
there is a chance that user might throw
up directly me uh mongodb bson ID almost
like Json but bson so I'll just go ahead
and just use a simple two string method
on top of it so that I'm 100 sure of it
now let's go ahead obviously this will
take some time because we are using 10
rounds of encryption so let's await this
and call this one as const
hashed token
all right so the token generation part
was super easy there is nothing I'll
just write the comment here as well that
will be create a
hashed token all right so this part was
super easy now the next part is actually
tricky now I want to update the user I
want to find a user and in case you
forgot that let me go ahead and open the
model for you we have this uh thing
forgot password token verify token and
all these so I want to add these things
into the token all right so how am I
going to do this again this is super
super simple there is nothing to be
worried but there is something known as
email type and based on this I want to
update so first let's update with
regardless of what the email type is so
I'm going to go ahead and await this
obviously a database operation database
is another card to then so I'll go ahead
and say user and then user can actually
run a find by ID and update for this I
have to provide the ID so I do have the
user IDs so super helpful here as well
and then I can put up a comma and then I
can just use the verify token so what
I'll do is the next thing is actually
suggestion is really nice here okay uh
so what I can do is let me just go ahead
and hit and enter here this is fine so I
am first of all having this reset
password token no I'm not as uh I don't
want this I want the verify token to be
updated first so I'll just go ahead and
update the values so this is my verify
token and obviously if the time is for
that expiry time should be for the
verify token time as well so I have this
so the verified token that we have is
getting this hash token that's exactly
what I want first make sure you
understand this part find by ID looks
for an ID and update the values and user
ID is the ID which you will be looking
for hunting the record in the database
and then only these fields will be
updated not all the fields so verify
token will get this new hash token
verify token expiry will get the date
dot now and then these values if you
don't understand this that's okay it's
nothing much more we are giving it 36 so
it's in milliseconds or you know 36
hours and all of that so in case you
want that you can just do it uh like how
many hours 24 hours into converted into
minutes and hours and all of that I'll
not go into that much of detail in depth
that's very basic now you can actually
go ahead and say new equals to true and
all of this we don't need this third
parameter although that's nice but I'll
talk more about that in some another day
right now that's not important for us
this will do the job for us and we are
happy with this okay now this is all
happening when I'm assuming that my
tokens are getting updated for verify
token but what if the email type is for
another one which is forgot password
token obviously this is the token part
of it you need to grab the password from
the request body and have to submit that
as well that's that's a different case
but actually I can just entirely cut
this out and just write a simple if Case
to understand that what type of email
you are sending me up so if the email
type and again I usually do that with
the enum but in this case I'll just go
ahead and do capitalize of that if the
email type is verify then I'm going to
do all of this now in case
else if
the email type
is actually other one which is the reset
password or I'll just use the reset
reset then in this case I'm going to
paste this again but I have to change
the values in that case I'll just go
ahead and use forgot password token
forgot password token and of course the
expiry will also be the forgot password
token expiry
again really simple code but again we
have just modified this now this email
is usable for both the context and we
can just we are just generating the
token based on that so that's super
simple now next part is this is all the
settings that we are doing already in
the database so the value by the time
this method is called the value should
be there in the database now again there
are lots of good approaches of handling
this scenario maybe you don't want to
send an email until unless all the
values are set in the database there are
a lot of use cases of that I'll not go
into that one then the next step that we
saw is use this node mailer
and create a transport so node mailer
dot create transport
create
transport there we go and we'll store
that into a variable as well we'll call
this one as transporter
just like this
and there we go we'll just end it like
this there we go
now what are all the options that are
required here notice here it says
Service Gmail we won't be using Gmail
instead what we're going to do is go on
to mail trap and we'll just copy all of
this so all this transport in fact we
could have copied this earlier and grab
all of this so I'll just go ahead and
paste it like this notice here all of
the password and everything are there
these are random password doesn't really
bother much but similarly you can have
these host and everything for other
domains as well like for Gmail there's
different port number obviously the
author and password I don't want to
display my password here again you can
put this into your process.env file as
well that's totally you usually we go
ahead and put this so I'm going to go
ahead and put up a to-do here
and add these uh
credentials to EnV files so that's a
to-do for you you can actually go ahead
and do this now this is ready now the
next option that we saw in studies was
creating a mail options you can create
it on the go as well but I'll just go
ahead and create these mail options just
like this now in the mail options we
have couple of things that we can get
first is from email so whatever Reserve
from email you can go ahead and do that
I'll just go ahead and say hitesh at the
rate gmail.com which is not my email
come on there we go
and I'll just put up a comma Now the
next is two emails so two is email whom
to send email we are already taking that
as an input in the parameter so I'll
just go with that and then after this we
also need to have a subject now the
subject can be just directly verify your
email or you can actually go ahead and
use that what kind of email is actually
coming in so I'll just cut this out and
I'll test it based on the email type so
email type
if email type is verify we'll say verify
your email otherwise we'll say reset
your password so again we can just use
these smaller variables now how the
email is being crafted actually I have
written it already so that we can
discuss this so there we go
so as we saw uh directly we don't have
hash token
hush oh hashed token
hashed we missed an edge almost all
replace I'll update this
hashed token small typo
there we go and we need to use hash
token or we have hash token here
and I think here also and now it should
be happy here as well okay so what we
are doing is we are simply providing an
email which is saying click on this
domain to verify your email or to reset
your password and notice here this is
going to process.env.domain the domain
name we have already set in environment
variable so it will be directly like uh
HTTP colon slash localhost colon 3000 in
case you deploy it on the domain just
environment variable needs to be updated
and then verify email question mark
token equals to Hash token so this will
be our email that we'll be having all
right that is all what we need the last
thing is to Simply send email with these
mail options so that's all again this
takes some time so transporter will send
an email with all the mail options and
you can go ahead and store this mail
response
just like this and after this you can
simply go ahead and return this if you
wish
totally up to you uh so we got this one
let's see what all so this one is also
saying hey cannot find a declaration
file of this one we'll just probably
install this types as well so that we
get rid of these errors
all right so quite a lot of detail
talked about the mailer and how the
mailer is going to work now once the
mailer is done all we have to do is
first create a page or we can first ah
now that's a confusion should we take
down first the apis or should we first
take down the front-end page let's take
the apis first I think that makes sense
so in this inside the user we will be
simply now again based on where you are
landing the user your route should be
according that but in this case now my
bad I'll take that back so in this case
the route doesn't really matter it can
be any route we need to just create a
front-end for verify email for that in
the back end my API request could be
anywhere because once I land there then
I'll use a use effect hook to fire a
request okay I'll do it that way
so I'll just right click and create a
new folder and this folder will be
simply
verify email
verify email verify token yeah totally
up to you I'll just right click create a
new file and we'll just go ahead and say
route dot TS now inside the route.ts
we'll have just the request response we
have to connect with database as well
because we'll be updating some fields in
the database as well and uh
already things are there in my database
so I need to extract the values by
searching through the token all right
so I'll first and foremost will be
connecting to
connect connect no option for Connect
nope don't want that
add the rate
slash and this one is config dbconfig
slash dbconfig
all right so no matter what happens this
needs to connect so I'll say that hey
you connect so database is connected now
we don't need any async or anything like
that we'll be needing the next response
and request all of that
so we'll be saying next
request
and next response
and we'll be needing user as well
because I want to perform a search so
I'll just go ahead and say hey give me
the user from model user model all right
that's great now once the database is
connected then I can go ahead and Export
My Method so I'll say export
async
uh no not like that a sync function come
on
if I can write that that would be great
function and this will be a post method
obviously because we are retrieving some
data or not
request that will be of type of next
request
and there we go
all right first try catch we should have
created a wrapper around it because this
is too many try cash in the entire but
again what can we do now after this I'll
just scroll this a little there we go
let's return uh next response with again
dot dot Json come on
response.json there we go error messages
and there should be a status code as
well
yeah that is the one that I'm looking up
for
and now next up is first and foremost
let's grab some of the tokens so we'll
be grabbing the token from request.body
so const and request body and await
request.body.json app that's
request.json directly
there we go okay now once this is there
I know that there will be a token coming
up for me so I'll just go ahead and
extract this token now this is an
approach where I'm using that there will
be a front-end call who will be making a
call to the API and will be able to
handle this again this could have taken
a different route if in the verify email
I directly create a ID the square
brackets an ID or maybe a token with the
name of token so I can directly extract
a colon token there so again both
approaches are correct there is nothing
wrong or right like that I would also
like to see if this token is actually
coming into this it helps me to debug
that later on
so there we go now I can see whether the
token is coming it or not I have to find
a user based on the token just like I
can find a user based on email I can
find a user based on the token as well
so I'll say find one yeah find one that
is fine
and this one this time will be finding
based on the token and whose time is
greater than now so obviously if the
token time has expired in the past
whatever the time I have set there I
don't want that so two condition needs
to be true now I have to find the token
as well and verify token expiry should
be like that so verify token expiry
comes from the model itself so if I go
ahead verify token expiry this should be
greater than what's the current time is
so obviously in the future I can verify
if it is already in the past I cannot
sorry uh
little cold here but again don't mind
that sorry I cannot edit them out
all right so now if it is there
obviously that needs to be a weight
and what else we will be storing that
into a user
all right
all right good and nice now what else I
can do if I don't find any user in that
case I need to take care of that
scenario
so if there is no user
then in that case return a next response
Json error invalid token yeah that
that's a good response or we can say
invalid token or we can say user not
found yeah that's the debate but we will
not go in that debate and now here I
would like to do a console log that
whether I'm getting this user or not
because it will help me to debug later
on I can remove them but I'll just keep
it here for you to Simply have this now
there are a lot of ways how you can
actually now update this since you have
this user actually you can utilize this
user but in case you want to make
another database call you have verified
it now now you can make another database
call to update this you can use this
Capital user but I will not do it
because I already have a reference of
this user which is a return from this
user object so it also has some of the
superpower so I can go ahead and simply
say user dot is verified so I found the
token I found the user everything is
okay so I need to update it not only
that I have to flush out my verify token
as well as the time as well otherwise
the time will always be there there's no
point of keeping the unnecessary data
and after that I'll just say a weight
and then user.save this await is super
important because it will take some time
to update this and now we can actually
be all happy now once this is done we
can simply go ahead and say return next
response and we can probably redirect no
I don't want to redirect the redirection
should be a job of front-end guys so
I'll not do this next response will just
send a Json response
he can actually do things based on the
response
so message email verified status is
success I'll actually use different
messages
and I'll say message email verified and
success
suggestions success true there we go
forgot the comma there we go all right
so in theory now it actually works
everything works in theory all right so
this should be all okay now we should be
able to send and fire an email
okay so how you are going to send an
email now that's that's a big question
so I think the email should be a part
when somebody is actually signing up
when somebody sign up we can actually
give him a message or we can give him a
button as well that hey get your email
send write your email and we can provide
another page for it but I think in this
case I'll just send him an email
whenever he signs up so that makes sense
otherwise we have to write another page
button don't want to do that okay where
it should be it should be a last job so
user is saved in the database before
sending a response we have saved the
user here before sending the response
let's send him an email send
verification email so how do we do that
now we can bring this send email so I'll
just wait for it and we'll say send
email so we can bring this up hopefully
the import is done
send email helper Sim mailers okay
that's good and there we go we can send
an email so already this is the email we
have extracted from the user body so
this will be used as to whom I want to
send email the email type is verify so
it's it's really bad to see this string
in the all caps here there should be an
environment variable or an enumeration
or a constant file for that but anyways
I'll be just happy with this and what
would be the user ID so now we have
saved the user so this is now useful for
us and we can extract and underscore ID
from it and I think that is it now in
theory at least it should be saving uh
sending me an email all right how many
errors ah nothing so far surprising
let's see how we can actually register
another user so I think this is it yeah
let's go ahead and go and visit the
profile if we still have a user yep
nothing
okay oh we have to get the user details
and we'll log out so now there is nobody
let's try to sign up another user how
many users we have we have one we have
two time for three
so this will be three this will be three
at gmail.com and this will be one two
three four five six we can put some a
validation for password as well but we
will not do it right now let's try to
sign up processing
command do it the first time it's little
bit slower
ah there we go now in theory we should
have something in the mail trap there we
go three gmail.com all right so these
are testing email now notice here when I
click on this uh verify email
I can actually right click and
ah there should be a link
oh there is a link but this link is
blocked probably that's really bad we
need to gra get this email directly so
that somebody can copy paste in the
browser as well uh we need to try it
again in the mailer as well let's go in
the mailer this might happen to you as
well so nothing wrong
okay
so this is email
this is somebody writing up here so
we'll just enter
here
and we'll say
r
copy
paste the link below in your browser
I think that's good
and we'll add a br
and there we go so now I think it should
be much better so that somebody at least
can copy and paste the link uh this way
okay uh I need to sign it up again I saw
this this doesn't expose any email or
something like that so we'll just do
this now in the meantime where we are
here we are we can actually delete this
ah how do we delete it we can delete
this confirm I want to delete it let's
go back here and we have three time for
four time for registration of the four
okay we don't need this we can come back
here sign up sign up the four
four and we'll get 4 at the rate
gmail.com
and one two three four five six
sign up
and taking some time that's ok we got
the processing here all right now let's
see where we have this mail trap okay
forgot here and this time hopefully
we'll get better
and Yep this is much better
oh we got some issues here which was
saying your browser dot undefined then
verifies so probably because it was a
local host that's why it's creating some
issues because I think process.env ah my
bad my bad my bad actually I know I know
why it is giving us an issue because if
I go ahead and check out my sample EnV
the domain is all caps so it's not an
issue it's actually an issue but anyways
it's good to have the text link as well
so it should be domain my bad I'm
referencing the wrong variable there
uh that's good
all right save this and this should be
all good this is how real world
development works it breaks it fails
uh let's let's go ahead and register
another user now
sign up it's time for five
five and then we will have five at the
rate gmail.com and one two three four
five six
sign up processing at least our emails
are shooting that's we're happy but we
have limited emails as well we cannot
just go all crazy so five and five Where
You Are
okay there we go all right good and now
we can click even on that I'll not click
on this but I can actually copy paste
this entire thing we have the token and
everything nice but if I'll do this we
don't have a page which goes on to slash
verify email and again now you can see I
can just provide a link of Slash verify
email slash and whatever the long string
and I can extract that that's easy but
we don't have we don't have the front
end part of it so it's time and by the
way everything is also dumping down here
as well so that's also nice that we have
got all the five four all the emails
email is going there username everything
let's also verify in the database as
well refresh where are you
where is the refresh option
there is somewhere refresh here it is
refresh option so I want to check
whether this tokens and everything is
getting to my database also
here we can see verify token and expire
is also getting up here all happy all
good that's good that's good okay
now what we can do is
next up is okay we need to create a
front end for it so apis you can go
minimize and I now need to create a a
simple route on the front end or the
pages which can actually do this so I'll
just close everything that's already too
confusing all right sign up verify this
is inside the API I need to create a
route for the pages which will be verify
email
and again it needs to be exactly same as
what you are crafting your url so I am
crafting this verify email so somebody
will land up here I'll copy this go back
and inside the app I'll create a new
folder the name of the folder will be
verify email that's exactly and of
course I know what will I be creating
the file name with this which will be
page dot TSX
okay now this is a little bit tricky
that how we are going to create this
verify page there is a little bit
involvement here first and foremost this
will be use client that I know for sure
use client there we go we need couple of
imports so axios obviously will be there
xeos from xcos and we'll be needing the
link to redirect the user as well
probably
not I will still get this
so we'll have this link from next link
and we'll be needing some use effect
Hooks and stuff like that so let's
import them so this will be coming up
from react and we'll be needing use
effect is the one that I am looking up
for first use effect I'll anyway I'll be
using reuse State as well so let's bring
that and I think that's that's all
majorly I'll be needing router will be
needing it probably not
anyways so let's go ahead and Define
export default function verify email
page we don't need any props in here we
can just go ahead and just close it like
that verify email page we don't have
props otherwise it would have any props
we can just extract it like this params
IDs just like that basics
okay we don't have it right now so we'll
just go ahead and escape this and now
first of all I will grab some tokens so
I need to store that token somewhere so
we need a state for that so we'll just
say token set token and this will not be
a string will not use the typescript
functionality here we'll just keep it
empty you state that's like and then
based on user is verified or not I'll
show him some messages as well so either
I can just create a message like this or
I can create a variables like booleans I
can use them to verify not verified or I
can use a message for the same so it's
totally your choice I think I'm going to
choose with the verify email so I'll
just say verified set verified and by
default it will be false
also we can grab some errors as well
maybe there are some errors on the page
so we'll just grab them as well error
set error I'll just use the booleans for
that as well
right now there is no error all right so
these are my data now how can I verify
this obviously in order to verify I'll
need a method
and I'll call this one as verify user
verify user email that's fine it will
obviously be a sync so there is no doubt
about that we need to set up an request
to an API so let's go ahead and do a try
catch for that
and in the catch part
we'll just set the error
with the error or true yeah true because
we are using Boolean and then we can
just do a console log as well so that we
can at least see what's going on wrong
so error
we can actually go ahead and get error
Dot
response because it will be because this
is going to get an XTO so xeos might
throw up some depth so response.data all
right for this we need to cast this
error as any otherwise it will not work
okay now next up is sending a request
from xcos okay all right axios will send
a post request did we made it post did
we made it post let me verify that again
yeah we made it post we made it post
so axials.post and where do you want to
send this request slash API slash users
slash notice here the suggestions are
absolutely horribly wrong we need to get
the verify token I'll verify email
what is happening to my memory
and this is what we have what we are
expecting we are expecting a token there
and the request is obviously verify
email should have seen that already
verify emails what we are bringing along
with us a token so let's go ahead and
grab this token this token is given to
us directly by this estate so that's
nice let's go ahead and wait for this
a wait for this one and that's it once
everything is all done then we can go
ahead and simply say set verified to be
true otherwise it is already false so
that is all my method is going to be
doing
all right so now the problem is when you
will be running this thing and I'll
write some of the controversial code
here okay so how you'll be or when
you'll be running this obviously we'll
be using use effect for this
and for this we are dependent on nothing
so we want to as soon as somebody lands
on this we will be running this but I'll
just do a small check whether there is a
token or not and all of that so if
uh I'll just check if the token dot
length because it's a string so I can
access its length is greater than 0 then
go ahead and run this verify user I
actually don't like this way because
it's less readable I prefer this
whenever students actually watch this
they find it more easy readable so I'll
go with that okay there is another use
effect that I am going to run again you
can write this yeah that's Advantage you
can go a little bit sloppy with the next
JS it actually do all the optimization
do duping a lot of things of the request
I don't have to worry too much okay so
this is what we'll be doing another
thing which I want to do is going to be
dependent on the token
so any change in the token will actually
no I'm actually bad any change in the
token should actually run this one okay
this one we'll talk about that in a
second I'll just go ahead and remove
this so let me tell you what is
happening here
this is the dependency array of use
effect so use effect is a hook which
automatically runs it runs first time
when the page loads there are a couple
of other ways but will not go into that
much it actually automatically runs as
soon as somebody comes on the page but
if somebody comes on the page and there
is any manipulation in the token then
also it will run now right now nobody is
filling up my token notice here there is
no code here which is actually filling
up my token the token is empty will
always remain empty so I need to grab
the information from the URL and update
my token as soon as my token is
Disturbed that's when this dependency
array is going to say hey something is
Disturbed which is mentioned in the
dependency array and I'll run this piece
of code that's the whole flow now I'll
come back here I need to actually grab
as soon as somebody lands on my page I
want to extract the URL so I'm going to
go ahead and say I'll just grab URL
token and this URL token we saw this
already window.location and then
again window dot location
dot this will be on based on search once
somebody is searching on that I'll just
go ahead and split it nice and easy
based on equals to and then the left
portion will be all zeroth value of the
array right portion is my token so I'll
be able to extract that not only that I
have to set this into the token so set
token will get this URL token now as
soon as somebody lands on this he will
be giving me the token I'll set this
token into this this will create a chain
of events the token will be updated here
this will notify that hey one of your
dependencies got updated so run this
method so this is obviously going to run
this method and that's it so I'll just
shrink this I'll shrink this and I'll
shrink this the only problem is right
now we are not returning anything so
there is no page
so return and there we go now what do we
want to return okay we'll actually
return and I have this already with me
in my notes yeah I have actually saved
this div class it brings everything to
the center easy for me okay what do I
want to have first of all most I want to
have an H1 which will have a class
name and we'll be going with the text
dash for
suggestions please yeah for excel
for Excel this will say just the verify
email
verify email or verify your email now in
the H2 I also want to display the token
so that I can see whether the token is
actually coming in or not so I'll just
go ahead and grab an H2 now inside the
H2 we'll start our JavaScript and based
on whether we have token or not we'll do
something if we have token we'll write
something otherwise we'll write
something that's something we'll write
no token
okay what do we want to do when oh my
bad
what do we want to do when the token is
there we want to Simply display the
token so what we're going to do is
instead of this let's use packticks and
let's go ahead and dump the token
directly
and
token
all right now also let's stylize it a
little bit it's class name this one is
going to be
a little bit of padding padding two uh
BG Dash value is orange I like that
color
orange 500 and the text is going to be
black
okay that's good now based on whether
the user is verified or not we want to
show him some text as well so what we're
going to do is let's inject the
JavaScript directly and we can just go
ahead and say verified if he is verified
then obviously I want to display this so
what do we want to display in that case
we'll just go ahead and have a div
and in the div we'll just say nice and
easy
email verified and you can log in I like
that I like that and all we need to do
is close this div all right that is
already good I love these suggestions so
in this case if the user is verified
then we'll optionally display him that
email verified now you can go ahead and
proceed to the login page so slash login
is there text blue I think that's that's
good enough
I think what can give us an issue is
this a tag because I think this is a
wrong usage of a tag this will
definitely crash our application so
we'll just remove this a tag usage of a
tag and the link tag is actually very
very dangerous
so I'll just go ahead and just clean it
up like this that is all good now we can
similarly make a copy of this and now we
can actually go ahead and paste on the
error we can display this
so we'll just display that there was an
error
and then we can just ask him to do
nothing we don't want to show him
anything the text is to Excel and the
color will be
BG Dash
red
and
yeah the text is default going to be
white but that is ok
I'll I'll convert that to Black
okay so I think that is it now we can
actually verify and go on to this page
if it works in theory at least
so now can I go to the verify page oh by
the way by the way one thing I forgot
almost I
I think we need to actually do something
more
verify email
and if I go ahead and look onto this
notice here I go and go back so notice
it says I cannot read the property of
undefined so if token length is 0
we shouldn't be running this so
obviously we need to verify there are
some of the steps
undefined reading lengths so let's go
back
so what we are doing is the token is
right now empty string so that is
creating some of the problems and issues
on this page all right so let us take
care of this you state is empty
and at the token length here we have the
token length is less greater than zero
then only run this
okay this should be okay verify user
email and what in the case we are not
able to grab this token all right so in
that case right now this is setting it
to undefined that is the problem so
let's use an or statement to set it as
back to the empty string
come on all right so this should be much
better approach okay there we go now we
have fixed this small bug happens so
right now there is no token
ah but there is a problem we should
actually fix that up into the middleware
also because remember you always and
always will forget about the middleware
that hey where the things are actually
matching so go back onto the code part
open up your middleware and also add
this URL here although we are not
matching it up with anything but I think
I'll add this one
verify
email
now as of now this is okay I'll just
save this but later on maybe I want to
add this to public pay so that everybody
can actually access this otherwise if I
add this here it will not be verifiable
I'm not tracking this if you don't add
it here that's not being tracked so I
want to call this as public page so even
if you don't have token you can actually
go ahead and access this so I'll just
add that hey path dot verify email that
is also allowed
to be visited without the token so
so if the path is there so this is the
public path let me just check this again
public path and token so redirect here
if there is not public path and the
token is not there
if the public path is not there in the
token so I think this is good all right
I am re-evaluating the things so let's
go back can I still access this yes I
can still access this okay now it's time
that we verify the email our
verification should happen now I can
just go ahead and click on this in
theory and it should verify this
and we are not actually bringing the
tokens so sometimes what happens is when
you click on this in the URL and stuff
your question mark token all these
things are not being traversed via the
browser that is why this issue actually
happens that's why a lot of companies
give you this or you can actually
provide a better URL notice here there
is a dollar and all of that so that
sometimes gets into spam so you can go
ahead and use this as link I can go
ahead and use this so I'm not able to
grab the token so why is it happening
okay so I'm going on to the verify
verify email uh my bad
so I'm just saying verify email question
mark token uh now we got the token this
is a common issue that you are going to
see that when you are actually doing the
development in the next JS this is a
common issue the development is so slow
that sometimes it takes time so yeah
this happens now let's see if we are
able to verify the user
ah let us refresh this and whether
everything got clean got a clean up or
not
let's see let's see come on give me that
okay I can see that the 5 is verified is
false
uh is verified is still false for the
five and we're actually verifying which
email
let's just check
okay so probably there is some issue in
the mail trap we are verifying the five
so five I think the rest of the things
are going great let's see
is verified false
okay so we got the password is verified
false the token verify token everything
got here nicely let's see that if we
grab the token what we are doing in our
apis so this is the job of our API to
actually say user dot is verified
and let's grab it from the model
and is verified I'll just copy it
probably I'm making a mistake here I'll
just open this up verify routes
and this should be oh my bad there is a
typo here it's is verified so bad
anyways anyways no problem no problem we
can just create a fresh user and try
this again one more time this is how the
debugging works so it's everywhere is
verified
oh goodness and the token names are
token names are good should have paid
more attention but anyways these are
small bugs this is how you fix them
let's try with a new user this time
I'll open this up here and let's try
we're here and we'll try with the
sign up
let's try it's time for six
6 and this one will be 6 at the rate
gmail.com password will be one two three
four five six
sign up the user
processing slow but only in the dev in
the production it goes like ridiculously
fast The Edge functions are always up
almost always up and there we go we got
the six
and again this is also painfully slow
I'll just copy this this time
whether this extra dot is there
horrible the dots should not be there
but this actually creates a problem so
we should actually use better approach
of generating the tokens
uh I'll just have this one the start
definitely is going to create issues and
again this
again why is it having the issues
probably with the dot now we have this
this dot is definitely creating the
issues so we can notice there is little
bit wrong in our approach that we are
generating The Tokens The Token should
be just a mix and match of letters and
numbers uppercase lower case that's fine
but these special characters and these
dots especially that is creating so much
of the issue also in the development
environment uh serving the page actually
takes some time so you will notice that
when it actually serves the page
compiled successfully and all of that so
this actually creates a problem
so possible emitter memory Leak
Detection will actually take care of
that but anyways now we have this is
verified false here so that is we are
getting all of this now let's check
whether we are actually having this
properly there
all right let's see
so we have the user six there we go we
can see that the is verified is true
verified
that is true in this case so we are
actually able to grab it now this is
really a very thorough example of
understanding a whole lot of things
that's happening it's really a decently
complex project we have worked on a lot
of things now I'll not actually do the
spoon feeding to you yes that is one of
the bad thing that a lot of people do on
the online codings and tutorials and all
of that now we have seen thoroughly that
how you can actually shoot an email the
verification of the email we have also
seen how we can extract the data from
the body as well there was a reason why
I did it this way the reason is because
I want to have you an assignment the
assignment is really simple we have
worked on our verify emails verify
accounts as well now we also want to
work with the forgot password the
mechanism is simple that again we'll be
using our mailer and mailer can shoot an
email so you have to first create a page
where you can simply say hey send me a a
male for for getting the password so you
have to create an API for that as well
as soon as somebody sends their email
and a submit button is being clicked now
it makes an xcos request use your node
mailer to send a token to him and also
send this token into a database as well
now when somebody visits this page as
well now you can take that token in
another API call and based on this you
can actually give him a simple thing on
the token on the URL you'll be grabbing
the token and in the body just get here
the password and the confirm password
and submit Button as soon as you click
on submit button he'll be sending you
the token he'll be sending you the
password and the confirm password based
on that first verify whether the token
is actually valid or not if the token is
valid now grab the user again based on
the token and update the password field
for the password field you have to
actually encrypt the things again so
there's a lot of things you can learn
and do the things and again I would
highly highly recommend that once you do
this do let me know on LinkedIn on
Twitter or anywhere that I have
completed the project this will be your
Learning Journey just watching the
tutorial is not going to be cut through
it now you know everything the only
thing that's lagging and missing in you
is the confidence so if you face any
trouble just reach me out on Discord
Twitter I'll help you in understanding
the code or seeing a code or something
like that as I get time but again the
goal is improve or implement the
functionality of the forgot password
it's super simple if you are not able to
do it if enough of requests are coming
in I'll do that no problem at all but
again I take this as take this as a
simple assignment I highly highly
recommend that you should be actually
doing this so this was all about an
introduction of nexjs I think this was
quite an in-depth introduction of next
shares definitely in the future I'll be
rolling out more of full-fledged more
complex projects in next year's if you
want that do let me know in the comment
section I would really really love to
have this one so that's it for this
video let's go ahead and catch up in
another such video it was great and
fantastic for teaching all of you I
enjoyed it thoroughly do let me know in
the comment section if you are enjoying
such videos I'll make them more
interactive more like just like you're
sitting next to me and learning
everything I'll make them more engaging
so that's it let's catch up in the next
one hit that subscribe
hey there everyone hitesh here back
again with another video and welcome to
this another video on xjs I thought we
have done so much why not to show you
the deployment part and some assignment
part as well so I've added some of the
assignments for you we'll first talk
about that and then we are going to talk
about how we can take this and Deploy on
the varsal Warsaw is one of the great
platform where you can host your nexjs
application our database is already
online in manga DB so we'll utilize that
let's go ahead and try this out let me
share my screen uh with you so this is
what I've added in the next JS readme
file you might have already seen that in
the repo it's nothing it says a detailed
course on xjs we can just actually move
this here a little and I have added what
are the tech Stacks that we have uses
mail trap Nexus typescript Basics
nothing much big deal and here's my
YouTube channel link as well so I've
added a YouTube I'm pretty sure you're
watching this on YouTube if you're
watching it somewhere else hey I have a
YouTube channel uh apart from this there
is assignment the first assignment is
improve the UI of the application right
now we were focused too much on
implementing uh the functionality part
and the bare minimum basics of UI so
that you can understand the flow of the
application now definitely integrating
too much of the Tailwind we could have
done that we could have just copied and
pasted that that I'll surely do that in
the upcoming videos but it doesn't
really add any much value if you request
me enough in the comment section I would
definitely add some of the videos which
are focused purely and purely on
Tailwind skills so I can do that if you
wish want to have it let me know in the
comment section but anyways in this one
I have skipped that so that's your
assignment to add more beautiful UI
maybe make button mode beautiful maybe
use a theme for it or maybe have better
inputs so something like that you can
have it and also add a feature of forgot
password we have done exactly same thing
in the verify email and again just
watching the video is no benefit for you
and in case somebody's saying hey why
didn't you do it you should have done
that this is an incomplete tutorial I
would say probably you will never learn
programming if you'll just watch the
videos and expect me to do 100 of it uh
you won't be learning programming so I'm
not bothered about you those who are
bothered about learning the programming
now is the time that you achieve it now
if anybody is actually completing the
entire thing just let me know your
GitHub repository or you can send me a
kind of a request here pull request but
make sure your pull request is not
merging your code in my code I don't
want that I want user to see only the
code which I have written I don't want
other people otherwise people will be
confused that hey from where this code
came in so only after the hint just try
to add or I can just add it just in
front of you that we can go ahead
instead of the hints up here so we'll
just add your completed repositories so
we'll just go ahead and say something
like this
uh your completed
assignments
and you can just add your links up here
so we can add here something like this
uh
add
your repo so if you have completed
everything so you can add up your repo
link here I'll just push it again so you
can just go ahead and add a repo link
here that hey here is my completed
version of it or probably a deployed
version of it so go ahead and add it
that kind of a pull request only I'll be
accepting if your pull request is going
to make any kind of a mess then I'll not
accept it if there is a conflict I'll
not accept it make sure you actually
update the conflict take the proper poll
and everything so go ahead and do that
that's your contribution in here all
right so that's the basic of how you can
do that I have even written your forgot
password hints as well that what user
needs to do it's a five-step process I
have given it here so that it will help
you to learn all of that all right now
this whole thing is being pushed so
let's go ahead and actually push this
final readme as well I'll just add this
changes add
your
contribution here gear
here and I'll just Commit This
and we're going to push this so that
this also this is also available there
so all right so now everything is being
pushed onto the GitHub it's time that we
actually go ahead and take it on to the
next JS uh versal actually deployment
part but before that we need to actually
create another user I have actually
removed all the previous users so I'll
just create another one just for the
testing this user will be I'll just call
this one hitesh
hitesh123 really bad uh show the
password h123 add a built-in role of
write and write any database not a good
idea but we'll still do it
I'm just uh making this up all here so
that you understand that what are the
security issues and concern which you
should be having so we'll just go into
database
and we will be connecting with the
strings so I'll just copy this so that I
can actually inject this in here so I'll
just copy this
go back up here and let's go ahead and
deploy this so virtual and we need to
bring up on our all of our environment
variables here so I'll just click on
project and this one is react not react
It's actually an xjs next JS full stack
auth yeah we want to import this this
whole thing is good here is our
environment variable this is where we
actually inject all of this so let's go
ahead and open up our environment
variables since I have deleted
everything so I'll just go ahead and
open up the sample.env hey I can just
close all of this we don't need this
sample.env I'll just paste this into
sample link so the username that we are
using is hitesh and the password is
hitesh123
and what you need to do further is add
up your database name so we'll just call
this as next YouTube auth yeah that's
good so the first variable that we have
is URI copy that enter into your
domain variable just like this you had
your environment variables and you don't
have to do even a single thing paste
copy its value
paste the value here add this up we have
one more
how can I get here here it has one more
we'll have the token secret make sure
your token secret is oops
make sure your token secret is way
better than mine I'll just add some
complex
token
yeah that that's good enough
I'll add this and we can also go ahead
and add a domain
uh domain yeah that's that's a crucial
one because right now the domain is we
have no idea what domain we have so we
need to come back here and add this
after the deployment because we will get
a URL if we would be having our own
domain then there would be no problem I
can just go ahead and do this but we
need to add the environment variable
little bit later this domain part I will
just click on deploy
and that is it that is it all it takes
to deploy your application it will start
building and if we don't have any bugs
or issues we will be able to deploy it
if we have some issues or something like
that obviously we have to debug that
part but again there is nothing much it
will just give me a URL and all I'm
looking for is a word cell app URL so
that I can add it into my domain as we
can see this is the domain that we have
we don't have to have ports and stuff
like that so
this is taking us some time in building
the build phase actually takes some time
yeah
okay maybe we should pause the video
here there is no point of unnecessarily
staring the screen here okay so let me
pause the video
all right so you just missed the
confetti there is a confetti that
actually comes up here so right now
notice here it says add your domain I
don't have my domain that's why I missed
out that environment variable so again
so let's continue the dashboard of it
where this is so I can see my
application is up and running and this
is the deployment URL so that is what
I'm looking up for so I need to actually
copy all of this uh next year's full
stack auth then some random variable
Dash My
username.versal.app I think that is a
better way of actually
domains
let's just click on it and we can edit
this to have a better URL
so let's just have this
next year's full stack auth versal app
yeah we'll just copy all of this
and now we need to actually add this
into environment variable so there is
environment variable without this the
thing is not going to work so we have
our token secret we need to
actually provide domain
and then the value of it so whatever the
domain wherever you are deploying it
needs that this is what we are using in
our mailing services so make sure you
actually get that and also there is a
issue here that in the if you go into
the source and inside the helpers
and in the mailer I have actually
deployed my own user ID and password
here but I have actually deleted that
account so it doesn't really work
anymore but still make sure you actually
use this to do add these into the
credential and EnV that's a security
concern here but anyways so I'll just go
ahead and say that hey this is add
another one no Adam save this one so
please define the name for environment
variable ah accidentally added that one
so we have all these domains and tokens
and everything now our app should be
there so now in theory at least we
should be having this being deployed
and it takes some time so there we go we
can sign up and we can log in that's
good and we'll just grab hitesh and
we'll be saying hitesh at the rate
google.com which is not true and we'll
be saying one two three four five six
very secure password uh we'll do the
sign up obviously our mail will fail
because that doesn't exist so that part
of the code is not going to work it's
saying processing
taking some time
and we got the sign up because our
mailing is actually failing otherwise we
would have got redirected there but in
theory at least we should be getting
some of the users in the documentation
here or the document
so there we go so there we go obviously
we didn't got properly redirected
everything but we are getting this the
reason for that is because in this
portion we are having a bug which is
intentional I didn't want to expose my
credentials otherwise we would have seen
that the everything is going nice and
easy so now one more assignment for you
is extract these user ID and password
put that into environment variable so
that we can actually inject them there
that would be really really nice but now
you know that how you can actually have
your application and stuff like that we
can log in and we can go ahead and say
hitesh at the rate google.com
and we should be able to get this so one
two three four five six we should be
able to log in processing login and the
login now we are getting this so get
user details I'm able to get my user
details hopefully there we go
and I can visit the profile as well this
is working fine I can go back and hit
the log out button let me see that if we
are getting this token as well inside
this and application
and cookie and there we go we got the
token this is how the real world
application works and we can hit the log
out and this should be taking us back
only thing that's not working is our
mail and we know why it is not working
in the code part as I always say it's
important to know how your code is
working but it's also important to know
that why your code is not working which
is the part of the flow that might be
broken this actually helps you to
understand and debugging debug a lot
faster because you understand your code
in and out and that's what I always
Focus that please go ahead and
understand the part that it's not always
about working code it's also about the
ability to understand that which portion
of my code is causing the bug or issue
as the application will grow larger
which shortly we'll see later on you'll
understand that hey there's so much more
to learn and so much more to understand
but this was a fun deployment part told
you deployment is super easy it's
actually fun so in this video you have
learned how you can deploy use your net
environment variables some of the issues
that we have that you can fix up there
and can actually make a pull request
that hey my repository is now all good
and perfect at the age can you add this
into the readme again I repeat this all
those people who will be sending an
unmindfully these pull request which
actually merge your code I will not
accept that I'll write a comment below
that that hey you didn't understood the
video but those will be just sending me
the pull request where there is a link
of your repo in the readme file only
I'll happily accept that and maybe
thousands and thousands of people will
be able to check out your repository
that what's your version and your
implementation of the assignments that
we have done so be cautious don't just
mindlessly send the pull request be
cautious about that and in case I miss
you uh miss your pull request or
something let me know on the LinkedIn or
Instagram or Twitter wherever you like
that's it for this one let's call this
one as the end for the series officially
I'll definitely make more videos so do
check out and subscribe to the channel
I'll catch you up in another such video
hey there everyone here and welcome back
to another video if you're watching in
continuation then no it's okay so
welcome back and I'm really happy that
you have shared so much of the series on
the LinkedIn on Twitter I'm really super
thankful for you for doing that there
are only handful of people who actually
promote the educational content and
you're one of them thank you so much so
I've decided that I'll continue this
series further on and I'll walk you
through with more scenarios where you
can understand next year's in a little
bit more depth and you can enjoy that
now one scenario that we have already
gone through is a full stack application
using the next JS we built our own apis
we send it Up all In the mongodb and
work with that now another scenario is
that maybe your backend is already
cooked up maybe in another language or
maybe you're using already cooked up
back end now your your backend might be
in fast API or maybe in the spring boot
so you'll get a lot of idea that how to
handle these scenarios so I'll be using
a already cooked up back-end which is
known as apprite and apprite is is a 100
percent open source you can deploy it on
your own servers or you can use their
Cloud I prefer to use their Cloud it's
easy to set up so in this entire series
not series but a couple of videos that
it will take I'll walk you through with
one such application so let me first
show you the application so that in case
you want to try it before me you can go
ahead because you have a lot of
knowledge now so let me show you what we
are about to build so this is what we'll
be building and I would agree and say
that hey upright I actually borrowed
your color scheme and themes because it
was so nice so sorry for that it was
beautiful so I couldn't resist myself so
we actually borrowed some of your theme
sorry for that but hey you are a good
platform so what we're going to be doing
is in this one we'll be using this nexjs
meets uh app right so I've already
created app or account on the app right
so if you go up into this one so it's a
free account anybody can create that
there is no limitation or something like
that I have created this next test we'll
be creating a fresh account fresh
project for the app when we'll be walk
through doing the walkthrough now we can
click on this and all that I'm using
here is the auth now notice here they
give you nice bandwidths and API keys
and whatnot so everything is pretty cool
about them go into the auth we have got
couple of users just like you know me
one at the red Gmail today at the regime
mail it takes a couple of users to
actually register and do it properly so
we'll be doing exactly that now this is
the application that we'll be building
there are couple of routes which are
protected so in case you don't know
about that so we'll be doing the route
protection as well so there's a profile
route which it doesn't allow me to visit
I have to be logged in user for that so
it's tracking all of that now if I go
ahead and click on the sign up obviously
I can do a sign up let's try with the
three so we'll go with the three at the
rate gmail.com uh that's that's a full
name so
I'll copy this I'll paste it up here and
I'll remove this one we don't want that
and the one of the best thing about
using the apprite is all the
authentication validation that is being
set as a default in apprite day comes in
so there's a minimum criteria of having
your password you cannot just set it one
two three four the needs of eight
characters so that is a default of app
right so you have to follow that as well
that automatically comes you can
obviously overwrite its open source but
I don't want to having a security and
password that's that's good so I'll just
go ahead and okay did I type it wrong so
one two three four five six seven eight
the most secure password in the world we
are using that let's create an account
as soon as you create an account it
actually the way we have set it up is uh
we have actually directly redirected the
user created an account and redirected
the user onto the profile page so we are
bringing in this three and the email ID
from the app right itself and these are
hard-coded so these are just taking few
values but you can definitely take more
values I'll just hit on logout and show
you the login flow as well this is our
login screen so I can just go ahead and
say hey this is uh three if I can write
that three at the rate gmail.com looks
like my keyboard is not at perfect place
and we can have one two three four five
six seven eight that's that's basic and
I'll just do the sign in and there we go
the same information I can hit a log out
as well there's no problem now one of
the thing that is absolutely amazing
about this project is that we are
maintaining the state of the user so
there is a state management also
involved in this project now that's not
Redux if you want me to do the Redux
part so let me know in the comments
section I'll do a proper separate video
probably an hour hour long or two hour
long video just on explaining what the
Redux is and what the state management
is in this one we are using the context
that is it the context API in the react
as well as next.js is so much like
Underdog it I would say that I would not
hesitate to say that it's so much more
powerful that you always don't need to
take out your big guns of Redux you can
just do everything with the context API
and that's exactly what you're doing
here as well I'll walk you through with
the context API how we'll create our own
custom providers and custom hooks so
that you can manage the user
authentication and States as well on the
front-end side as well and back end is
all cooked up on the app right so we
won't be touching too much on the back
end part this project is going to be
serving a lot of other knowledge as well
which you should be having with the
upright uh not apprite the next JS as
well so there are a couple of routing
information parenthesis folder name
structure which are also there in the
yes I'll walk you through with that but
hey uh go ahead and try this application
on your own first I'll definitely give
you the link in the GitHub repo for that
as well but it's always a good idea to
at least try out something on your own
otherwise I'm always here so in the next
video or in the sequence of the next
video I will just walk you through we'll
start with a fresh project we won't be
using the previous one so let's go ahead
and get started with this one
all right so let's go ahead and get
started with the app right and the
next.js we'll create a fresh new project
and we'll understand that how we can
inject app right into an xjs project we
have to work on something known as
parenthesis there are some routes which
you can create with the parenthesis we
have worked on the square brackets and
there's a difference but in thesis
square brackets curly braces so we'll be
talking about how we can utilize
parenthesis and something known as
layout and can take advantage of this so
all of this in this video without a
further Ado let's go ahead and get
started because things are easier to
understand if we go directly on the code
part I'll just copy this here and I'll
just click and copy first we'll be
generating a simple nexius project so
let me go ahead and fire this up a new
Fresh vs code instance and let me go
ahead and get a project as well just
like this so I'll just actually move
this for a second and we'll be bringing
this all up here so that's nice and
let's create a new folder a fresh new
project and we'll be calling this one as
simply the next JS Dash app right
because that's what it is and obviously
it's a YouTube Project so let's Trail it
with the YouTube as well drag and drop
this should be absolutely easy open up
the terminal that we have so if it can
open that so there we go and paste the
command simply and I'll at the end of it
I'll just add a DOT so that it generates
everything in the same project folder do
you want to use typescript of course let
linting I'm not a big fan but I'll still
use it Tailwind CSS yes please give it
to us Source directory do you want to
use it yeah I'll take the source
directory app router yes of course would
you like to customize the default uh
I'll not customize it I'll use the basic
at the rate which is the default one and
that's it now it generates a fresh
project for me now here's the idea will
not be working too much in the app
folder in this video or in this section
of the video if you're watching it all
in one go we'll be first working on
configuration of the app right because
that's the logic part that's the
difficult part how we build the pages
and how we can transform the data that's
that's easy part there is nothing too
much difficult for that one
all right so looks great and looks okay
now let's go back on to the upright and
see how that we can configure it I've
already created an account on Earth but
we'll create a fresh project for this
one because I have no shortage of
creating the apps I'll create this one
and let's call this one as YouTube next
JS yeah that's that's good enough name
go ahead and create this
and there we go now you don't need to
find any project ID or anything here you
can just simply click on the ADD web app
because that's what it is and let's call
this one as next JS with
app right that's my app name the host
that I'm using for this one is actually
localhost so no worries on that part now
as soon as you click on next it will
give you that what should I do I should
actually do npm install app right first
so I'll just copy this and we'll go up
onto my code editor and first and
foremost I'll just go ahead and do npm
install app right it's not really that
much of a big package comparatively very
very small and that's majorly what we
need and then you can just ignore this
because I'll walk you through how to do
this with the web SDK we just need the
app right and just click on the next and
this is something that we'll be needing
so let's go back here into the root of
directory just create a DOT EnV I'll
create a sample EnV for as well so that
I can give you all of these files as
well so I'll just go ahead and say
sample dot EnV so that I can push it
onto the GitHub I'll be working with
this mainly so let's go ahead and First
grab the EnV file in the EnV file you
need these two things so endpoint which
is actually your next year's public URL
and the endpoint which is a project ID
so let's go ahead and add this one so
I'll just go ahead and lower this down
so this one for me is next underscore
public
underscore app right and URL
all right and then simply have an equal
to sign and this is where you grab it
copy this entirely without the codes
that's the first part of it and next
part that we need is Project ID so
notice here that's that's a funny one we
won't be using that we'll be using the
actual one so go ahead and copy this
and that's it now we don't need to come
back and again by the time you'll be
watching it I might have already deleted
that but I'll still copy this and paste
it up here so that you know which URLs
to actually work on with this one so
this one is saying the top one we are
not worried about that part here I'll
just add the classic one 5c 5c 5c5 see
that whatever that is so that it
actually remains for you so that you can
work on with that now let's also take a
look on to our package.json as well that
what all we have in this one we have
actually very less we don't want to kind
of overburden with this one we'll be
having just the app right that's where
the focus is I won't be even installing
the xeos and anything that that will go
with the classic so that is it if we
need anything else we can just go ahead
and just create it at the go and that is
all we can just hit the next here and
take me to the dashboard we don't need
anything else the advantage is when you
actually work on with authentication and
the auth part you don't have to worry
anything in case you wish you can go
into the settings and add all these
things probably we can talk about them
later right now I'm just worried about
email and password that is enabled for
me by default so that is it that is all
I need one good idea is to once you have
done all of this it's actually good idea
that we go ahead and say npm run Dev
which we have already learned and see so
at least I can see that whether my
project is actually up and running or I
need to debug at this point also
all right
initially it takes a little bit time to
load and there we go we can see now the
project is all good done will be just
changing a lot of this a lot of this
this time but don't you worry I'll give
you the exact CSS and the code files of
the tailwind and all of that so that you
don't worry on that part now first and
foremost inside the source we can see
there is this app folder and there's so
much more going on we'll discuss about
the app little bit later right now we
just want to go ahead and create couple
of other folders now one of the more
approach that I will walk you through in
this one is first create a new folder
into this one and let's go ahead and
call this one as conf for config or
maybe something else I'll just go ahead
and shrink down this app because I'm not
interested in app as of now I'll just
right click on this create a new file
and let's just call this one as conf.ts
now one of the common thing that you
might have already seen that when we
were importing these environment
variables we had to put an exclamatory
sign to say that hey this is always
there I'm pretty sure of it one of the
other alternative that you'll see
especially in the production is actually
to use a config file or some other
third-party libraries as well which can
get you a surety that it is there one of
the way of doing that is you'll see this
a lot is actually create a simple conf
variable just like this or config I'll
just call it as conf that's much better
and we can simply go ahead and create an
object and here we can simply say export
default conf now this config will be
responsible of having this so we'll just
go ahead and say Hey I want a app write
URL
and that URL will be coming to me in a
string so that I know the format that
it's coming in and in here I can just go
ahead and say process dot e and V Dot
and the name of it which is next
suggestions app right public URL
hopefully that's the same if I'm not
making any mistake all right the next
one is app write project ID and we'll
just go with the next public app right
project ID so now that we have exported
it that's actually considered as a far
better approach instead of just directly
calling them and calling them hey that's
a string and that's an exclamatory sign
there are a couple of packages around it
as well which are also considered quite
a lot with the dignity in the community
as well so I will say that if you want
you can go ahead and have that one as
well now let's go ahead and talk about
the app right because that's the major
ingredient here so let's in the source
we'll create a new folder and we'll just
call this one as app right so that later
on somebody comes up he just knows
exactly that hey this is the app right
folder and all the configuration related
to apprite belongs here I'll create a
new file into this one and let's call
this one as config.ts
now this is the one file which we'll be
talking to your app right now the way
how you talk to the upright it's not
really difficult it's actually easy app
right from the upright package module
gives you everything your client your
account your ID anything that you need
will be provided just directly by that
so let's go ahead and try this
first I need the config so I'll just go
ahead and say hey bring me the conf from
the config then I'll say that hey I need
some stuff from upright
app right so what are the stuff anything
that you want to deal with that in this
case I obviously want to deal with the
client so client is one which will be
talking to that giving me the user
details and everything we are
specifically working on account so
that's why we need that and we'll also
be smallly handling the ID part so
that's also important in case you need
more this is exactly the place you
actually write so in case you want
database or something you just go with
that right now we are not playing around
with the database we'll do that in some
another video right now we're just this
much important now we'll be creating
some types as well so far we haven't
created any type and we have always
written any that's that's also an
approach but in this case we'll just
write the type so at the time of
creating the user or at the time of
logging in the user we know exactly what
type to expect in that that's the
typescript specific feature we have
talked quite a lot about typescript so I
think that's a good idea in this case so
we'll first create a type which simply
go ahead and say create user create user
account
and we'll be creating a type for it as
well now similar to this we'll also
create another type so let's go ahead
and say the login user account login
user account we'll be creating a time
all you have to do in this since these
are type specification just mention what
are the variables and what's their data
type is so in this case I'll grab an
email I'll grab a password and I'll also
grab a name that all string type that's
it in the case of log in a user I'll
just grab email and I'll grab a password
as a string that's it so this is my type
again you can skip this part in case you
wish to but all you have to do is just
write the simple any in that case now
step one how do we deal with that this
client is responsible for talking to app
right so let's create an object from
this client all we have to do is simply
say new and client this actually gives
you a reference to it let's store this
reference into a variable and call this
one as app right client
there we go now storing the reference
this is going to be super helpful for us
this client actually talks to your app
right but it doesn't know how to talk to
it it doesn't know the URL it doesn't
know the project ID so yes you get it
right you have to exactly tell it that
hey I need this so upright client has a
lot of methods into it called config
headers and all of that we are
interested in this set endpoint this is
the first one as soon as you do this
then you have to say that hey config or
conf I want to use apprite endpoint it
does not know that endpoint so obviously
you have to go into the conf and look
for that hey what is giving you that URL
so in this case app right URL so I'll
just go ahead and copy this app right
URL because it knows that variable
on top of this once you have mentioned
the URL then you have to set the project
ID so on top of this let's change it and
then we'll say that hey I want to set a
project
and the project also needs to go ahead
and say upright project ID and again
we'll be borrowing this one from here so
that I don't make any mistake here there
we go that's exactly the same now at
this moment you specifically know that
what project you are talking about and
how you are talking about and all of
that now on top of that we have used
this client now also we want to take a
reference from the account in case you
are working with the database you have
to take the reference from database as
well but in this case we are talking
with the account so just like we have
taken the reference here with the client
for setting up the connection let's take
a reference of the account as well super
easy so again the the idea is same we
want to have a new account reference and
we can provide the upright client so we
know how to talk to it let's store that
into a variable so let's go ahead and
call this one as
account with a small one just like that
not only that I would love to export
this as well because I'll be using it in
a lot of other places so just write a
export here so anybody can talk to the
account wherever they want we don't want
to export it at the end we just want to
have it like this now this is all basic
now whenever we work with the upright
client in case you have watched my other
videos on the react native and stuff I
always recommend to create a class out
of it simply the simple reason is as
soon as the class Constructor is it
actually does a lot of job for you not
only that you can create a lot of
methods a synchronous method which are
responsible for creating the account
logging in the account log out the
account so that at the time when you're
actually doing the work you don't have
to do the work there you can just call
these methods and it's a singular place
where everything is being mentioned this
file is for just for just the
authentication but I usually prefer to
create separate classes all for
authentication all for database all for
storage and just like that this is my
workflow that I usually like to do
so let's export this class so that
anybody can use this so we'll just go
ahead and say I won't have a class which
will be app
write service
this is one of the best practice that
you can utilize now in this the first
one that we are going to go ahead and
say create a new user or rather better
will be create a new record of user
inside app right probably that's that's
a better name all right then what we are
going to do is start with a sync
async create user account I think that
that's a good suggestion that's a good
suggestion and I'll just go ahead and
close this like this so all we are doing
here is we are simply naming this as
create user account so we'll be using
this method instead of the app rights
account dot create method uh we'll be
just taking email password and name that
are given to me and these are of type
create user account remember the type
that we have exactly created so these
are of type so now instead of writing
any here I can just route this write the
specific type now since it's a database
connection it's no different than a
mongodb it can fail so we go ahead and
wrap this up into the try catch we won't
be doing too much we'll be just throwing
the errors so let's just go ahead and
say Hey I want to throw the error
through the error that's it in case you
want to do console log or something more
you can go ahead and do that in the
Tripod I would love to just go ahead and
create a connect account so I'll await
this one because it can take some time
and I'll just go ahead and say account
dot create again for creating all of
these accounts the thing which is
responsible is this account not only it
actually creates the account it actually
gives me some more details about the
user that whether it is logged in
session is there or not so I can use it
later in later Point as well once that
is being done all I'm going to do is
ah will will be just creating this but I
think we can do a tiny bit better just
instead of saying uh email password and
name we also need to put a unique ID for
this one because this is an this is a
new record in the entry so obviously you
have to do it uh it sometimes I have to
check the docs to actually make a
comment I'll put that in the comments if
I have something in my mind but again in
this case I'll just use the ID directly
which already we have and we have a
method on this which is known as unique
so oops unique just like that so there
we go now still we are creating this now
notice here we are not taking this from
the user so anybody who creates or call
this method I don't have to worry about
this ID we are directly bringing up from
the app right it gives us this ID and
you don't have to use any uuid or
something like that so let's go ahead
and store that into a variable call this
one as user account
there we go nice and easy
once this is all done then let's check
if the user account was created or not
so simply go ahead and ask for it that
hey do you have this user account if you
have it just return this user account
based on this user can do that if you
found sir account redirect him and to
log in or keep him on the page or
something like this I think if the user
account is created then I'll go ahead
and simply log in so I'll just say this
again Dot Login feature doesn't exist
right now I have to actually go ahead
and create this one remember it doesn't
exist right now just like the create
user account is responsible for creating
it I'll create my own login feature so
that I immediately log in the user I
already have the access of email and
password so I can directly pass on to
this one and it's the job of my method
which I'm about to create that hey go
ahead and log in the user and in the
else case I'll just return whatever is
being given to me so I'll just go ahead
and say hey you want to return this user
account
now there are chances that you have
nothing in the user account so I'll
check on the front-end part that if user
account is nothing I'll just accordingly
proceed and if there's something into it
I don't have to worry I'm not returning
that I'm just returning the login so I'm
directly going inside this all right now
well the issue is that this whole thing
looks great the try catch and everything
but I don't have this thing the login
which is creating a problem so
immediately the first thing that I'll do
is just go ahead and create this so that
it stops giving me these errors so go
ahead and say a sync a login and there
we go now this should be all happy
and it says async login login account
why are you giving
okay property password so we don't have
this password
let's see we have this password in the
login user account so I think there is
some issue
all right shouldn't be that much login
user account we have this one
should be all okay let's try this one
more time
or probably we are missing some of these
so where is this shrinking in
all right so let's expand this probably
I'm missing out some of this one so this
is whole part of it and now here we can
actually do the login
is this extra looks like this
yeah this is probably extra so I have
this create user account so yeah
I think now let's go ahead and try in a
sync login email just like this and have
this yeah this one was extra all right
anyways so now obviously this is where
we are catching the errors so this is
giving us some issues here
let's go ahead and expand this why are
having you having some issue okay error
is not of Define type so we can go ahead
and say any
still there is an issue there is an
issue
all right let me check this I'm pretty
sure the issue is of these curly braces
let's try this
all right
catch finally ah
there is something there is something
issue this is the try block
else let me just quickly check and find
out that I'm pretty sure this is an
issue of a curly braces so let me just
quickly figure out that
ah I really hate these indentation
issues I thought somehow that I'm in
yaml file or something but yes finally I
have fixed it it's actually not that bad
I was just missing this one here and
this one is here so now we have this
async login which is also resolving the
issues that all we were having this is
still not in the best indentation where
I want it to be but okay okay I'll get
that it sometime happens and it's it's
not the best of the work all right let's
just close this one let's close this one
now it's in the better position
I prefer it to be on
this line a little bit indentation like
this
but we'll keep it there all right so now
we have this login method as well which
is accepting email and password how it
is doing the login that's not our
concern but since if I'm here and I know
this kind of mistakes will happen I'll
just first declare rest of the other
method as well so another method that
will be going with that is going to be
to finding out whether it's logged in or
not so we'll just go ahead and say is
logged n so if is it logged in or not
and this is going to be a promise but we
will worry about that in a second first
let's go ahead and get is logged in this
will give us a promise that whether the
user is there or not if it is a user it
will give me the user data otherwise it
will just return me a false and similar
to this we might need to get the current
user as well
so a sync and we'll be saying get
current user again you can design as
many methods as you like and finally
last but not the least we'll be giving
it a log out as well
a sync logout that's it now it's time to
implement them implementation is super
super simple we can go ahead and work on
with that so let me try with the login
First again the most easiest one to go
with that hopefully I don't do the typos
or the try catch the error that's any
and we can simply go ahead and simply do
a through error
throw suggestions throw error that's it
in the try part of the login it's
actually one of the simplest of all
login all you have to do is simply say
account and it just creates an email
session so again create email session
not the session so we'll be using Create
come on
three too many suggestions create email
session that's the one I want to use and
I'll just pass on email and password
just like that and we'll be awaiting
this because it takes some time and
we'll be returning this so as soon as
the session is being created I'll just
return that session directly so return
await just like that told you it's super
simple it's a backend pre-written so
there is nothing too much to discuss on
that now this is logged in is actually
an event which will happen in the future
as well so this is going to return me a
user itself so it's the best idea that
you actually go ahead and make it a
promise
again you can just go with the try catch
it might take some time and all of that
but actually giving it a Boolean value
and promise a Boolean value that's
actually better because it's an event
that will happen in the future
Boolean there we go
and again looks okay
why are you having this issue a function
whose declare type is neither undefined
void must return a value yes I will
return a value don't you worry
I'll go ahead and return that in all the
other case just go ahead and return a
false so that should actually get rid of
this now let's go ahead and try catch
this
so in the catch we'll just go ahead and
say hey I don't want to do anything so
we'll just keep it as it is so there is
nothing that we are doing because if you
don't do anything in the catch phase
that's okay because we are anyhow
returning the false that I couldn't get
the user so that's that makes sense but
in case you want to do that in the
catchphase as well that's okay and all
we're going to do is returning a Boolean
data so what this actually does I can
just go ahead and say await and then I
can find this dot get current user so
this is a method which actually gets you
the current user and we can just hold
this into a data
now in this case you can return the data
there is no problem for it but we have
actually created a separate method which
is get current user this is just
checking whether you are logged in or
not this will be super helpful a later
phase now one of the hack that you can
do here is you can just go ahead and
simply return something like this and
then you can say hey I want to return a
Boolean variable Based on data if the
data is present it will return a true if
the data is not present it doesn't get
anything it automatically returns a
false very tricky but it happens in case
you don't want to do that that's okay
you can try if and else if the data is
present return it true if data is not
present return of false that's also
valid no worries at all all right so
this part is all easy now we are done
with is logged in now this is the point
where we'll be doing almost the same uh
this dot get current user there is a
better way of getting the current user
again both of them returns you the data
so we'll be working with that in the get
current user we can actually get the
current users simple absolutely simple
just go ahead and have a try catch
and in the error part uh we'll be doing
a simple error so just like this let's
go ahead and do a console log and in the
console log we'll be simply saying that
hey I want this error and I'll also want
that get current user actually provided
that error so get current user actually
gave me this error and I'll just go
ahead and work with the error yeah
that's that's it
all right why are you having issue this
is having an issue which is having an
unexpected
colon just like this why are you having
an issue
get current user error
do you need this one yeah it needs this
one and now why are you having an issue
all right this is bad this is bad why is
it having an issue all right so
if this is not working first and
foremost I want to return a null
so there we go that is happy
ah man sometimes it's difficult to even
read the errors that why is it giving me
these errors
let's try it one more time ah my bad
this this one shouldn't be there yeah
this one is happy now all right okay so
now this part is handled and if we are
able to get the current user current
user getting there are two ways of
getting the current user the first one
is this dot get current user remember uh
this is the instance of this entire
thing so remember here we are creating
this app right and hold this so I want
to get the user of this but there is
another way in case this is confusing to
you you can go ahead and use this
account remember we have account just
simply get it that's it that's all it
takes to get all the details about the
current user since we are getting this
let's go ahead and return this as it is
in the front end side or in the pages
side we'll see that what this current
user actually gets us you can do a
console log here as well but we'll just
return this and in all the other cases
we are returning the null you can read
the documentation of apprite as well
it's yes it's that ridiculously simple
and also in the log out it's again
simple there are a couple of ways how
you can do the log out you can delete
multiple sessions as well or you can
delete the session as well so there are
multiple ways of handling this I'll just
go ahead and do a try catch and there we
go suggestions are really really nice in
this case okay so what it's doing is
it's returning in a weight where it says
account dot delete session and we can
just provide the current this is the
string yes this is a string where it
actually removes the current session and
then you can simply go ahead and catch
the errors thrown out so this is the
basics of how this is being done
now if you remember this is the class we
are not we can export this class as well
but nobody needs this entire class we
can actually make it kind of a one-time
usable and we can do something like this
let me show you we can go ahead and say
hey app right service I'll create an
object from this class and then I'll go
ahead and Export a default app right
service that's it now again you can
directly get this class and just create
an object there then run with this but
since I can make my life a little easier
I can just go ahead and create an object
directly here from the class and Export
that object and have a default of it so
that I can import this and work on with
that I also have an access of account so
in case I need something more I can do
this but I think everything that is
probably usable I'll do this I'll prefer
that to do in my class itself so that is
what the wrap up of the app right
configuration that we have here now
let's also work a little bit of how we
will be using the context as well
because that's also important let's go
ahead and save this so we'll be just
removing this now since we have all of
this now you'll be super happy that how
we are working with the context part of
it the context is nothing it's just a
wrapper which will be wrapping up a lot
of components and will tell these
components whether the user is logged in
or not so if he is not logged in we'll
be protecting some of the pages if his
uh logged in we'll be allowing him to
access the certain pages that's that's
all it is so let's go ahead and do this
we'll be creating our own context so
let's go into the source create a new
folder and call this as context there we
go the context will have just the two
file the first one is use auth which is
our own custom hook that we'll be
writing and we'll be creating first a
new file to provide this auth context
auth context and Dot TS of course
the way how you write the context is
it's super simple if you know the react
you will be just doing this like this
but in case you don't know about the
react as well that's also okay creating
the context mainly includes creating a
provider provider is something which
provides you the information that's all
it is that is all so let's go ahead and
do this the step one of doing this is
first go ahead and import a create
context just like this and now we don't
want it to film from the when we want it
from react
come on react there we go once we have
this then we have to export couple of
things first is auth context and the
second one is auth provider okay how do
we do that first is export const auth
context which will be created by this
create context there we go and we go
like this that's it it actually does
that but how is it going to tell me that
somebody is logged in or not that's the
job of the context it gives me the
information right now it's going to tell
me just a Boolean information and a way
to update that Boolean information but
you can pass on so much of the
information here so again this will be
responsible for just two things giving
me a Boolean value and the ability to
update that Boolean value otherwise
what's the point of it it will always
give you the same information so what
we're going to do is after this context
that we have we'll first declare the
data type here so how we do that we
simply go ahead and use this and inside
this we can have a curly braces this is
a type declaration you can avoid that
skip that that's no big deal but I'll
still declare that the first one is auth
status
the auth status obviously is going to be
a Boolean and then a method or a way how
I can update this so I'll just call this
one as set odd status
and this status obviously is a Boolean
type but I am declaring a method here so
notice here this is a callback not
callback It's actually an arrow function
so it doesn't do anything it returns you
void but now I have mentioned my data
type that hey there would be a value
which will be true and false and I have
the ability to update this value why are
the context as well so by default dot
status will be false so nobody is logged
in and I'll also give that that hey
right now this is the empty method but
since I am expecting or accepting a
method you can go ahead and provide me a
value and since I'm also providing out
States using this method you can
actually change this that's the whole
idea and that's how you always actually
do this you can provide more information
here an entire object as well but it's
really simple now this is the half part
this is the half part that's the context
you also have to have a provider
see this is the informational part of it
context and in when I'll be creating
component I'll show you that I can
actually just like I create user State I
can create a simpler hook like that
which will give me direct information
whether user is logged in or not and
I'll I'll actually ask the use for this
provider is something which wraps all
these components because otherwise uh
there is a prop Drilling and a whole lot
of things in the react itself so what
I'll be doing is I'll be creating a
provider which will act as a wrapping
box where I can put my components and
anytime my component need an information
I can just directly grab it so this is
how I do it export const auth provider
auth context.provider now since this
auth context is Created from this create
context it has the ability of that for
more information read the react docs
that's the basic once we have all of
this let's go ahead and Export this so
we are going to go ahead and say export
and did we export it no export const
auth provider let's go ahead and Export
default as well
although not required but I prefer to
have a default so that I don't use curly
braces and all of that I'll just have
this one
all right that's the part one of it now
also let's go ahead and make a hook from
it now how do you design the custom
hooks that's that's an interesting one
let's go ahead and design a hook it will
be not as powerful as a use State use
effect something like that but it's it's
our hook we'll call this one as use auth
there's no such thing in the react which
is known as use auth so we'll be
creating our own how can I create
such hook on my own you can you can you
can do this really simple steps so first
and foremost you have to use the context
so use context from react that's the
first part also bring in that auth
context that you have created
so now it's super simple just go ahead
and say const use auth is my hook just
like this
and there we go what does this hook does
every single time you use this hook it
just provides you the data which is
there in this auth context what's the
data Yep this exact data and all I'm
looking up for is this auth context and
Status so all the data will be given to
you so now I can just go ahead and say
hey give me the data and the data will
be coming up from use context auth
context
that's it this is classic react 101
again this can be a little bit confusing
but this is what we have and after this
you can just go ahead and simply say
return data and the data will be
returned to you now what's inside this
data that's very very crucial uh
question I'll surely answer that but
it's easier to answer all of this when
I'll actually show you directly in the
console log that's that's much easier so
there we go finally we'll be exporting
this now I highly highly recommend that
you go ahead and read a little bit so in
case you are confused about this part of
the code go ahead and say that hey I
want to study more about this let me
show you this so This use context and
the react is actually available directly
so just search for this use context and
in the react and I'm pretty sure they'll
redirect to best official documentation
yeah here it is notice here this is why
it's saying use context is a react hook
that lets you to read and subscribe to
the context from your component context
is something that we are creating and it
reads And subscribe to our contacts so
that anytime there is a change and all
of that it actually automatically gets
to know that
and then it's actually used to passing
the data deeply into the tree whatever
that's exactly what you are using and
notice here they are exactly saying that
hey how to use it caveats and all of
that and we're using exactly what they
are doing
so notice here we have created this
provider something like this will be
using almost exactly like this theme
context or provider something like this
so read the documentation a little bit
that how they are doing it that's the
basic in case you don't understand it
much I do have a video on the context as
well on my channel if you want a newer
one just let me know in the comment
section I'll try to do that as well all
right so a lot of work that we have done
in this one video we have created a lot
of things upright connection is all done
uh configurations is all done context is
all done these are major portion of it
we have to spend a little bit time in
creating the component since this app
looks beautiful and beautiful takes time
so the next video is all about creating
the components don't worry I'll not
waste a lot of your time in just the CSS
part of it I'll give you directly there
because there's no sense of it uh we are
not on the Tailwind side we are on the
next year's side and I highly highly
recommend to read a little bit more
about it because I can understand
already this context part if your react
Basics and Foundations are not that
great you will struggle here either
brush of them or just ask me I'll do
that so go ahead understand it if you
got this one you know it's basic one so
that's it for this video I hope you have
enjoyed this one let's go ahead and
catch up in the next one
hey there everyone hitesh here and
welcome to another video or another
section of the video if you're watching
it in the long run so in this section of
the entire training that we're doing
we'll be focusing a little bit on
building the components now components
are not very crucial apart from login
and sign up rest of them are just for
the beautification the Avatar that we
are getting is just holding the images
the profile card it's not doing much
just checking available and If the
variable is present display this if it
does not present display that I will not
be wasting your time in just giving you
these CSS classes or the Tailwind
classes it just is a wastage of your
valuable time so since we are focusing
on next year's and upright I'll be
skipping that part I'll give you these
code Snippets via my GitHub repository
and I'll be just copying and pasting
them via my coding notes that I have
already with me but I will be still
writing the important portion of it the
logical portion where it's required only
the return statement where it returns an
input box and the buttons and all of
that will be bringing them up from my
notes itself so this section is wholly
divided just in just four uh coming up
with the components and finishing them
up with so that's the plan for this
particular section let's go up here in
the uh this portion on my code editor
and let's try to have this one so inside
the source we are still not going into
the app directory we are still into the
new directory which is known as uh
components
components there we go now this
component let's first take down the most
important one the signups and the login
because rest of them are just copy and
paste so let's start with the sign up
component so we'll be going with the
sign up and of course dot TSX because
it's a component itself now first and
foremost this is going to be a client
component so I'll just go ahead and
declare this like this let me just move
my keyboard a little bit
so we have this use client once we have
this we'll be needing the app right so
first bring that so how we are going to
bring the app right that's the most
important question it's pretty simple if
you remember we have this app right
service that we created an object from
the upright class file and we exported
that this is exactly what we'll be going
through and working with that uh also
thanks to our uh at the rate symbols so
that we can actually reference it from
any files anywhere directly from the
reference of this one okay another thing
is in the sign up we'll be actually
taking some advantage of our hook as
well so let's go ahead and bring that
one as well so we'll be saying import
and I don't want to import this using
the curly braces because if you go ahead
and look into the context and use auth
we actually exported that as a default
as well so we don't need to do this we
can just go ahead and directly Say Hey I
want to use this use auth and I can
directly bring this up
now we'll be needing some link as well
uh in a minute but let's go ahead and
first import them so next link
oops not like that
from next link there we go and we'll be
needing the router as well so let's go
ahead and bring router and here's a
common mistake that is there in all of
the suggestion so don't just bring this
from the router itself we want to bring
it from the navigation itself so let's
go ahead bring this up and say
navigation
nothing else
okay so one more thing one more
important thing how we are going to be
submitting the form that's that's
important one so let's ring in react and
uh we will be using use state for sure
uh but in the react now you have
actually this uh form event that we'll
be using now what happens with the form
event is uh we can do a lot of tracking
of what's the form how it is being
filled up all these data so we can
actually take advantage of it and we'll
be taking one that one
all right so first and foremost let's
create a simple sign up so we'll be
saying con sign up just like this and
there we go now obviously once the sign
up is there I want to export that as
well so export default sign up that part
is easy we will be returning something
from here so let's go ahead and First
Take Care Of The Return part as well so
there we go we are returning nothing as
of now but let's just say we return a
simple div
that says a sign up and we just go ahead
and close it up just like that so that
now we are not worried about that what
we are returning back it's obviously
going to be a sign of form but first
let's take out the logical part okay
going like this first I need this form
data to be somewhere because I'm
collecting name email and password so
let's go ahead and do that so I'll say
that hey I'll be collecting that into
the form data and set form data this
will be a object just like this so I'll
come back here and I'll say I'm
collecting email for sure I'm collecting
the password for sure and I'm collecting
the name so that's all I'm collecting
now obviously to show some errors I will
need a state which actually tracks my
errors as well so I'll just go ahead and
say hey here is what is keeping track of
errors and set error right now the error
is nothing so that's okay now coming up
on the most important part how the
signup will know that whether somebody
is logged in or not and how it is going
to do all of that for this we are going
to take advantage of this use auth and
there is a similarity here lots of
similarity let me show you that how this
is
so what we're going to do is we are
going to go ahead and extract so we'll
be extracting just one this which is set
let me just go ahead and open this
and
will be opening up not this one we need
this one so set auth status copy that
this is the one that I need not both of
them or all of them this is the one I
need and by destructuring I can extract
the one information which I really need
so in this case I'll be using this use
auth there we go just like how I do it
there we go forgot the equal sign there
now you might be noticing a striking
similarity because let's just say we are
also having this use router you use the
use router almost similar to this one so
you go ahead and say const router and
that is use router just like this
exactly similar so there is no
difference in the hooks that we are
using so this is exactly like that
whatever the coding of the router is
behind the scene we actually get all the
information in this and you get all the
methods like router.push and all that
all that that you need similarly in this
I use auth it provides me just two
things one is auth State status I can
actually import that or I can just go
ahead and use this auth status which is
a method responsible for changing this
this one here so it's totally up to you
whichever one to go with the path uh
that's totally okay okay next up we want
to Simply go ahead and have a method
which actually creates a user so let's
go ahead and create that so we'll be
saying hey this one is going to be
create or create user however you want
to call this one this one is going to be
async and then we'll be capturing an
event which will be a form event just
like this and not only this you can
actually go ahead and specifically
mention that hey what kind of elements
are going to be coming in not really
required but in case you want to go too
much into the typescript part of it you
can actually go ahead and do this you
can go ahead and say that hey there will
be HTML form Element no suggestion form
element so I can explicitly mention that
these are the data that will be coming
to me in this case the first thing
whenever there's a form you don't want
to submit it you want to prevent the
default basic JavaScript 101 so prevent
default so that's the one part of it so
I'll just go ahead and say prevent
default after this I'll just run the try
catch so try catch the catch part is
easy I'll just cast this one as error
that will be of any I don't know I
really don't care too much and I'll be
simply setting the error because I have
a state for tracking it and I'll be just
saying error.message that's basic now in
the try part I need to go ahead and
create a user for this I'll be using a
weight and then I have a service already
written for it which is apprite service
and this has a method I don't need to
use dot account.create I can because
there is an account export as well but I
don't need to do this if I go ahead and
open up my app right notice here I'm
actually exporting this one here which
is app right I'm definitely exporting
the account as well I can use that but
since I have all these methods which are
actually doing everything for me so I'll
just go ahead and use that one rather
one of the method that I created was
this create a user account and I can
pass on all the information directly
here and I don't need to do it like this
I can just go ahead and simply pass on
my form data because my form data is
actually a state just like here all
these information and my method is also
expecting the same information so email
password all of this so this is being
passed on to it that's it and you just
simply go ahead and create an account
now let's also hold this into a variable
so we'll just go ahead and call this one
as user data just like this and let's
hold this one now once the information
is in my user variable I can actually
check whether the user I actually got a
user or not and at this point I highly
recommend to Simply go ahead and console
log the user data so that you find out
whether things were okay or they were a
little shaky I'll use a simple if else
statement I'll say if the user data is
there then go ahead and set this one set
all status that hey we are authorizing
it so let's just set it to true and
let's also push the user since we are
using the router so router.push we want
to push it to profile right now we don't
have this but we'll definitely create
this one in the else case we do nothing
so simply by default the status is false
so I don't have to worry anything about
it and that is majorly what my logical
part is now obviously in this one as
well I'll give you some of the code as
well so don't you worry in that part but
I'll explain you that part directly
so this is a long piece of code and
again don't worry you'll be finding
everything inside of the GitHub
repository all we are doing this is all
just gibberish the CSS of the Tailwind
so we don't even bother much about it if
it is there that's great if it doesn't
there that's okay fine you can create a
bare minimum forms as well now first and
foremost there are a couple of links
which are going on to the login as well
we haven't created that but we'll surely
create that now most important thing
here is if I go back here this one value
which is form data dot name this is
where we are capturing the name this is
the on change event which actually pass
on the information from the form to my
state that is the most important and the
email is exactly same the password is
exactly same I could have written that
but that would simply waste your time
and here we are simply saying hey this
is the type submit so as soon as the
submit is being done uh we actually
capture all of this and we can just
simply go ahead and work with that so
nothing in case you are little panicky
about that that hey how this is all have
happening and all of this you probably
don't need to worry too much about it
you can just simply go ahead and simply
call a method that hey what happens on
click as well totally up to you how you
submit the form data that's totally up
to you how you work with that and how
you feel comfortable with that we can
definitely come back and debug obviously
that's a part of the life so we can
actually go ahead and work with that so
this is a form event if any form event
happens we'll just simply say create if
it doesn't work I'll just come back and
set it to on click all right so that's
the basic of it let's just save this
all right hope there is no issue into
this one let's go ahead and now create
the login form or the login component as
well
and yes one more thing I would like to
mention here is that a notice here in
this portion I'm not checking whether my
data is actually properly set or not so
form data if email is present or not I'm
not checking that uh usually this can be
done automatically by the app right they
check it and provides you better error
messages and all of that but in case you
want to do it go ahead do it there is no
harm in that let's create another
component almost exactly similar to this
rest of them are just boilerplates they
are no logical components they don't
have their brain they are just display
components so let's go ahead and create
another one which will be login and
again since I have predefined some of
the things in this one so go ahead and
make them named exactly so this one is
TSX just like that now one of the
important thing let me mention this
already in advance you'll notice that
here we are actually redirecting it so
notice here this link says slash login
so right now we are creating components
not the pages at the time of when we'll
be creating Pages I'll walk you through
but these are important so just keep
that in mind let's go into the sign up
and log in and first let's go into sign
up and bring all of this copy paste into
the login that's the basic and now let's
create a method so this one will be
login
and that login is going to be just like
this
and we'll be saying
export default login so that part is
handled
all right now the logic part again
exactly same we'll be needing a router
so that we can push the user onto the
new page so let's just go ahead and say
hey router let's go ahead and do a use
router just like that we obviously need
somebody who can change my auth state
because my provider will be providing
all information from there so let's go
ahead and say hey we want this set all
status that will be coming up from our
own designed hook which is use auth and
we'll be needing the form data so the
form data just like this and there we go
we'll be needing some information email
and password that's it nothing much more
we'll be setting the errors as well so
let's go ahead and set the error as
default now let's go ahead and create a
method now again you can create a method
on click you can create a method on when
some events are triggered I know which
event I'm looking up for so I'll just go
ahead and directly go for that so this
one is login so notice here it is async
it is looking for an event which is a
form event which actually gives me all
the HTML form element again not
comfortable with this totally okay you
can just go ahead and say on submit on
login on click whatever makes sense and
whatever makes you comfortable there is
no right and wrong in this particular
portion
okay uh first thing just like always
we'll be preventing the defaults so e
dot suggestions prevent default
once the default is prevented let's go
ahead and have uh simply held over the
try catch
and here we'll be saying that set error
set error error.message that's fine and
simply here we can just go ahead and
await for the that we created the
did we have this one yep we have the app
right service so apprite Service uh
login form and I can just pass on the
data directly to it that's it and if it
is all successful first let's hold this
into variable because what we'll be
checking without that so const and let's
call this one this will be creating a
session just like this
if it is all good let's check this if we
have a session which actually upright
creates it for us we'll be simply saying
uh set auth status probably this one is
extra yep a set out status is true and
will be pushing the router to the
profile that's it really really basic
couldn't be much more simpler than this
I'll shrink this and I'll just go here
because obviously we need to return
something again return part is exactly
same so that's why I'm not focusing much
on that part I'll walk you through with
that still so notice here this is all
just the form designing and all of that
sign in actually goes on to the link
which says sign in sign up and basic
like that and simply after that we have
this email address important parts are
here that the value is form data.email
on change is also handled here nicely
and set form data previous values
expanding the previous one getting the
email as Target email so very basic
nothing too much extraordinary there if
you know even your basic job script you
can actually figure it out Simply we
have this submit as form as soon as the
form is being submitted we'll be
capturing it while the event trigger
which is for form data and we can
actually do all of this so really really
basic so these were the most logical one
complex one after this is just a copy
and paste but I'll still do it because
obviously we need to completion we need
a completion on this one let's go ahead
and do one by one so we'll first go
ahead and say
Avatar
ta and why is it not typing yeah little
slow when you record the videos it's
actually a little slow the system is
otherwise it's really Beast fast okay
what we're doing in this Avatar uh
nothing really much we'll be importing
the react
there we go I will be creating a type
because we'll be injecting uh some of
the images into it that's what Avatar is
let's go ahead and have this type props
are we importing something yeah we are
importing type from OS now we don't need
this
so we'll be having some props and inside
this will be saying image is going to be
and string and there will be some alt
text if somebody gives me but I'll keep
this one as optional if they give it to
me that's nice otherwise it's okay and
here we need actually column because we
are defining types so sometimes the
suggestions are really bad okay and
we'll be saying type props is declared
but never used I'll be using that in a
second don't worry
now let's go ahead and say const Avatar
somebody will be giving me these props
just like this and let's go ahead and
have it just like this and then I have
my code base which is returning me as
CSS class CSS object basically
so there we go we have this class
rounded all of that we will be having
these images
why are you having issues because this
doesn't need to be like this these are
not a prop declaration like this uh the
way how this is being done is whenever
somebody calls this this will be
returning a react component so react
functional component basically and the
data type that it is expecting is
actually inside the props
and this should actually do the job so
let's go ahead and have it like this
react functional component props equals
looks okay to me
what is your issue now it says type
playlist can be used in the typescript
file ah I named it as jsx my bad
I don't edit these out because these are
most important thing to understand TSX
now it's happy
okay so there we go now the Avatar is
done another such component is also
almost similar to that so I'll be just
directly creating that again these are
copy paste I know this is very boring so
speed it up 2X or something like that
this blog is not doing any blog it's
it's just very simple dumb component it
doesn't even accept anything somebody
just runs it uh gets me a Boolean value
and there we go so I'll just go ahead
and have it it just has this simple
color a blur a Blog at the back it's
just a Blog blog doesn't mean those
article writing blogs are simple
circular blog blob yeah so that that's
one I'll show you what's the use case of
it it's nothing it just has this uh SVG
file into it nothing else so based on
true and false you can pass it on and
make it enable and disable for the
mobile responsive and all of that after
that almost similar to this we have a
header file as well so I'll just walk
you through with that one as well so
we'll be saying header dot TSX and I'll
be just copying and pasting this one
again because literally there is nothing
here that is new and we have discussed
everything here so what we have is we
need to actually bring this auth
from Context use auth why is it having
an issue we don't have a logo yet but
we'll be creating it very soon so let me
just try that why the import
of use auth
probably there is some typos probably
missed there and Logo will be creating
in a minute what it is having is a menu
items so we have home about us and the
contact they are going nowhere so it
just is helping us to get the visualize
there and notice here we have this use
auth status as well based on user is
logged in or Not So based on that we are
checking some things this is where we
are looping through the menu items and
we are creating simple navigation bar
and whether the user is on profile or
not so based on that we are saying in a
slash profile or slash sign up based on
this auth very basic ternary operator if
you have reached so far in the course
itself you are pretty much aware of this
one similarly we are saying hey we
should show him the sign up or we should
show him profile show him a log out
route or a login route based on that so
very basic there is nothing too much to
be worried about all right so let's save
this obviously there is an error here
because we don't have this component log
logo let's see if it allows me to create
this directly from here
uh probably not I have to create it
manually and let's right click and let's
go ahead and Logo dot TSX logo is
exactly same uh it just gets you a logo
so we actually love the logo here so we
are directly using an SVG path here
again nothing much logo is just an SVG
so this is your SVG it returns your logo
uh that's it and you simply go ahead and
use this one so
should be should be all happy
okay let's try to are we exporting the
logo as well yeah we are exporting but
why this is having an issue let's try
this one more time so I want to bring
the logo from dot slash logo now it's
all happy
just want me to rewrite the thing
similar to this we have just one more
rest of all are done I know very patient
I'm testing your patience out
okay the next one is profile card and
this is having no much information so
let's right click and create a profile
and the profile card dot TSX
let me bring this again profile card
from my notes itself because we are
doing nothing much here but uh still
I'll just walk you through with some of
the important Concept in the profile
card so this is very basic uh why are we
having issue in Avatar
TSX
okay shouldn't be having an issue just
like this
dot slash Avatar
are we not exporting this Avatar
yeah we are not exporting this
export default Avatar should be all good
so that's also a testing all right now
uh the most important thing here is if
we go ahead and declare a simple const
like profile card and we'll be having
react functional component just like
this go like this and of course export
this as well export default profile card
now this is not going to do any return
type like that so we can just go ahead
and get rid of this there we go the most
important thing in here is that as soon
as this component loads up we want some
states to come into the picture and as
soon as this one loads up that means I
need to use use effect to figure out
that whether somebody is logged in or
not if he is logged in I can grab some
data and in case you remember we
actually wrote a script for it as soon
as I call this one method here which
says uh get current user it actually
gives me the user details so we'll be
actually taking advantage of this one so
first and foremost let's create a simple
a state
so const user
user set user just like this so really
basic and a couple of interesting stuff
here notice here we don't have this
model so why there is suggestion of this
and yes you can actually go ahead and
completely get rid of this so this will
be absolutely happy this will work this
will 100 work but let me show you one
more interesting stuff about the app
right if you go ahead and simply say
models.user because uh what you are
about to inject into this is not going
to be a regular string it is something
that is coming up from the app right
itself and apprite actually gives you
these types as well and the one of the
great advantages you can go anywhere
here and you can just actually import
these models from the app right and
simply work with that now right now this
is complaining let's see the complaint
that generic type user requires one
argument and we haven't passed on to
this one so right now this is all null
and let's go ahead and use this so let
me just quickly check this that why is
it still crying
all right had to look into the
documentation a little bit uh with this
error so exactly let me show you what I
found out when I say model.user it's
saying that hey it requires generic type
user requires one argument so after
looking a little bit into this models by
the app right I find out that hey this
one is saying that hey uh give me
another type so just like with the
angular brackets typescript we actually
need to provide it one here which is
also given to us by model so no need of
further includance of this and they say
that hey if you go ahead and set it up
as preferences it will just get rid of
this again if this is something which is
too much for you can cut this out but we
are not taking advantage of the
typescript in that case we are simply
saying that hey this is a user right now
there is a null there could be something
else into it or you can just set it up
with empty string whatever you like but
we want to be little bit more explicit
and take advantage of the typescript so
that's why we are doing it after this is
super simple we have already seen this
so many times so we'll be saying Hey I
want to have a use effect just like this
and we'll be saying hey use effect this
will be dependent on nothing as soon as
this component loads I want to take
advantage of this one go ahead and
execute a method
you can name a method outside and then
call it or maybe just call an Fe here
and that's it if we immediately invoked
function we'll be calling it as an async
if we and there we go
that's it this one takes no parameter
nothing is needed I'll go inside in here
and say that hey I will be awaiting and
this app right service
can actually call the get current user
the method that I created it doesn't
take any parameter if the user will be
there then it will be doing the job and
that's it let's hold this into a
variable so let's just call this one as
user data again
if the user data is there then we'll be
setting the user that's it let's go
ahead and say that hey if there is user
data
user data then uh suggestion could have
used that
set user as user data that's it
otherwise let's keep it null and we'll
be checking all of our condition based
on that so I'll just copy and paste the
conditions that we have already checked
so I'll just go up here
and paste it now all we are doing is we
are rendering a component based on
whether the user is there or not if user
is not there we are not rendering it so
null yeah you get that very basic
JavaScript and in this case we are just
rendering a profile and notice here
there are some information that I'm
getting so this user is an object model
that is coming up from upright it has
all the information that you are storing
for a user and we're not storing much
we're just storing name and email so
that's why you see that in the place of
name we are saying simply user dot name
we could have done it better in case you
don't like this approach you want to
always show the card then you can check
if user is there then show the username
otherwise show the null very basic
ternary operator you can go ahead and do
that that's basics of it so all right
too much of the basic some values are
hard coded obviously because we are not
taking that data simply then it says log
out button and that's it we are just
doing the profile card so all right so
all of the components are ready and
let's evaluate the situation where we
are right now in the app right so let me
summarize this this will be a super
helpful summary station
first we haven't talked about the app
yet everything here is absolute basic we
haven't touched it this was all the
preparation ground so first we created a
service which is config.ts and before
even creating that config service we
went into the config this is nothing we
are just setting up our configuration
variable which are given to us by the
app right itself once we are done with
this then we simply go ahead and create
a upright config now you can create all
these methods into separate files and
folders but I think that's not a very
scalable approach I want to keep all
this in one file at least the odds1 file
database related stuff in one file and
maybe storage in one file and we can go
with that then we created and worked on
with this so we created couple of types
after that we set it up the end point
and create an account out of this app
right then we simply created a class and
created a couple of methods so that we
can reuse them we created a create user
this is not a original method for
creating the user in upright the
original method is account.create so we
actually wrapped them up as a wrapper so
that our code is more reusable
and then we created a login we created a
log out we created a get user to check
the at least check that whether the user
is there or not and then we created a
log out and all these so it's logged in
to check the user is logged in or not
and get user to get the actual
information after that we worked on to
the context API we don't want to use
Redux or anything so we simply used auth
context provider we created our own hook
which actually gets two values one is
auth status and set auth status set odd
status is capable of manipulating the
auth status and the auth status is all
status it's a Boolean value true and
false then we created a hook based on
this provider so auth context and we
simply says anybody now should be able
to use this context and should be able
to get the data so anybody who uses it
we return the data to it that is it that
is all that we are doing in this one
then after that we created a few
components the most important components
for us were login and sign up there is
nothing too much into that just like we
created the use router we simply also
use the set all status which can
manipulate our status that's it and as
we will be wrapping our other components
in the pages all of my components will
be aware that the state of the user is
logged in or not based on the context
provider so that's all what we have done
here we are just tracking for an event
which is a form event if that event is
triggered we are preventing the default
trying to either sign up the user or log
in the user rest of the components like
logos these are nothing just filler
elements there is literally nothing into
it and similarly for headers and all
this thing there is nothing too much
going into that the next thing is super
important for us that is handling the
app right now I'll show you some of the
interesting things about this app folder
as well there is one more way how you
can create your folders which is by the
parenthesis so far we have seen with the
square brackets but now I'll show you
how you can do that with the parenthesis
and what's the importance of this layout
this layout can be directory level and
for the global level as well I'll walk
you through and we'll show you that as
well but I think we need a small break
as well in case you are watching in
continuation that's great another
segment is breaking out here if you're
watching in the videos itself it will be
catched up in the next video let's go
ahead and see you there
all right hey there everyone hitesh here
and welcome back to the series if you're
watching in continuation then that's
great uh but in this video we'll try to
finish up and wrap up this project
because there is nothing too much to
discuss and uh discuss in this video uh
we have prepared everything our services
are prepared for app right our
components are prepared now we just need
to do is bind up everything that's what
the thing is but I don't want to repeat
The Binding process as you have seen in
the previous video where we discussed
about how we can make a mongodb call and
all of that I want to show you a
different approach of that otherwise
that would be a repetition of the things
and it doesn't add value to your life
and that's what my goal is add a value
so let me show you one interesting thing
which will be super helpful for you and
again there is no right and wrong there
are different approaches of doing the
things sometimes you find more value in
this approach sometimes you find Value
in this approach more so I'll show you
one such approach maybe there you can
find some of the values all right let's
go ahead and get started with that so uh
this is the directory structure this is
one of the project that we built in the
earlier in this series or in the video
wherever you are so notice here we were
going into the source directory and we
were keeping all the files here our app
directory was important so we actually
went into this the API is the backend
which we kept into users and then we
have a lot of folders inside it but if I
go outside this API is a backend rest of
all the things are front end so I hope
you can imagine as the pages will like
expand there will be so much of these
directories which some of you might get
panicked that hey this is a problematic
structure directly here we are having
our backend organized in just one folder
why don't we have something which can
organize our front end as well uh yep
I'll explain you how you can do that
just in this video that's exactly why
I've opened this up so I'll walk you
through that how we can do that in a
minute I'll tell you that but first this
is a different approach that we're using
we won't be using any middleware or
something because you have already
knowledge of that so I won't be focusing
on that I'll walk you through with a
different approach of how you can do the
things now first here let's take an
example of this layout we haven't
discussed it in much I did created a
video earlier which is not a part of
this series where we discussed the file
structure a lot in details in case you
want that go ahead and watch that live
stream I was discussing that in the live
YouTube video but I'll still give you a
brief approach so notice here this is a
layout this layout is actually right now
inside my app directory so this is
considered as a global layout what is
the layout nothing much more it is a
wrapper this will be a wrapper around
all of the things and which are
happening inside that directory so
notice here in the app directory right
now there is one thing only which is
Page and this wrapper is actually a
wrapper around the page itself so for
example notice here there is a title
here which says create next app so we'll
just go ahead and say that this time we
are not creating just an app so we are
going to go ahead and say create next
and app right app
something like that
and we we're gonna say description is
generated by create next app uh now you
are learning uh learning it on YouTube
so we'll just get that now not only this
what I want to show you is that notice
here this component actually is a root
layout component that means it's on root
level so obviously that's where this is
it accepts children and it renders the
children the whole job of this component
is to do nothing the whole job and idea
is to just render the component but
right now if I just save this and go
back on to my code files and this is how
it looks like but somehow if I actually
want to modify all the pages that I have
I can actually come here and every
single page is going to render this I'll
go inside the body I'll just say hey I
want an H1 tag
and this one is going to say this is uh
all render element something like this
and we'll add some classes so that we
can actually see it much more easier so
we'll just go ahead and say uh we'll
just get a width of 100 we'll just get a
background of a white maybe and the text
is going to be black and the text is
going to be 3XL just basic classes so
what you'll notice now that every single
page has this render element and maybe
we can actually try something more fun
in case you are enjoying these classes
so text Dash Center if I can write that
properly text Center so this is a render
element now no matter what page you go
this element will be present in every
single element and that's the whole idea
behind having this layout now if you
amend anything so notice here we are
since injecting this metadata this
metadata will be presented in every
single page that we have all right so
now that you understand the importance
of the layout it's not like that this is
the only layout that you can go ahead
and create there are other other layouts
also that you can go ahead and create
that and I'll walk you through that how
you can actually go ahead and do that
I'll show you in a minute all right so
what we're going to do is notice here
how interestingly we are going to modify
everything we can just save this we are
not worried about changing things here
inside the app I'm going to create a new
folder notice the syntax of how I'm
actually creating these folders I'll
create a folder I'll start with a
parenthesis not the square bracket
square bracket has a different meaning
and it's a framework everything has a
different meaning in here and I'll call
this one as Pages now in the next JS
still you can actually use this
parenthesis to denote a special thing
for you it will not affect anything
inside the framework itself but it will
help you to organize your files and
directories and folders everything quite
a lot so now inside this pages I can
create a lot of things the first thing
that I'm going to do is I'll create a
page so I'm going to go ahead and say
hey this will be page dot TSX just like
this now why I'm creating this page only
now this is a page which will be saying
that hey what should I log in should I
render this will act as a home page and
I'll show you how it is being actually
done because right now there is no other
page so we'll be actually redirecting
our home page that hey this is the
children I'll do that
now the first thing that I want to do
here is that should I be rendering a
home element or should I be rendering a
profile card because if the user is
logged in he should be seeing a profile
card so for this we'll be using
something like this so first and
foremost I'm going to go ahead and say
use client I'll surely inject some of
the CSS as well that I'll directly give
you I'm going to go ahead and simply say
hey use auth is the one thing which is
telling me whether I should be having
this or not everything is designed there
obviously we'll be needing a react and
that react is going to come up from
react and we'll be importing the profile
card as well so profile card comes up
and we'll also grab the login component
as well
so let's go ahead and say hey let's go
ahead and bring in login that comes up
as a component that's it let's call this
one as const and we'll be calling it as
home this home will go like this and
there we go now I can do conditional
rendering based on just one thing I can
just go ahead and bring something from
the use auth and you know what what I'm
about to build and I'll just go ahead
and say auth status all right now as
soon as I do this now where should I
access this that's that's a big question
if I go ahead and reload this there's
nothing if I go ahead and say slash
Pages which I just mentioned up here
there is nothing so what's the point of
having this Pages if I'm actually not
able to do all of this and we have
created a component right now this
component doesn't return anything but
let's just say for some the sake of
rendering so I'll just go ahead and say
hey return and this will not do anything
I'll just shift it a little
come on not like that
I'll shift it here and I'll say return
and we'll be returning just a simple
home so just like this
and I'll say give me an H1 and we'll be
saying home page that's all and again
you'll be seeing there is nothing
literally nothing so how do I actually
grab anything from there that's that's
the question so let me answer that first
all right so now let's address the issue
which is bothering us so again we have
created all this we are super happy but
one thing is still bothering us how can
I get these Pages this is a million
dollar question right now in front of me
and if you look into the documentation
it's actually a little bit confusing
there as well so I don't have these
Pages that's for sure but also I don't
know how can I actually bring the home
page as home here so this is my home
page I want it to redirect here this is
where the directory structure fallback
comes in so let me just tell you a
theory here again Theory not a whole
hard proof up here so notice here
everything is inside the pages and I'm
not directly defaulting to serving this
page here what if this page doesn't
exist this has so many things right now
all that next.js and stuff like that
what happens if this page doesn't exist
let's go ahead and delete this and try
this out if I go ahead and move it to
trash ah now this page is gone does my
app crash so let's go ahead and look at
the refresh ah my page is hey received a
promise that resolved to undefined lazy
element and all of that so what is
actually happening how this is not
working if I don't have a page it
doesn't really work let's go ahead and
try to refresh but but but here couple
of things here interesting one I'll just
close this and we'll restart this and
there we go we don't have anything so
this is not yet giving us the error now
hit a refresh and this will take still
some time and now the thing is that if
that page doesn't exist we get an error
we know this already now let me just
resolve this error
all right so I'm back after a small
phone call yes things happen and this is
life and this is how we run all right so
everywhere uh we were just trying to
explore that okay we have this home page
we haven't yet exported it so let's go
ahead and simply go ahead and Export
default home so that's nice uh but this
is not going to resolve the problem but
what we have done is a foundational
change in the next JS project which is
everything is dependent on the page uh
this and this layout is also expecting
that okay I'm a rapper but you need to
provide me some children so that I can
render them out and you have deleted
this entire page thing what are you
doing are you in your right mind or not
and that is the reason why nothing is
getting served and nothing is going to
be served here even if you get this page
this page is right inside the pages uh
that's great that's great but there is
the issue of the layout here again after
couple of hit research you'll find that
this error is a little bit trickier
because next year's is still in very
development phase aggressive development
so sometimes you'll get this error
sometimes they're not and all there are
asking is that hey what you're missing
is okay you have this pages but you
should also have a layout inside the
pages as well this is the structure of
what the next GS follows yes layout
inside a layout and there can be one
more every directory can have its own
layout and that that's crazy here and
that actually solves a lot of issues in
here so let's inside the pages I'll
right click and create a new file and
we're going to call this one as layout
what you export method inside it doesn't
really bother you much but the file name
should be layout.tsx just having a
layout is not going to solve the issue
if I go ahead and save this layout but
at least it resolves the issue giving us
that now there is not that much of
problem uh the nexgs is decently happy
but not too happy because it needs all
of this now layouts are exactly same so
you can just either copy and paste this
whole layout or you can just actually
write it along with me I'll prefer to
rewrite it so that it builds some habit
for you now this layout is also going to
be a cloud client layout because I want
to pull in some information this is
everything happening client side I would
definitely need app right service so
I'll just say app right service let's
bring it up here I will be needing some
of the blog from the component to just
display some fancy stuff nothing much
there we'll also be needing header
because header will be every single
place and the way how we have designed
the header in case you forgot that it's
actually automatically uh rendering
Things based on conditions so notice
here
so here it is based on the auth status
our header is displaying either the
profile or signup so header is a good
information that we want to have it now
one of the most important thing that
we'll be bringing here is actually
the auth provider so if you notice that
auth provider this auth provider will
help us to display conditionally whether
we should be displaying something or not
and all of that not only that since it's
a provider I told you that provider
actually wraps up everything and this
layout actually wraps up everything so
this solves our issue that I can use my
auth provider and this provider can send
information to all of my component what
they need there otherwise there will be
prop Drilling and I really don't want
that so I'll after this I'll be having a
react and then two famous guys of the
react which is use effect and use state
will be bringing it up the way how this
layout is designed you can call this
method anything but first let's study
this layout that how this layout is
designed so rest of the things are
pretty boring so after this export
default function root layout this root
layout takes the children and that
children is of type react dot react node
and then we simply go ahead and render
these children this is the basic I
repeat this again probably that was the
first name your function whatever you
like I usually use the word layout
that's a good idea but again the naming
of the file is important not the methods
it accepts children that's one thing
this children is of type react.react
node and then simply you go ahead and
render it so that's what exactly we'll
be doing in this case let's go ahead and
say hey we are going to call this one as
protected uh layout
and protected layout takes a parameter
as children again remember children's
are of type react dot react node so
we'll be giving this type as well and
let's go ahead and say that this will be
of type react Dot
react node I'll copy this otherwise I'll
probably make a mistake so I'll copy
this and we'll paste it up here that's
better
all right that is good enough now let's
go ahead and have it like this this will
complain obviously because you are not
rendering the children you are not
returning the type as well we'll deal
with this error in a minute but first
let's go ahead and grab our auth status
so we'll be saying hey I'll probably use
a tab indentation here
there we go so we'll simply have
that's a wrong one I'll actually bring
in mine so I'll be saying that hey I
need a state which will be auth
auth status that's my variable set out
status and we'll be setting the states
just like this so that's fine I'll also
introduce a loader I probably would love
to have a loader which is more of a a
spinning wheel or something but in this
case I'll just uh settle up with a
simple loader which is just a text a set
loaders initially it's true so that's
okay now before I return anything
obviously as soon as this layout but end
of the day we are calling it as a layout
but end of the day this is just a react
component and react components can use
use effect we'll do that so I'll just
simply Say Hey I want to use the use
effect and there we go I have nothing
inside as a render so it renders only
the first time as soon as this comes up
I want that my app right service should
actually ask that the weather is
somebody is logged in or not and since
this actually returns a promise the way
how we have designed it we can actually
go ahead and say hey Dot then if
actually it results then we're going to
go ahead and say Seth odd status and as
soon as I call this this is going to set
it because notice here what we are
returning this we are passing it on here
so this set auth status is going to set
it up and if it is not then will not do
the catch we'll simply go ahead and run
the finally because anyhow we need this
one in this case we'll set it up false
so if you just call it this is obviously
going to set it up to true in case you
are not happy with this one I will just
go with this otherwise we'll set the
loader false this set auth status is
default false it will remain as it is
all right
now after this we'll just go ahead and
simply use The Return part of it in the
return I'll use this auth provider yep
the value of the auth provider is going
to be auth status and auth set auth
status so both of them are being
provided to us and we'll simply go ahead
and in this one first and foremost we
need to cloth close this auth provider
so I'll just say auth provider
and not like that we'll be having a
slash there we go should be all happy
all right so now we have this one now
inside this auth provider I told you
this auth provider is nothing come on
why are you doing this
escape and hit a tab escape and hit a
tab okay so now what this auth provider
is is a wrapper so it will pass on the
information every single place where I'm
just asking it uh but based on
the loader is done or not we'll be
providing the information so first I'll
check if there is no loader
and not leader
loader and we don't need all status and
stuff we'll just go ahead and put the M
percent Escape that we'll just render an
element what that element is going to be
a simple fragment just like this and
inside this I do have some classes which
will help you to have a proper display
so uh div dot text Dash
primary I'll give you these assets and
some of the files as well so don't you
worry
come on no suggestions div dot primary
just like that and
I'll actually give you directly this so
that actually helps you copy that and
I'll paste this again nothing more there
are some CSS files which actually
include this blog nothing to be worried
these are just the background elements
so nothing much more than that after
this we'll be having this header so just
like this we'll be having
header come on
what is happening
there we go we have this header and
after this we'll be having a simple main
class which will be rendering the
children so that is all what we are
doing
and let's hit enter main class all right
so this was all fancy with stuff so this
whole div is a fancy stuff nothing to be
worried this header is also almost fancy
stuff the Meat part is here the main
which is rendering the children so auth
provider will be responsible that
whatever the children comes up here I
can pass on information and can query
directly the auth provider hey what's
the current value of it so as soon as I
save this now let's go ahead and try to
hit a refresh now notice here we have
couple of errors that did hey elements
are of lazy type there are some issues
with that probably we are not exporting
this yeah we are not exporting the
protected layout so let's go ahead and
do that first
and we'll be saying export default
protected layout so now things should be
different and there we go now we are
having this app right home about contact
and home pages rendering so what we have
learned with this that is the most
important thing and what we have learned
into this is although I don't have a
page.tsx directly inside the main I
really don't need it but what I need 100
is a layout if that file goes yeah the
project is Bonkers but inside the pages
I can have this layout and Pages dot TSX
and this can actually serves as a home
page yeah that's that's a new
information all right let's see where we
are having this issue so this children
why are we having
a property protected layers all right so
I think this is bothering a little bit
shouldn't be bothering that much
let me just quickly check that why this
is bothering us let me quickly take a
look on this
all right got it there are some syntax
issues so it's actually better if I go
ahead and take this one as a structure
so I'll just copy this till the above
this one so I'll copy this directly
these syntax and structures are
sometimes problematic
so I'll just go ahead and copy it here
and there we go and probably we copied
an extra colon and I think we shouldn't
be doing that
and now this is giving a colon just like
this there we go hopefully things are
okay now okay let's check it out
all right so at least uh this is working
and we have so this blog yeah this is
exactly the background elements and all
that so this is what we are having now
so here is the interesting part now that
you have understood this much part now
can you understand that we can instead
of doing this home page we can actually
go ahead and do a conditional rendering
here and that is exactly what we are
about to do so based on this auth status
we'll be doing some conditional
rendering let me just go ahead and tell
you that directly so instead of this
return we'll be pasting this one here so
notice the top part is just nothing it's
just centering the element on the left
side next JS and blah blah nothing to be
worried the whole thing is actually here
this is the piece and this is very basic
minimum we have already discussed in the
previous part of it that if the auth
status is present then go ahead and
render the profile card otherwise just
load the login component that we have if
I save this notice here this is what we
have again we don't have this Global
some of the style sheets are still
missing I'll just go ahead and add this
a little bit in a minute but notice here
this is all what we are having and if
this is what we are logged in let me
quickly check that if I can quickly fix
the styling part otherwise we'll just
move with this one
all right it's not a big issue I
actually forgot to customize some of the
theme elements as well so I'm actually
configuring a little bit of the Tailwind
team nothing too much but I'll still
show you so this is how the project is
looking like because it's not able to
find these primary colors and all of
that I'll just go ahead and do that so
inside this extended all I can do is
actually provide some of the custom
colors that we are using so I'll just go
ahead and wrap this up first and put up
a comma so that it doesn't give us any
error and all I'm doing is setting up
some of the primary and secondary colors
so I'll just give you we actually picked
up the colors from the app right itself
so I'll just give that so that is it and
should be all happy now
save this and there we go so most of the
colors are there uh but yeah I know this
is not the best styling work I don't
want to focus too much on the styling
part so that is it okay let's just let's
just close it right there all right now
that we understand that okay this is
again a cool way of having the elements
and layouts and you understand the
importance of layout there is little
more that we can do with this layout and
I'll walk you through with that but
first what we're going to do is do close
the sign up and all these Pages as well
because there is nothing too much in
that it's actually very basic right now
this is the home page but if I go ahead
and do the sign up that doesn't exist
because we don't have nothing here there
so I think that's the easy part now
let's quickly do that and how we do that
because right now we are seeing
everything is outside of this now inside
the pages I'll create a folder and I'll
call this one folder as sign up
and inside this I'll create a page.tsx
again this is because it's a front-end
page.tsx and there is nothing much into
this one all I have to do is simply say
hey use Client First
use
client just like that and let's import
our classic things uh use auth and all
of that we don't need to import service
here we can just go ahead and work with
the use auth here everything We'll be
asking with the use auth let's also go
ahead and import router as well use
router this one is coming from
navigation
navigation there we go and we'll be
needing react of course so we'll be
saying hey react
and that will be coming up from react
and we'll be needing a sign up component
as well
and we'll be saying give me sign up
component sign up from sign up component
sign up okay now again basic uh sign up
page yeah that's good enough and let's
export this as well export default sign
up in here we'll be first asking that
hey let's give us a router
routers will be coming up from user
router will also be having one more
which is auth status based on this I'll
be rendering the stuff
so I can just simply ask if the auth
status is true then I can simply go
ahead and simply say hey router let's
actually replace the stuff instead of
router.push we are going to replace the
entire page
so router dot replace and we'll be
replacing it to a page
or a URL that is Slash
profile because if the user is already
logged in I don't want to show him the
sign up page really simple there is
nothing much and what you're going to
see I think that is already uh that's it
but
uh what we found out while working on
this is sometimes you want to actually
return an empty fragment why this
because of the layout layout needs
sometimes this to actually avoid this is
the issue which I am still researching a
little bit like how we can do the basics
so again I'm also in a Learning Journey
so please if you find some better
alternative or solution like that just
give me that I'll actually take that
otherwise if the user is not logged in
then that block will not run so I'll
just go ahead come here what I'll return
is just a sign up component wrapped
around it that's all but I have actually
a wrapper so I have actually written
some CSS here so we can simply have the
sign up component here so this is just a
sign up and that's it now if I save this
and hopefully if I go ahead and refresh
this and we have the sign up page there
we go so this is what we built up again
you don't have to worry about the CSS
part even if you have the basic CSS that
is also totally fine
all right similarly we need to build up
a login page as well and a log out page
as well so let's go ahead and build the
login page
we can close this inside the pages we
are having a folder which will be
login
and we'll be having this page.tsx this
is for a lot of people a better approach
again I don't judge people based on what
approach they are following I think this
is all is required so I'll copy this
paste it up there
and we don't need signup we actually
need login in this one
and actually just directly write it
that would be better
import login from login all right const
login page there we go we simply go
ahead and Export default login page
inside this the same stuff will happen
we'll first ask that hey whether you are
logged in or not and all of that so I'll
just copy this it actually makes sense
to copy all of this
and paste it up here so we'll say let's
read this again so router is there auth
status is there if the auth status is
there I want to redirect him to on the
profile this is still on the research
phase if it is not working then
obviously I want to mount the login
all right so the login page is done
what's interesting is that how we are
actually dealing up with the log out
that's interesting because if actually
you see the component part the way how
we have designed it
so in the login also and also let me
show you the login as well
now the login actually Avatar yeah here
it is
if I open up this Avatar component not
the Avatar actually profile card yep my
bad profile card we have this log out
and this is directly a link
so what I want to do is I want to create
this log out in such a way that if
anybody visits this lockout
automatically I have couple of options
as soon as I could have done this
directly here as well that I could have
requested a route could created a method
here but I don't want to do this I will
create a component of logout as soon as
somebody visits slash logout so there
will be a page of logout there I'll use
my use effect hook because I can and
there I'll call my app right service
that hey just do the log out so that's
my flow again if you don't like this
flow simply go ahead and create a method
here that's that's it so how we are
going to do this is create a page for
the logout
so let's right click on the pages create
a new folder we'll be calling this one
as log out make sure you call it exactly
lockout because that's what we have
mentioned in the profile card right
click new file
page.tsx nothing too much in this one we
don't need all of this but I'll still
grab all of this
copy this we can close this we can close
this paste this we don't need to bring
in any components so that is fine but
obviously I know that I'll be using use
effect so it's better to have the use
effect just like this okay
very simple log out page there we go we
simply go ahead and say export default
logout page that's the basic absolute
basic okay now I need couple of things
we need router to push to some somewhere
else so let's go ahead and create a
router
router use router there we go we
obviously need the auth states so we'll
be saying const I need set auth status
because I'm pretty sure I don't need the
status to verify I just want the method
so that I can just do the false here
there we go and I'll simply go ahead and
first return so I don't need to return
anything but since there is a layout if
you don't return an even an empty
fragment it will crash we have seen that
so just giving you Advanced heads up
there all you have to do is provide an
empty fragment and this actually saves
your life
there we go
and yes our team struggled really hard
in understanding that that why is it
crashing then we realized oh that's a
layout it needs to render a react
component and that's we injected uh the
tail the typescript that hey we need
this so yeah just sharing the experience
how we actually build it use effect and
there we go Basics just like this in
here I'll use the app right
are we bringing the app right here no
we're not bringing the app right so we
should be bringing the upright service
where should I bring probably top is
good
app right service now we have this so
app right service you go ahead and just
do the log out we created a method
here is the log out and again the logout
is also a promise so you can just run
the method and once you have this method
you can actually go ahead and use a DOT
then
and if the dot then is there then we can
have a call back so let's go ahead and
have
first let's close the then then we can
have a callback just like this there we
go now inside the Callback I'll say set
auth status to false and router is going
to push you to the home page home page
will take care of itself and that's it
so I hope you understand the logic that
we are doing with the log out super
simple nothing complex there okay now we
have let's check out we have the sign up
happy with this we have log out we are
happy with this login we are happy with
this but what about profile hitesh
that's that's the major question we have
been wondering so far now again
something interesting about this one as
well
now notice here inside the pages I'll
create a new folder notice the naming
convention again I am creating a
parenthesis again yeah parenthesis means
there's a lot of stuff that is going to
happen I'll call this one as protected
so all the pages inside this one are
going to be protected Pages since I'm
not creating a middleware I can go with
the middleware approach as well but
actually a lot of thing can be taken
care by the use context itself so just
like I have used this couple of other
places as well inside the protected also
I can have other pages and all of this
so again you know what's the syntax and
how the structure goes protected the
page inside the protected is not that
important so let's just say I don't have
this one so I'll directly create a
folder I'll say that hey there will be a
profile here which will be protected so
inside the profile I'll create a new
file which will be page.tsx or there
could be hundreds of other protected one
not the TS right click and what is
happening
I want to rename this
and this one will be page dot TSX why is
it not working
page.tsx because it's a component
and this protected itself the most
important thing is this protected should
have a layout
layout.tsx
all right so I hope this is now very
repeatable so you can have as many
protected routes and this layout will be
common for all the directory yes that is
where you actually uh include or enjoy
the directory structure so in the
directory structure we'll be working
through so again remember this uh this
layout will be for all this directory
structure and this layout will be for
all the directory structure at this so
the level actually matters and we have
one more here this layout will be for
everyone so layout inside layout inside
layout yeah we are going crazy with that
but we'll go with that all right so
let's first handle this layout this is
actually a relatively simple to
handle let's go ahead and do that all we
are doing is predicting if the user is
logged in that's okay we'll be rendering
the children if it is not then we'll be
sending email on to some other place
again this is again use client
suggestions no suggestion
no suggestion hate that okay once we
have this client let's go ahead and
first bring the use auth
so we'll be saying hey I'll be saying
give me use auth that will be context
all right I will be needing the router
as well to redirect ah next navigation I
like that import react from react that's
there again we'll be saying const I'll
actually copy paste this time I don't
want to get into the mess of fixing this
so I'll be just saying that hey this is
a product let's name it exactly same
there is no point of changing the name
so let's go ahead and do this there we
go all I thing that I don't want to do
is this whole stuff so I'll be just
closing it like that and we also don't
need to return it like that
I'll just remove everything here that's
it so it's much more we don't have a use
effect here we don't want to do that and
I'll also clean this one as well I don't
understand what status what I have to do
is as long as I return the children this
will be super happy so I'm done I'm done
with the layout but I don't want to do
it like that since this is a protected
route every single page on every single
page if this is getting mounted then I
can check something I don't need
middleware just a simple line what
middleware is it just is a checker you
can inject this is on your own custom
way of implementing the middleware so
what I'll do is first I'll grab a router
so let's go ahead and say hey router use
router and also use our status and
that's it and let's just check it simple
if and else if there is an auth state if
there is no auth State then hey redirect
him onto the login page return this
because crash yeah you get that and in
that case return the children too much
space
and then we can simply have this
protected now that's it the page is
every single page is protected that
that's all I'm saying yeah and now let's
go ahead and try this out save this and
inside the profile we have this page
don't have to write a single line of
code I can freely just say that hey this
will be protected because of the layout
so I'll just say hey let's bring in the
profile cards now and once we have the
profile card let's also bring in the
link we'll be needing that this will be
from next link okay and let's also
import react
from come on suggestion from react and
we'll be having a profile
command suggestions no suggestion the
app profile page just like this export
this as well export default profile page
in here whatever you want to display you
can just go ahead and display that I
know that I I'm not going to be
bothering you with much of it
I have told you the concept now you
display here the Account Details you
display the profile card whatever you
want you can just go ahead and do that
we are also not doing a drilling we are
just getting a profile card
and we are getting the information
directly in the component itself so
whatever that is we can actually bring
it up here and that's the magic that's
coming up here and now let's see if I
can actually visit the profile so
instead of the sign up let's try this if
I go ahead and say Hey I want to visit
uh profile
no I don't I don't visit it because
I am redirected back to the login so
that is what is now this is again a
different way of understanding and
learning let me summarize this because
this is again a really really
interesting take on the next JS I'm
super happy about it uh but let me show
you and walk you through with that so
how this entire thing happened and how
this is all working so we learned that
if we don't even have the pages we can
still make the layout of the next JS
work but what's more important than the
pages is the layout because layout is
the thing which is rendering everything
and it needs something to actually
display that's what the whole goal is
what approach we are using here inside
the app is we were worried that if we
will have too many of the front-end page
that might get scary uh scattered here
so now our API can have dot app can have
dot API and there we can write the
backend logic if we have if we don't
have it we can create a pages with the
parenthesis this doesn't need to have
its own page itself we can have and can
just be worried about the layout itself
so inside the pages we created this
layout which is the most important thing
and inside this we have this page here
and now this page is conditionally
rendering this layout is effective on
all the pages that we are having all
right so this is what the directory
structure means in one Pages we will
have just one layout and this will be
rendered in all the pages that we are
having further if we know this we use
this technique inside the protected as
well that hey again a directory
structure that means inside this also I
can have one more layout and in this
layout I have checked it so before
rendering any component I'm checking
this out so this is another approach in
case you don't want to have this
middleware or the back end or anything
related to the back end you can simply
check this with the component level as
well because end of the day this is
react this is how we used to do this
react so there are different approaches
there is no right and wrong whichever
feels good to you you use that whichever
your company says hey this is better
approach use that I've walked you
through with the cases of middleware as
well I've worked you with the cases of
context API as well in case you need
something more just let me know I'll
present that scenario as well in case
you want to have a research or a
discussion with me hey which one is
better which scenarios are good for
which one we can do that in our Saturday
live surely but I think this is it
and I'll also push this entire source
code in my GitHub repository as well so
that you can see this all of that that's
basic and again if there is a small bug
or something like that I'll definitely
go ahead and tweak that out as well but
majorly whatever I wanted to share with
you I've done that so I think that's a
good start of uh there's a really lot in
depth start of the react.js and we are
just talking about authentication how
amazing is that really I'm enjoying this
teaching part so I hope you understand
the efforts as well that we are putting
in so a subscribe is kind of you can get
that you can give that that is it for
this video I hope you have enjoyed that
and let's go ahead and catch up in
another such video
all right so you have gone through with
a really really long course I don't know
how many of you will be reaching into
this section or this portion of the
video a really long video but the good
news is now your basics of nexgs is
absolutely Rock Solid you understand
every portion of it how we are dependent
on the client side how we can do
everything on the server side but of
course there are use cases where we
actually can use some of the just the
client side just the server side or mix
of it incremental updates and all of
that for this we need to create more
tutorials and obviously I'll be doing it
I'm already planning to create more
tutorials which uses nexjs and show you
some of the use cases we're already
trying to build some of the Clones which
are not just the look wise clone like
Amazon or something their functionality
clones so complex functionalities are
being included I'm already working on
that since these videos take time so
obviously I'll work a little bit more on
to this then recording process will
begin but rest rest assured that I will
be bringing up more tutorials on next JS
and some more stuff as well just like we
always do so thank you so much here
spend so much time with me I hope you
have enjoyed this and I'm pretty sure
that I was able to add some value to
your life that was the goal and if I was
able to successfully do that then drop
me a note on Twitter Instagram threads
yeah that's the new one just drop me a
tank note and that will be my piece from
your side that's it so let's go ahead
and catch up in another such video